MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BATES.
BELL. FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CALIENDO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
THERE ARE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GROVE [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MONNING.
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible] TO TINO
[inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN -- BURKE Y. CASKEY
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR DERIVED SO.
AS WE BEGIN THE STATE.
WE CENTER OURSELVES IN A POEM BY
TEN A FULL.
IT ONLY TAKES A REMINDER TO
BREED.
A MOMENT TO BE STILL.
AND JUST LIKE THAT.
SOMETHING INNER SETTLES SOFTENS.
MAKES SPACE FOR IMPERFECTION.
THE HARSH VOICE OF JUDGMENT
DROPS TO A WHISPER.
AND WE REMEMBER AGAIN.
THAT IFE IS NOT A RELAY RACE.
BUT WE WILL ALL ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
THAT WAKING UP TO LIVE IS WHAT
WE WERE BORN.
FOR AS MANY TIMES AS WE FOR
GUESTS.
CATCH OUR SELVES CHARGING FOR
ROUTINE WITHOUT EVEN KNOWING
WHERE WE'RE GOING.
THAT MANY TIMES WE CAN MAKE THE
CHOICE TO STOP. TO BREATHE.
AND TO BE.
AND WALKS SLOWLY INTO THE
MYSTERY.
GRACIOUS GOD.
WE TRUST THOSE WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
OUR GOALS.
BY WALKING SLOWLY INTO THE
MYSTERY OF OUR LIFE A MAN.
THIS IS A BROTHER'S HAND OVER
HEART.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
ONE NATION -- IT IS A SIMPLE.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE'RE
GOING TO PASS THAT TEMPORARILY.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
THERE ARE NONE.
SO SENATORS WERE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE.
MOVING ON TO SECOND READING FILE
THERE ARE TWO ITEMS.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY TWO AND SENATE
BILL.
THREE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS.
ITEM NUMBER THREE ON A ON OUR
AGENDA SENATOR WELLS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE IS A
CONFIRMATION OF A SHOW MINOR TO
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS.
MISS MINOR SERVICE OF PAROLE
COMMISSIONER SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN PARTY THAT
SHE SPENT ALMOST THIRTY YEARS
WORKING INNER NUMEROUS ROLES AT
CDC ARE INCLUDING AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
ADMINISTRATOR AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
SHE WAS APPROVED ON A BIPARTISAN
VOTE IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MAY FIFTEENTH.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
IS THERE ANY COMMENT OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
SAYING.
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I CARILLO HI.
BY JANE [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NUMBER.
IOWA CASKEY I WINNER.
HI WILK HI [inaudible]
WELL.
WELL WILL MOVE THE CALL.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE ON ON THE AGENDA
[inaudible]
SENATOR WELLS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR FELIX
YET. FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA DR
YEP IS A POSITION THAT HAS
SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN HE'S ALSO
A CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF UROLOGY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
KECK SCHOOL OF MEDICINE HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MAY FIFTEENTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE ANY MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
THING MAN MISTER SECRETARY THERE --
PLEASE [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASE [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
GLAZER.
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible] FOR
TITLE [inaudible]
YEAH.
HI JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
HI NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY -- BURKE.
OUR COUNTY BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
WILK MOVES A CALL [inaudible]
BUT FOR MEMBERS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
PLEASE RECOGNIZE OUR NEW
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S CHAD.
BIANCO AND HIS EXECUTIVE TEAM
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR COMING
TO THE SENATE TODAY.
THANK YOU TO THE FOR THEIR
WELCOME TO THE SENATE CHAMBER
.
SENATORS ARE MOVING ON TO SENATE
THIRD READING WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON ITEMS SIX THROUGH ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR SO WILL
BEGIN ON THE FILE WITH ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE SENATOR HERTZBERG ARE YOU
READY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO EMERGENCY SERVICES.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE FLANK
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM PRESIDENT SP A FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT WILL REQUIRE EMERGENCY
DISPATCH SERVICES TO BE
COORDINATED BY GOVERNMENT.
EXCEPT UNDER VERY VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT DECIDES OTHERWISE
WITHIN THEIR LOCAL A PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS -- THIS IS BEEN
A SOMEWHAT OF A CHALLENGE WHERE
WE'VE HAD -- ON ISSUES REAL THAT
RELATING TO LIFE AND DEATH ON
DISPATCHING EMERGENCY SERVICES I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THE FINISH.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR HER TIED UP.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES OF
FOR BRINGING UP THIS BILL AND
ALSO FOR WORKING.
WITH ME ON SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE IN MY
DISTRICT AND I ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
MY DISTRICT BEING UNIQUE TO THE
REST OF THE STATE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE IN VALUE -- MY
COLLEAGUE.
EFFORTS TO WORK WITH ME ON
MAKING SURE THAT THIS ALSO WORKS
FOR MY DISTRICT THANK YOU SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
SENATOR HERS [inaudible]
SENATOR BRIDGES.
NO I PULLED.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING THEN.
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
AS FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY THE ROLE PLEASE
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BELL.
HI. FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE -- TITLE BY JACKSON I JONES
[inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I LIKE CASSIE.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS.
BATES [inaudible]
DODD.
GALGIANI.
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIXTEEN SENATOR WIENER.
ARE YOU PREPARED [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
CALL [inaudible]
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR WINNER
RELATIVE TO HARVEY MILK DAY. FOR
YEARS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT -- COLLEAGUES -- TODAY --
IS HARVEY MILK TODAY MAY TWENTY
SECOND I WANT TO THANK MY
PREDECESSOR SENATOR MARK LENO
FOR AUTHORING THE LEGISLATION --
TO MAKE HARVEY MILK DAY A DAY OF
SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF HARVEY HAD NOT BEEN BRUTALLY
MURDERED IF YOU WERE STILL WITH
US TODAY HE WOULD BE EIGHTY NINE
YEARS OLD -- HARVEY MILK PLAYED
A CRITICAL ROLE IN CREATING THE
MODERN L. G. B. T. MOVEMENTS ARE
MOVEMENT FOR EQUALITY FOR
DIGNITY AND TO HAVE A SEAT.
AT THE TABLE -- HARBI STOOD FOR
SO MANY CORE VALUES THAT WE HOLD
DEAR TODAY OF JUSTICE AND
INCLUSION.
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES ARE LINKED TOGETHER
AND WE ALL HAVE A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY TO LIFT EACH
OTHER UP.
I HAD THE HONOR FOR SIX YEARS --
TO REPRESENTS THE DISTRICT THAT
HEARTBEAT REPRESENTED PREVIOUSLY
ON THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
OF HARVEY INSPIRES ME EVERYDAY
TO FIGHT FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND
TO FIGHT FOR OUR VALUES.
HARVEY MILK DIED FOR OUR
COMMUNITY HE WAS ASSASSINATED
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE STOOD FOR AND
WHAT HE FOUGHT -- FOR WE NEED TO
REMEMBER EVERY SINGLE DAY WHO HE
WAS AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
FULFILL HIS LEGACY COLLEAGUES I
ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN HONORING.
AND REMEMBERING THIS GREAT
AMERICAN THIS GREAT MEMBER OF
THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR.
I MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
I BATES.
HI BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
HI COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
HI JANE [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER BY GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI BY HILL.
HI HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL.
NIELSEN.
HI PAN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY HAMBURG.
I WOULD COUNTY.
BY WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
MORE LIKE I ICE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE.
ONE TWENTY SIX SENATOR PENN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THE BILL TO SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACT GOING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS DOCTOR PAN.
THANKS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB TWO LANES TO SEVENTY SIX A
BILL SPONSORED BY DOCTORS AND
FAMILIES.
WHICH PREVENTS UNETHICAL
PHYSICIANS FROM TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF ANXIOUSNESS INFORM PARENTS BY
SELLING INAPPROPRIATE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND DANGER CHILDREN
AT SCHOOL.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX BUT SURE
STUDENTS WHO TRULY NEEDED
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
THAT WILL RECEIVE THEM AND THAT
THE SCHOOL TODAY AT TEN MAINTAIN
TO MEDIUM UNITY TO KEEP THEM
SAFE. FOUR YEARS AGO IN THE FACE
OF THE MEASLES OUTBREAK RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE INFECTED
OVER ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE MOST TO
OUR UNVACCINATED.
THE LEGISLATURE THIS LEGISLATURE
TOOK ACTION BY PASSING SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF CHILDREN TO BE SAFE IN
SCHOOL FROM PREVENTABLE
INFECTIONS.
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN WORKED.
AS OUR COUNTRY IS TODAY'S
EXPERIENCING THE GREATEST NUMBER
OF MEASLES AND FACTIONS AND OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY CASES TODAY.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT HAD A LARGE
OUTBREAK LIKE THE ONE WE HAD
BACK TO DISNEYLAND NOT LIKE THE
ONES ARE EXPERIENCING NOW NEW
YORK MICHIGAN AND WASHINGTON.
DESPITE THE FACT OF HAD SEVERAL
CASES OF MEASLES BROUGHT INTO
OUR STATE BY TRAVELERS.
HOWEVER ARE HARD FOUGHT EFFORT
TO RESTORE COMMUNITY IS BEING
ATTACKED.
BY CANCER.
BY HANDFUL UNSCRUPULOUS
POSITIONS FOR SELLING
INAPPROPRIATE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
FOR THEIR OWN PROFIT.
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN THEY BEGAN
ADVERTISING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
ONLINE AND OVER SOCIAL MEDIA.
SOMEWHAT OFFER EXEMPTIONS FOR
CASH WITHOUT EVER EVEN EXAMINING
THE CHILD.
IN FACT SINCE THAT TIME
CALIFORNIA'S READY EXPERIENCE AN
OUTBREAK WHERE IN UNVACCINATED
CHILD.
WITH SUSPECT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
ACTUALLY BECAME INFECTED WITH
MEASLES AND THEN SPREAD THIS
DISEASE TO OTHER CHILDREN.
THE LOS ANGELES TIMES.
REPORTED ON SCHOOLS WITH MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
RATES AS HIGH AS 50%.
AND MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
SCHOOLS LAST YEAR REPORTED
MEDICAL EXEMPTION RATES ABOVE
10%.
WHEN THESE EXEMPTIONS SHOULD BE
UNDER 2%?
THESE SCHOOLS ARE HEALTH AND
SAFETY RISK FOR THE STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND STAFF AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
UNDER SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
STUDENTS WHO CURRENTLY HAVE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WILL NEED THE
FILE THOSE XEMPTIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THE
EXEMPTION TO REMAIN VALID.
HOWEVER THOSE EXEMPTIONS WILL BE
GRANDFATHERED UNLESS THE STATE
OR COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER
SPECIFICALLY INVALIDATES THAT
EXEMPTION FOR BEING AN
APPROPRIATE.
THAT'S STUDENTS WILL NOT BE THE
LADY FROM ATTENDING SCHOOL
WAITING FOR A HEALTH OFFICER.
DATA ON PHYSICIANS WRITING LARGE
NUMBERS OF AN APPROPRIATE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WILL BE
PROVIDED TO THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH THE BOARD SAYS IT NEEDS TO
INVESTIGATE.
AND PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT.
AND THEN BEGINNING IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YOU MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WILL BE REVIEWED IN
GRANTED BY THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER WHO IS A
PHYSICIAN.
AND PHYSICIANS CAN APPLY FOR
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FOR THE
PATIENTS AT ANY AGE AND ANY TIME
A VALID REASON FOR EXEMPTIONS
AND THAT A FIGHT IS SURELY
TIMELY ACCESS TO THOSE
EXEMPTIONS.
THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
OR HER DESIGNEES WILL ADLAI
EVIDENCE BASED STANDARD OF CARE
GUIDELINES TO DETERMINE THE
VALIDITY OF THE EXEMPTION
REQUEST.
THUS SB TWO SEVENTY SIX SIX A
PREVENTIVE APPROACH TO KEEP
SCHOOLS SAFE FOR ALL STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY THE CHILDREN WHO
TRULY NEED A MEDICAL EXEMPTION
APPLYING A MODEL SUCCESSFULLY
USED IN THE STATE OF WEST
VIRGINIA WHICH BY THE WAY HAS
NOT EXPERIENCE AND MEASLES CASE
AND OVER IT IN A DECADE.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S POSITIONS.
BECAUSE THEY SEEK TO PROTECT THE
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP AND
THE HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IT IS OUR DUTY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM THREATS TO
THEIR SAFETY THE FACTS ARE CLEAR
VACCINES KEEP US SAFE AND OUR
CHILDREN SAFE BY PREVENTING
SERIOUS INFECTIONS.
I STRICTLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU -- MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES FIRST OF ALL LET ME
SAY THAT.
AS A CO AUTHOR OF SB -- TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN I WAS VERY PROUD
OF OF WORKING WITH DOCTOR PAN I
THINK IT WAS A RIGHTEOUS
LEGISLATION.
AND AS A PHARMACIST -- I FULLY
SUPPORT IT.
AND WE HAVE TO HAVE A 95% HEARD --
IMAGES AYE IMMUNIZED --
CONSTITUENCY -- IF WE'RE GOING
TO PROTECT OUR OUR OUR CHILDREN
AND EVEN ADULTS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS
BUT I GOT.
MEASLES AT THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD
AND I WAS PROPERLY IMMUNIZED
CITED NO I NEEDED A SECOND
BOOSTER.
AND I WAS HOSPITALIZED FOR A
WEEK.
I WAS PACKED IN ICE WHEN MY
BODILY TEMPERATUREGOT UP OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIX AND I ACTUALLY
ALMOST DIED -- THE VIRUS -- TACK
MY LIVER AND MY WIFE AND MY MOM
WERE IN THE HOSPITAL AND THE
DOCTOR SAID I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S
GOING TO MAKE IT.
BY THE WILL OF GOD I'VE I MADE
IT.
AND I'M HAPPY THAT.
I WAS ABLE -- TO MOVE ON TO
ALTHOUGH WAS.
TOOK ME ABOUT A MONTH TO RECOVER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THAT --
MEASLES AND CHICKENPOX ARE KIND
OF SYNONYMOUS OF ANOTHER THEY'RE
NOT.
MEASLES IS A VERY EARLY DISEASE.
IT CAN KILL YOU ONE OUT OF A
THOUSAND INFANTS CHILDREN DIED
[inaudible]
SO.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS --
REGARDING SB.
TWO SEVENTY SIX IT MANDATES AS
OF A CHILD NEEDS A VACCINATION
MEDICAL EXEMPTION THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER MUST SUBMIT
A REQUEST. TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND DOCTOR PAN RIGHTFULLY --
DESCRIBES AT THE OFFICER AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH IS THE
PHYSICIAN IS GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT THE CDC GUIDELINES FOR MAKING
EXEMPTIONS -- WHICH TO ME IS --
MAYBE NOT AS COMPREHENSIVE AS IT
SHOULD BE.
AFTER TO RECEIVE THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER WILL
REVIEW THE REQUEST.
FORMAN EITHER APPROVE OR DENY
THE EXEMPTION [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT WHY ARE WE HERE TODAY?
WE ARE HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE A HANDFUL OF POSITIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HAVE ABUSED THEIR AUTHORITY.
AND THEIR POSITIONS [inaudible]
TO WRITE.
NON LEGITIMATE EXEMPTIONS
[inaudible] FOR PATIENTS.
A MAJORITY OF PHYSICIANS THAT
ARE WRITING FOR EXEMPTIONS ARE
DOING IT.
BASED ON THERE.
MEDICAL TEACHINGS AND THEIR
VIEWPOINTS OF OF MEDICAL SCIENCE.
THE DIFFERENCE THOUGH BETWEEN
HAVING THE MEDICAL BOARD.
ENFORCE THIS NEW LAW AS OPPOSED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CANNOT.
SITE A PHYSICIAN THE CAMP.
BUT THERE LICENSE ON PROBATION
THEY CAN'T REVOKE.
THE PRIVILEGES OF BEING A
PHYSICIAN IF THEY'RE OUT
FOLLOWING GOOD [inaudible]
HIPPOCRATIC [inaudible]
BOTH.
SO THAT IS A CONCERN OF MINE I
THINK THE BILL IS A GOOD BILL.
I'M CONCERNED THOUGH THAT IT
SHOULD BE THE MEDICAL BOARD THAT
OVERSEES THIS AND WE SHOULD BE
WEEDING OUT THOSE BAD POSITIONS
THAT ARE.
JEOPARDIZING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR CONSTITUENCY.
THIS DISCOVERY OF VACCINES IS
UNDOUBTEDLY ONE OF THE GREATEST
MEDICAL ADVANCES OF ALL TIME.
AND SECOND OUR STATE'S PUBLIC
HEALTH.
MUST ALWAYS REMAIN A PRIORITY.
BUT DESPITE THIS THE FACT THAT
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX GREATLY OVER
REACHES POWER THE STATE IS
TROUBLING.
FIRST SB TWO SEVENTY SIX BREAKS
THE LEGISLATURE'S PROMISE WE
PROMISE WHEN WE DID SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN THAT.
WE WOULD ALLOW FOR A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION SO THAT A PARENT OR
CHILD WHO HAS LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS CAN GET A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
I GOT A MOTHER.
BUT I SAW [inaudible] FOR DINNER --
TWO NIGHTS AGO.
THAT HAS A SIGNIFICANT IMMUNE
DEFICIENCY [inaudible]
AND SHE HAS EXEMPTIONS FOR HER
CHILDREN THAT SHE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO GET.
IF THIS LAW IS PASSED UNLESS
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS TAKEN.
SHOULD THE BILL MOVE OFF THE
FLOOR AND INTO THE ASSEMBLY
WHICH I HOPE.
THAT THE AUTHOR WORKABLE
CONSIDER HER SITUATION SHE WANTS
TO STAY IN CALIFORNIA SHE WANTS
HER CHILDREN TO STAY.
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS -- BUT MAY BE
FORCED TO BE MAY MAKING -- AN
IMPORTANT DECISION -- IF THIS
GOES THROUGH WITHOUT BEING
CHANGED.
MANY OF US VOTED FOR SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
VACCINATIONS.
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND AGAIN IT'S MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX DIRECTLY
UNDERMINES THE PREVIOUS
DECISIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
MAKES US [inaudible]
LOOK LIKE.
WE'RE GOING BACK ON A WORD.
AND TO ME.
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
WE NEED TO KEEP YOUR WORK.
THIS BILL MAKES ME.
A CO AUTHOR.
TO SEVENTY SEVEN LOOK LIKE I'M
NOT KEEPING MY WORD.
IN AN EMAILS.
I GET ACCUSED OF BEING A LIAR IF
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO AND
MY FRIEND WHO WAS AUTHORED THIS
BILL REPEATEDLY EXPLAINED THAT
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL TO TARGET
UNSCRUPULOUS DOCTORS SELLING
FAKE MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
I APPLAUD HIM FOR THAT.
IF THIS IS [inaudible]
THE CASE.
WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE SHOWING SO?
IF THIS IS IN FACT THE CASE WHY
ISN'T THE MEDICAL BOARD DEALING
WITH THESE BAD ACTORS.
THESE.
INAPPROPRIATE ACTIONS BY THESE
POSITIONS.
WHY ARE THEY NOT HAVING THEIR
LICENSES REVIEWED?
PROBE PUT ON PROBATION.
OR IF THEY DON'T LISTEN AND
FOLLOW.
GOOD MEDICAL PRACTICE GETTING
THEIR LICENSES IN FACT WE VOTE.
IF BAD DOCTORS OF THE PROBLEM
THE BACK OFFERS MORE DISCIPLINE
AND SANCTION.
BUT NOT AT THE COST OF LIFE AND
LIBERTIES OF FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN.
AS A PHARMACIST MY BIGGEST
PROBLEM WITH SB TWO SEVENTY SIX
AT A GREATLY OPENS A DOOR OF
LIABILITY IN LAWSUITS TO DOCTORS
AND THE STATE.
SECTION TO PROVIDE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CREATE AND
KEEP A DATABASE.
WITH A CHILD'S NAME.
IN ALL MEDICAL RECORDS.
IN A SOCIAL MEDIA WORLD WHERE
EVERYTHING SEEMS TO BE MADE
PUBLIC EVEN THINGS THAT ARE
MEANT TO BE MADE PRIVATE.
HEALTH MATTERS ESPECIALLY
MEDICAL RECORDS NOT ONLY DESERVE.
BUT ALSO LEGALLY WARRANT PRIVACY
IF WE'RE GOING TO ASK HER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO GET MEDICAL
HISTORIES.
OF OUR CHILDREN AND WHETHER THEY
HAVE EXEMPTION THEY'RE NOT
EXEMPTIONS REPORT THAT TO THE
HELP HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
I HOPE THAT AT THIS BILL MOVES
OFF THE FLOOR.
THAT THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
WHICH SHOULD NOT BE OF INTEREST
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SHOULD BE REDACTED.
AND IF NOTHING ELSE JUST THE
DATA OF THE EXCEPTIONS BEING
FORWARDED. TO THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH.
I THINK THAT THIS DATABASE THAT
IS BEING CREATED SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX COULD.
VERY WELL BE A VIOLATION OF HELP.
IT'S A GREAT OVERREACH OF
GOVERNMENT POWER IN ULTIMATELY
VIOLATES [inaudible]
INNOCENT CHILDREN'S [inaudible]
PRIVACY [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
SB TWO SEVENTY SIX IS A SLIPPERY
SLOPE PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
THE INTENTIONS OF THE AUTHOR ARE
GOOD.
AND I THINK THAT IT CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED.
BY EMPOWERING THE MEDICAL BOARD.
NOT PUTTING MANDATES
[inaudible]
ON SCHOOLS.
AND RELEASING OUR CHILDREN'S
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
THIS BILL IS UNPRECEDENTED AND A
DANGEROUS INTRUSION.
NOT ONLY INTO THE DOCTOR PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP.
BUT ALSO THE PERSONAL LIBERTIES
OF THE PARENTS.
AND THEIR CHILDREN.
AGAIN WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUE.
I SUPPORT WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX IS THE RIGHT TOOL TO
GET US THERE FOR THOSE REASONS.
I REGIONAL VOTE ON TWO SEVENTY
SIX SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
OF MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE -- AND I APPRECIATE
THE THE COURAGE IT TAKES. TO TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE -- WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE MANY CONCERNS
REYES AND SUMMER LEGITIMATE
SUMMER NOT.
IN FACT MANY ARE NOT.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO STAND
UP -- AND ADDRESS THE THE
ILLEGITIMATE -- MET MEDICAL AND
NONMEDICAL EXEMPTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SOUGHT BY FOLKS OVER THE
YEARS -- BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE.
THE CENTER FOR SACRAMENTO'S
WILLINGNESS.
TO TEMP TO RESOLVE -- SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS AROUND FAMILY
MEDICAL HISTORY.
AROUND -- SERIES ALLERGIES
AROUND OTHER VERY.
IMPORTANT MEDICAL ISSUES THAT
HAVE A LEGITIMATE PLACE -- IN
THIS CONVERSATION.
AND NOTING THAT THE CDC
GUIDELINES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
MENTION IN THE BILL.
MAY NOT BE SUFFICIENTLY
EXPANSIVE OR RESPONSIVE.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR UPDATED.
BUT WE NEED.
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
THAT IS STILL IN THIS FRAMEWORK
TO BE SOLID AND DEPENDABLE AND
WORKABLE.
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT.
THE CD PH REVIEW THAT THE BILL
ARTICULATES [inaudible]
IS THE UNWARRANTED INTRUSION IN
A DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE APPEALS
PROCESS THAT IT CONTAINS ALREADY.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY FOR FOR
DOCTORS TO ASSERT THEIR CASE ON
BEHALF OF THEIR PATIENTS.
IT IS TRUE THAT SOME PEOPLE
TRULY CAN'T DEAL WITH.
ARE THESE VACCINATIONS AND FOR
THOSE PEOPLE I THINK THERE IS
RECOURSE IN HERE -- I THINK THAT
THE DOCTOR IS LOOKING DEEPER
INTO.
HOW TO THE CURRENT AND ACCURATE
ABOUT?
THAT LIST -- I THINK IT'S A
TOUGH THE TOUGH.
NEEDLE TO THREAD BUT I THINK
YOU'VE DONE IT TODAY. FOR
PRESENT PURPOSES I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SENATOR BRIDGES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MAY I
POSE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
BE PREPARED FOR SESSION YES
MAYBE SEE.
I HEARD SOME COMMENTS FOR MY
STEAM REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE WITH
A BACKGROUND IN.
MEDICINE AND PHARMACEUTICAL
SCIENCE.
ANY BROUGHT UP A POINT THAT I
WANT TO JUST KIND OF FIGURED OUT
WITH YOU.
IS THERE A REASON WHY THE
APPELLATE BODY FOR THIS WOULD
NOT BE AT THE MEDICAL BOARD AS
OPPOSED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH.
SO FIRST OF ALL I WOULD SAY IS
IS THAT -- THERE'S TWO PROCESSES
AND I THINK WE SHOULD CAN'T
COMPLETE THE TWO SO THERE'S ONE
ABOUT WHETHER YOU.
IN TERMS THE GRANTING OF THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION ITSELF AND IN
FACT THIS IS A PROCESS THAT
ACTUALLY IS BEING SUPPORTED BY
THE MEDICAL.
COMMUNITY AS I SAID THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN KHAKI AFTER.
THAT INTENSELY TAKES A
PREVENTIVE APPROACH NOW THIS
BILL ALSO BY THE WAY ALLOWS THE
PROVIDES INFORMATION TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO CALIFORNIA'S
AGAIN PURSUE THEIR ROLE IN TERMS
OF PURSUING IN TERMS OF BE ABLE
TO INVESTIGATE AND HAVING THAT
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
INVESTIGATE.
THE PHYSICIANS WHO ARE ACTING
UNPROFESSIONALLY IN FACT YOU
KNOW I THIS BILL IS FOUR YEARS
AFTER SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION PROBLEM HAS
BEEN HAPPENING SINCE TWO SEVEN
SEVEN WAS PASSED.
THAT NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS EXPRESSED THAT THEY ARE
CHALLENGED.
IN TRYING TO PURSUE THESE
POSITIONS BECAUSE THE MEDICAL
BOARD PROCESS GENERALLY REQUIRES
THE COOPERATION OF THE PATIENT
OR THE PATIENT'S FAMILY IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A CHILD.
AND THESE FAMILIES ARE NOT
COOPERATING BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
CAHOOTS WITH THE POSITIONS THEY
PAID FOR AND THEY WANTED TO
MEDICAL ATTENTION SO THEY PAID
FOR IT THEY'RE NOT ABOUT TO TURN
AROUND AD MEDICAL BOARD SAID
OVER HERE BY THE WAY WE WANT TO
SHARE THE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING.
ON WITH THIS POSITION WHO IS
ACTING INAPPROPRIATELY FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD ITSELF IS
FRUSTRATED THEY ACTUALLY DID --
THE PLACE ONE POSITION WHO THEY
WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO FIND A
COOPERATIVE FAMILY WITH -- TO
ACTUALLY PUT ON PROBATION THAT'S
DR BOB'S YEARS IN ORANGE COUNTY --
HE WAS ACTUALLY PUT ON PROBATION
FOR ISSUING AN APPROPRIATE
MEDICAL EXEMPTION BUT IT'S VERY
HARD. TO IDENTIFY GET A FAMILY
TO COOPERATE THE OTHER ISSUE IS
THIS CURRENTLY.
THE WAY THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION
PROCESS WORKS CURRENTLY IS IS
THAT.
FAMILY GOES OF PHYSICIAN DAVE.
APPLY A MEDICAL EXEMPTION --
THEN THEY TAKE THEN IT GOES TO
THE SCHOOL THERE'S NO PLACE
WHERE THE MEDICAL BOARD CAN
ACTUALLY GET A LIST OF ALL THE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS UNLESS THE
SCHOOLS TURNED OVER AND BY THE
WAY WHEN THE SCHOOLS RIGHT
INFORMATION THEY DON'T PROVIDE
THE NAME OF THE PATIENTS.
WHO AFTER RECEIVED A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION SO THERE'S NO THE
MEDICAL BOARD IS FORCE THEN TO
SAY WELL WE KNOW THAT THE SCHOOL
SAID?
THIS DOCTOR SO FOR EXAMPLE SAN
DIEGO ONE PHYSICIAN WROTE ALMOST
A THIRD OF ALL THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
FROM FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD IS IS
THAT THEY CAN'T GET THE LIST OF
THE NAMES OF THE PATIENTS IT IS
SO THEN WHAT THAT HAVE TO DO IS
THEY HAVE TO GO TO A COURT SAID.
THAT THE SAY OKAY WELL THE
PARENTS AREN'T COOPERATING WITH
US YOU'RE NOT PROVIDING US THE
INFORMATION -- NOT VOLUNTEERING
TO SAY OH YEAH BY THE WAY THIS
PERSON.
GIVE US A MEDICAL EXEMPTION --
AND AND YOU CAN GO AHEAD LOOK AT
MY CHILD'S RECORDS SO NOW THE
THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS TO GO TO
COURT AND BASICALLY THEN
SUBPOENA NOT.
INDIVIDUAL RECORDS BUT SAVINGS
THAT WE WANT ALL THE RECORDS OF
THIS POSITION. TO GO AND SEARCH
THROUGH IN FINE WHICH PATIENTS
THEY GRANTED MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
TO ASSUMING THEY KEPT ACTIVE
RECORDS.
AND THEN -- AND THEN FINALLY AND
INVESTIGATE THAT SO IT'S A
TREMENDOUS BURDEN ON THE MEDICAL
BOARD IN FACT THE MEDICAL BOARD
IS EXPRESSED THAT WITHOUT THIS
BILL WITHOUT THIS BILL THEY ARE
TRULY ON ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY GO
AFTER.
THESE PHYSICIANS ARE OF ACTING
UNPROFESSIONALLY.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PASSIONS ON THIS ISSUE -- I AM I
AM THE FATHER OF TWO YOUNG BOYS.
AND SO I'VE HEARD IN MY DISTRICT --
JUST CASUALLY IN AROUND --
AROUND THE SCHOOL -- FOLKS
EXPRESSING CONCERN.
MOSTLY ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT --
THOSE FEW INDIVIDUALS THAT.
ARE PHILOSOPHICALLY DISINCLINED
TOWARD VACCINATION ARE
CONTAMINATING.
THE LARGER A STUDENT BODY AND
EXPOSING THEM.
NOW I'M NOT A SCIENTIST SO I
HAVE TO RELY ON FOLKS LIKE YOU
AND IN CENTER STONE IT CETERA.
BUT WHAT I'M HEARING FROM YOU IS
THAT THERE IS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLICATION.
AND YOU ARE SEEKING THE FAR
REACHING HAMMER OF THE STATE TO
STEP IN.
AND WOOD I'M I'M STILL OF THIS
OPINION THAT IF WE HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROBLEM DO WE
NEED THE HAMMER OF THE STATE.
OR CAN THIS.
BE LEGISLATIVELY ENHANCED AND
STILL KEEP IT -- WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
AND IT SOUNDS OF FIGHTING THEIR
SUPPORT [inaudible] FOR THIS.
THAT IS OPPOSITE THAT DIRECTION.
IT'S A QUESTION OR DO YOU WANT
ME TO ANSWER OR NOT IT IS THAT'S
A QUESTION NO ANSWER IF IT'S NOT
A QUESTION AND I WILL.
CLOSE I'LL LEAVE IT AS AS IT
OKAY THANK YOU FOR ANSWER MY
QUESTION.
VERY GOOD.
SENATOR MORE LOCKED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS THAT
HAS GENERATED AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF CONTACTS TO MY OFFICE
EMAILS PHONE CALLS CERTAINLY
SEEN AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
WONDERFUL.
PEOPLE COME TO THE CAPITAL AGAIN --
LOOK AND LONG LINES TO EXPRESS
THEIR CONCERN SO FOR ALL OF THEM
I SAY THANK YOU FOR GETTING
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS.
VISITING SACRAMENTO.
AND ATTENDING PUBLIC HEARINGS --
I ALSO.
SORT OF BEEN SAID LET'S DO SOME
MORE DIGGING.
IT -- OF SO MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE [inaudible]
CONCERNED.
AND IT SORT OF REMINDS ME OF A
FRUSTRATION I HAVE -- I CALLED A
SAFETY FOR ALL APPROACH.
I IN NEWPORT BEACH MANY YEARS
AGO THERE WAS A MURDER ON THE
BEACH.
AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT OUR
BEACHES IN ORANGE COUNTY WE THEY
THEY SHUT HIM DOWN AT TEN
O'CLOCK -- JEEP COMES BY
INTELLIGENT A TO LEAVE BECAUSE
OF ONE MURDER AND NOW EVERYONE
HAS. TO TO LEAVE EARLY JUST
BARELY GET.
DARK AT TEN O'CLOCK COULD BARELY
GET THE FIRE GOING AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN WE HAVE TO TO LEAVE
AND I JUST.
I JUST WORRY ABOUT ONE BIG
BLANKET ANSWER. FOR ONE INCIDENT
OR SO.
SO I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
NEED FOR VACCINES BUT SP TWO
SEVEN SEVEN ESTABLISHED PROCESS.
FOR ISSUING BALLAD MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AS MANY SINCERE
PEOPLE ARE ALLERGIC TO THE SAY
THE MMR VACCINE INGREDIENTS.
AND THEY SHOULD RECEIVE.
A MEDICAL EXEMPTION AND AND AND
HERE WE ARE NOW LEGISLATING THE
PRACTICE OF MEDIC MEDICINE AND
THAT REALLY CONCERNS ME.
WHEN AS THE SENATOR FROM TO MAKE
A SAID WE SHOULD WE SHOULD
PUNISH THE WRONGDOERS
[inaudible]
SO.
AND WE SHOULD DO THAT THROUGH
THE EXISTING IN NORMAL CHANNELS
NOW I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF SINCE
HIS NAME IS INVOKED THE
PRIVILEGE OF TALKING TO DOCTOR
BOB SEARS I IN MY RESEARCH ON ON
THIS BILL.
I TALKED TO MANY A HE SAYS IT
TAKES IF YOU WANT TO GET A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION THROUGH HIS
PRACTICE IT TAKES AN HOUR AND A
HALF.
OF QUESTIONS IN RESEARCH IT'S
IT'S IT'S A VERY DETAILED
PROCESS AND HE DOESN'T GIVE THEM
****.
**** NILLY -- BUT IT'S A
DIFFICULT PROCESS TO GET.
MEDICAL EXEMPTION SO NOW TO TRY
TO INSERT STATE BUREAUCRATS TO
INTERVENE IN THIS PROCESS SEEMS
TO ME IS AN INVASION OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONFIDENTIAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
THAT WE HAVE A DOCTOR PATIENT IS
THAT SHORT.
IT SHORT OF OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PARENT AND CHILD
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I LOOK AT THE STATISTICS DEATHS
BY MEASLES HAVE BEEN ZERO IN
DECADES.
BUT MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED BY THE
MMR VACCINE.
LOOKING AT THE HEALTH RESOURCES
AND SERVICES ADMINISTRATION'S
WEBSITE.
THERE IS A VACCINE THERE'S A
PAGER VACCINE INJURY
COMPENSATION DATA OVER THE LAST
TWO DECADES FROM 1-989-220-0019
THERE'S BEEN A TOTAL OUTLAY OF
FOUR POINT ONE FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN SETTLEMENTS. THREE
POINT EIGHT TWO BILLION THE
PETITIONERS WITH THE REMAINDER
TO IT TWO ATTORNEYS FOR THEIR
FEES AND COSTS. ONE RECENT
LAWSUIT REVEALED SOMETHING
RATHER INTERESTING.
THAT THE REQUIRED SAFETY TESTING
FOR VACCINES HASN'T BEEN DONE IN
THIRTY TWO YEARS.
WITH MORE MANDATES ON CONCERN
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS.
ARE WE GIVING YET ANOTHER REASON
FOR THEM TO LEAVE CALIFORNIA.
OR NOT COME AT ALL.
CALIFORNIA HAS A SHORTAGE OF
DOCTORS.
WITH ALL OF THE OTHER BARRIERS
LET'S HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON ON SB
TWO SEVEN SIX BEFORE OUR GOOD
DOCTOR STRUCTURE HANDS AND NEW
DOCTOR SELECT STATES THAT
ACTUALLY TRUSTS THE PROFESSIONAL
JUDGMENT.
MISS MADAM PRESIDENT SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
TO FURTHER INFRINGEMENTS ON
PERSONAL FREEDOMS.
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
ON SB TWO SEVEN SIX THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT [inaudible]
SENATOR RUSSELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CENTER PAN AYE I RISE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL.
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON
BEHALF OF SO MANY FAMILIES IN
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT.
WHO MANY OF HOME?
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS. TO THIS KIND
OF YOU KNOW HEALTH CARE AND THE
VACCINATION WHO LIVED IN FEAR IN
THEIR OWN.
THEIR OWN PREVIOUS COMMUNITIES.
SO.
I DON'T KNOW I WAS IN HERE WHEN
THERE ARE OTHER BILL WAS PASSED.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME WE ALWAYS
LOOK FOR FIXES.
AFTER SOMETHING HAS BEEN
APPROVED AND PUT INTO PRACTICE.
WE LOOK TO SEE WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE LAST TWO THREE
YEARS.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
THESE UNSCRUPULOUS DOCTORS.
A IS REALLY UPSETTING TO ME
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
TRIGGERED THIS ISSUE SO.
YOUR COURAGEOUS OF I SAT THROUGH
THAT A HEARING FOR HOURS.
EVERY QUESTION BACK AND FORTH
YOU WERE VERY YOU HAD ANSWERS
YOU'RE VERY DIGNIFIED IN YOUR
ANSWERS EVERYONE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY BRING UP THE ISSUES
AND SO.
I JUST FEEL I HAVE TO SAY THIS
PUBLICLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I SUPPORT THAT [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
APPLE THINGS YOU KNOW I'D LIKE
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CONNECTICUT FOR TELLING US THIS
STORY -- ABOUT BEING AN ADULT
WITH MEASLES AND IT REMINDED ME --
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE WORKING AT
THE SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF Là
THAT'S WHERE I LEARNED TO SIGN
IN WHERE I BROUGHT THIS.
TO EVERYONE'S ATTENTION SO THE
IRONY -- THAT WE USE THAT SIGN
AND I LEARNED IT -- WORKING WITH
STUDENTS SOME OF WHOM WHO HAD
LOST THEIR HEARING.
AS A RESULT OF A HIGH
TEMPERATURE.
RESULTING FROM THE MEASLES --
AND SO I WILL NOT FORGET.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO FOR COMMENT. TO A DISEASE.
THAT WENT AWAY.
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY OVERCOME FOR MANY
YEARS.
I BALANCE THAT WITH THE NOTION
THAT.
TEAM IS THE HARDEST JOB ON THE
PLANET [inaudible]
THE HARDEST.
OTHER THAN OUR GRAMMY NIGHT IN
THAT THEY'RE DIFFERENT.
AND WE HAVE TO RELY.
ON OUR BEST JUDGMENT WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS BEST FOR OUR CHILD
AND CONSOLE.
WITH THOSE WE TRUST.
AND SO WHAT'S DISTURBING ABOUT.
IN MY NOW SECOND EXPERIENCE WITH
THIS ISSUE AS A LEGISLATOR
HAVING SAT THROUGH.
HOURS OF HEARINGS.
HOURS OF MEETINGS WITH
CONSTITUENTS AND NON
CONSTITUENTS.
READING REPORTS LOOKING AT
VIDEOS THAT WERE SENT MY WAY.
IS HOW DO WE VALIDATE THE
INFORMATION THAT'S OUT THERE IN
THE UNIVERSE.
HOW DO WE VALIDATED HOW THE WE
KNOW THAT IT'S SCIENCE BASED?
AN OBJECTIVE AND FAIR.
AND SOUL I HAVE A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR.
COURSE DOCTRINE COURSE THANK YOU
WITH THE SAME QUESTION I POSED
TO YOU IN HEALTH COMMITTEE --
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE DEBATING THE ACTUAL
MERITS OF THE LANGUAGE IN THE B.
L. RIGHT AND THAT WE ARE NOT
DEBATING BASED ON FEAR.
AND MISS REPRESENTATION.
AND SO IF YOU COULD ANSWER FOR
ME.
IF THE BILL ALLOWS. FOR MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS AND THE CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER WHICH THOSE EXEMPTIONS
WOULD BE AFFORDED YES.
THIS BILL CERTAINLY ALLOWS
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS AFFECT WE
WANT TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION SYSTEM SO.
THE PURPOSES BILLS ACTUALLY TO
PROTECT MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS.
AND WHEN A CHILD RECEIVES A
MEDICAL EXEMPTION DAY NEED THE
PROTECTION OF THE OTHER CHILDREN
IN THEIR SCHOOLS SO THAT THEY
DON'T GET INFECTED WITH MEASLES
DEVELOP.
HEARING LOSS OR OTHER THE
QUALITY FROM MEASLES -- EVEN
THAT UNFORTUNATELY EVEN INCLUDES
OTENTIALLY DEATH -- FOR ONE IN
A THOUSAND AND THE STANDARDS BY
WHICH THE EXEMPTION REVIEWED IS
USING AND IF THEY SAID THE
STANDARD OF CARE EVIDENCE BASED --
CDC GUIDELINES -- WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE AMERICAN QUE
PEDIATRIC GUIDELINES INCLUDING
THOSE AS WELL -- NOW SOME PEOPLE
POINT OUT THE FAIRLY SIMILAR
THAT'S BECAUSE THE EVIDENCE
SPACES PRETTY WELL RESEARCH THAT
WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA OF
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER DECADES.
OF USING THESE VACCINATIONS SO
WE CERTAINLY WANT TO BE SURE
THAT CHILDREN WHO NEED MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS WILL GET.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILLS ABOUT
CHILDREN WHO ACTUALLY NEED
MEDICAL EXPENSES WILL GET THEM
AND THEN WHEN THEY GO TO SCHOOL
THEY WILL BE SAFE.
AT SCHOOL AND THAT'S WHAT THE
PURPOSES OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ISSUE [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU -- I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I WANT TO THANK THE
CENTER FROM SACRAMENTO FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE FOR
YEARS I KNOW.
IT HAS NOT BEEN EASY -- BUT
SOMETIMES LEADERSHIP -- MEANS
THAT IT TAKES A PERSONAL TOLL
AND I WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK
THE CENTER FROM SACRAMENTO.
WE'RE NOT JUST DOING -- ONE STOP
AT THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT FOR
STICKING WITH THAT BECAUSE THIS
IS SO CRITICAL FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH.
OF OUR STATE AND I THINK IT IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU -- IF
THERE IS AN ACTUAL MEDICAL
REASON.
WHY YOUR CHILD CAN BE VACCINATED
YOU CAN STILL GET AN EXEMPTION
THIS TEST AN ADDITIONAL LAYER OF
REVIEW TO DEAL WITH THESE
UNSCRUPULOUS UNSCRUPULOUS
POSITIONS?
I ALSO THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS IS NOT
AN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT -- PARENTAL
RIGHTS THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT TO
VACCINATE THEIR KIDS.
THIS IS ABOUT PARENTS WHO ARE
TERRIFIED THAT THEIR OWN
CHILDREN WHO CANNOT BE
VACCINATED.
ARE GOING TO BE EXPOSED -- LAST
YEAR I MET -- A CONSTITUENT OF
MINE -- FATHER WHO HAS A CHILD
IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND HAS A
BABY AND HIS RESPONSIBILITY IN
THE FAMILY WAS TO DROP.
THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CHILD OFF AT
SCHOOL EVERY DAY AND HE HAD THE
BABY WITH THEM BECAUSE ENOUGH
CHILDCARE.
AND HE WAS IN A CONUNDRUM
BECAUSE HE DID NOT WANT TO BRING
HIS BABY INTO THE SCHOOL KNOWING
THAT THERE WERE UNVACCINATED
CHILDREN IN THAT SCHOOL BECAUSE
THAT BABYWAS TOO YOUNG. TO BE
VACCINATED SO THIS IS WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE AND NEEDS OF THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
CHILDREN WHO FOR WHOM THERE IS A
MEDICAL ISSUE WILL NOT NEED TO
BE VACCINATED THEY CAN GET AN
EXEMPTION BUT WE MUST PROTECT.
THE BROADER PUBLIC HEALTH.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN -- MEMBERS A K. A.
ALSO WANT -- TO FIRST SAY THAT
I'M.
HAS THE JOINT AUTHORS ON SB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN WITH THE CENTER FROM
SACRAMENTO.
I AM VERY PROUD OF THAT LAW.
I THINK WE WERE ABLE TO BOOST
VACCINATION RATES SIGNIFICANTLY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN A
WAY THAT -- THAT REALLY HAS
HELPED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE KIND OF
OUTBREAKS THAT WE SEE IN OTHER
STATES.
WE HAVE NOT HAD THE OUTBREAKS
THAT THAT EVICT THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE IN NEW YORK AND WASHINGTON
OREGON.
AT THE SAME LEVEL HERE I THINK
IT'S LARGELY HAVING TO DO WITH
SB -- TWO SEVEN SEVEN IN IN FACT
THEY'RE SIMILAR LAWS PROPOSED IN
OREGON WASHINGTON THAT WERE
ROLLED BACK BECAUSE OF OF OF THE
OF THE OBJECTIONS OF FOLKS --
AND AND IT ALSO THE INTENSITY
AND I WANTED TO POINT OUT I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE --
INTO THE SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO
HASBEEN SUBJECT TO
EXTRAORDINARY.
VICIOUS.
VILIFICATION AN ATTACK -- I'VE
GOT A CHANCE TO TAKE EXTRA TO
LIMIT MYSELF BUT BUT I REALLY I
REALLY IT IT.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
OPPOSED TO WHERE.
HE HAS SOUGHT TO DO YOU HAVE
BEEN VERY RESPECTFUL AND ENGAGED
IN AND BUT THERE ARE A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ENGAGE IN
BEHAVIOR THAT IS IS SO BEYOND
THE PALE.
AND IT'S REALLY DESPICABLE TO ME
AND I THINK THAT THE SENATOR --
HAS HAS HANDLED -- SOME VERY
DIFFICULT PEOPLE WITH -- AND
THEN SOME DIFFICULT THREATS TO
HIS FAMILY -- TO HIS LIVELIHOOD
TO HIS HOME.
HI WITH A LOT OF GRACE AND
DIGNITY [inaudible]
I YOU KNOW IT MIGHT A LOT OF A
LOT OF FOLKS HERE WEREN'T EVEN
HERE DURING THE SP TWO SEVEN
SEVEN DEBATE.
AND DONE.
MY PERSONAL CHALLENGE WITH THIS
BILL IS THAT AYE.
AYE SO MANY TIMES DURING THE
COURSE OF THE DEBATE OVER SB --
TWO SEVEN SEVEN MADE COMMITMENTS
RELATING TO THE GRANTING OF THE
MEDICAL EXAMS AND THE THE
DISCRETION OF THE DOCTOR
ASSOCIATED WITH THE GRANTING
MEDICAL EXEMPTION.
I'M ON CNN NBC.
AND I FACT THOSE MIGHT WOMEN
VERY FIRST BILLS I THOUGHT THAT
WAS WHAT LIFE IS GOING TO BE
LIKE AND I DON'T THINK I'VE BEEN
ANY THOSE.
CHANNELS EVER SENSE BUT BUT THAT
WAS WHAT IT WAS LIKE RIGHT
COMING ROUTE THE GATES WITHOUT
CREEK THAT WILD EXPERIENCE THAT
WE LIVE THROUGH.
THAT MANY OF US HERE LIVE
THROUGH -- BUT I AM ON THE
RECORD SO MANY TIMES TALKING
ABOUT THAT AS A CRITICAL PART OF
SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN THAT I JUST
DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE.
WITH THIS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
PART OF OF SB TWO SEVEN SIX I DO
THINK THE DATA COLLECTION
ASPECTS ARE.
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I I WOULD
PERSONALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO DO WHAT
CENTER PAN IS TRYING TO DO
THROUGH THE MEDICAL BOARD BUT I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND I'VE I'VE SPOKEN AT THE
CENTER PAN ABOUT THIS AND HE
REALLY DOES BELIEVE IN I THINK
HE'S A STRONG CASE AS TO WHY
THAT.
THE WAY HE'S PROPOSE IT IS A IS
A CLEANER MCHANISM -- BUT IT
EIGHT A BUT IT DOES PUT ME
PERSONALLY IN A VERY DIFFICULT
SPOT BECAUSE OF THE COMMITMENTS
THAT I MADE -- THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF THE PASSAGE OF SB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN AND SO THAT'S
WHY I'M I'M LAYING OFF ON THIS --
BECAUSE OF THOSE COMMITMENTS I
MADE.
AND WANTING TO TO STAND TRUE TO
MY WORD -- I I I I DO SHARE THE
CORE CONCERNS ABOUT UNSCRUPULOUS
DOCTORS.
BOB I ALSO THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT DISCRETION
FOR DOCTORS AND I THINK THAT'S
AT THE HEART OF WHAT MAKES THIS
BILL CHALLENGING AND DONE -- SO
THAT'S WHERE I AM WITH THIS BILL
AND AND AND I APPRECIATE IT ONCE
ATTENTION.
SENATOR WAS A JUST A POINT OF
INFORMATION MANAGER IN TERMS OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS HERE.
I JUST WANTED TO ASK -- WHOEVER
CAN MAP PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION
THAT IF THE BILL SHOULD THE BILL.
NOT SUCCEED TODAY COULD THE BILL
STILL BE RECONSIDERED AND
AMENDED.
COULD BE AMENDED ON THE FLOOR
AFTER A VOTE HAS BEEN.
THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS
IF THE BODY GRANTS
RECONSIDERATION YES THE BILL CAN
BE CAN BE AMENDED WERE STILL
WITHIN THE TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU I I JUST --
WANTED ALSO COMMENDTHE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING ON THIS ISSUE THIS
IS A VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE.
AND IF PEOPLE -- THE PEOPLE FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT SAY THAT -- SOME
OF THESE.
DISEASES -- AND SOME OF THESE
VIRUSES ARE NOT DEADLY ASK.
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
NATIVE AMERICANS THAT -- WERE
ALMOST WIPED OFF THE FACE OF OF
AMERICA WHO WHO WHO WHO
SUCCUMBED TO A LOT OF THESE
ILLNESSES -- THIS IS A THESE ARE
VERY DEADLY DISEASES AND THE
VERY DANGEROUS AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOME ABOUT IT.
I I JUST WANNA I JUST FEEL THE
BILL THIS CURRENT BILL GOES A
LITTLE BIT -- TOO FAR IN THAT
AND THAT IT CUT OUT I THINK THE
WAY IT'S WRITTEN.
AND I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE YOU'RE
SPEAKING POINTS ABOUT -- MAKING
SURE THAT THE CHILDREN.
THAT REQUIRE AN EXEMPTION OR
FORD AN EXEMPTION I'M WITH YOU
THERE WANT TO SUPPORT THE BILL
WITH THAT.
I I HAVE A I I THINK I HAVE SOME
LANGUAGE IT'LL LOOK PROVIDE A
LITTLE MORE.
CLARITY ON THAT AND AND BASED ON
THE SCIENCE AND ALLOWING --
CHILDREN WHO ACTUALLY HAVE OF OF
TESTS THAT SHOW THAT THAT --
THEY WOULD.
BE HURT BY THIS THAT THAT WOULD
INFORMATION WOULD BE PASSED ON
TO THE SCHOOL. TO FOR THE SCHOOL
TO MAKE FINAL RECOMMEND --
BECAUSE OF DETERMINATION WHETHER
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE TO ATTEND I WAS
JUST A LITTLE TWEAK IN TERMS OF
THE THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AND
AND THAT'S JUST MY PROPOSAL IF
THE AUTHOR.
IS WILLING TO CONSIDER THAT BUT
IF FOR THE MOST PART.
I'LL JUST -- SEE WITH LOGOS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SENATOR BRIDGES.
FOLLOWING UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTION FROM SAN DIEGO -- I'D
LIKE.
TO POSE A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
YOU MAY -- VERSE.
I WASN'T HERE WHEN A TWO SEVEN
SEVEN WAS PUT FORWARD AND I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF PASSIONS ON
THIS PROJECT -- WITH THEAUTHOR
TO BE WILLING.
TO MODIFY.
OR CONSIDER MODIFYING THE BILL
TO HAVE IT REMAIN WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OR TO BE WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD.
RATHER THAN THE STATE.
BUT AS THE YOU CONSIDER THAT AS
AN AMENDMENT -- WE'LL SEE WHERE
THINGS GO FROM THERE.
SO ACTUALLY WE TOOK US
AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY IN
APPROPRIATIONS TO INCORPORATE
THE MEDICAL BOARD SO THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS A PART OF THE BILL -- I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT -- THIS
BILL IS CRAFTED -- THROUGH A
PROCESS IN WHICH WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD ITSELF.
AS FAR AS WHAT THEY'RE
CHALLENGES WERE WE TALKED TO OF
COURSE PUBLIC HELP THE STATE
PARK PUBLIC HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS IN THE PHYSICIAN
COMMUNITY THAT'S WHY THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AS WELL AS
ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA ME THIS IS
THE PERFECT THIS IS THE
PHYSICIAN COMMUNITY THE DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE.
THAT INCLUDES OF COURSE
INFORMATION FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD TO DO ENFORCEMENT BUT ALSO
A PREVENTATIVE APPROACH TO BY
HAVING THE PARMA PUBLIC HEALTH
REVIEW THE EXEMPTION REQUESTS IN
FACT THIS IS A MODEL IT'S BEEN
USED SUCCESSFULLY.
IN THE STATE OF WEST VIRGINIA SO
THIS WE'RE NOT INNOVATING
SOMETHING THAT'S NEVER BEEN
TRIED BEFORE AND IT'S WORKED
VERY WELL -- IN WEST VIRGINIA SO
THIS IS A PROCESS BY WHICH
NUMEROUS PEOPLE CAME TOGETHER
BEFORE I SUBMITTED THE BILL
KNOWING HOW CONTENTIOUS IT WOULD
BE.
I BROUGHT TOGETHER VERY
STAKEHOLDERS TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT'S THE
BEST APPROACH TO BE SURE WE KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE AND WE ADDRESS --
THE UNSCRUPULOUS PHYSICIANS WHO
ARE WRITING THE EXEMPTIONS AND
THIS IS THE RESULT OF THAT
PROCESS AND SO THAT THAT'S WHY
THE BILL IS IN ITS FORM IT IS
I'M OF COURSE ALWAYS HAPPY TO
HEAR FROM.
MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT -- YOU KNOW
AMENDMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS THEY
HAVE FOR THE BILL BUT I ALSO
WANT OF COURSE WE'VE ALL DONE
BILLS BEFORE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CAME OUT OF A PROCESS WHICH
WE ENGAGE RIGHT PEOPLE LOOKING
AT WHAT'S THE BEST APPROACH TO
THE BILL IN THE PRESS TODAY --
WILL -- FEEL THAT WOULD BE MOST
EFFECTIVE.
AND THAT'S THE RESULT OF THIS.
THING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
BY SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOT A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
DR PAN OF COURSE.
THANK YOU -- MAY I THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED THAT HE CONSULTED ALL
STAKEHOLDERS I'M WANTING I WANT
TO KNOW IF HE CONSULTED AT
PARENTS ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
IN FACT ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL ARE IS APPARENT TO FAX
THE CALIFORNIA AND SO YES
PARENTS WERE CONSULTED.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR PAN YOU MAY
CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE DISCUSSION.
ON THIS BILL -- IS AGAIN THIS IS
ABOUT KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY SAFE
WE RIGHT NOW HAVE AN ACTIVE
MEASLES OUTBREAK GOING ON LEASES
HAPPENS WAS CONTAGIOUS DISEASE.
THAT'S THE ONE WE HEAR ABOUT
FIRST THAT WOULD POINT OUT THAT
IN TWENTY TEN TO GET A PROTEST
THIS OUTBREAK THAT KILLED TEN
INSTANCE AND OTHER VACCINE
PREVENTABLE DISEASE.
WE HAVE OTHER DISEASES AS WELL
THAT THAT'S A THAT'S THE REASON
WHY THIS LEGISLATURE THE ONLY
PASSED SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN BUT
ALSO PASS REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE
IMMUNIZATIONS FOR SCHOOL ENTRY
IT'S THIS LEGISLATURE DETECTED
THAT.
SO IT WAS MADE REFERENCE TO BY
SEVERAL PEOPLE ABOUT TWO SEVEN
SEVEN I FEEL LIKE I HAVE.
TO CORRECT THE RECORD REGARDING.
WHAT HAPPENED TO SEVEN SEVEN SO
IN SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN ACTUALLY
THE BILL DID NOT ACTUALLY
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS?
ACCEPTED AN AMENDMENT THAT WAS
TAKEN -- AND ASSEMBLY HEALTH OF
MY AMENDMENT -- THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION ITSELF.
IN FACT THE HOPE WAS IS THAT.
BASICALLY THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION
PRIOR TO SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN WAS
AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
POSITION THAT WAS NOT A NEW
INNOVATION AND SB -- TWO SEVEN
SEVEN WE WERE HAPPY TO LEAVE IT
THERE BECAUSE WE FIGURED THAT
THE CHILD'S PHYSICIAN WOULD TALK.
TO THE FAMILY AND THEY WOULDN'T
DO AND WOULD PROVIDE.
ACCURATE AND APPROPRIATE
GUIDANCE.
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER SB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN IS NOT?
FAMILIES GOING TO THEIR OWN
CHILD POSITION FACT WE SEEN AND
NUMEROUS OCCASIONS WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA MY
DOCTOR WILL GIVE MY CHILD
MEDICAL EXEMPTION SO I WENT AND
BOUGHT.
ONE THIS IS NOT WHAT WE INTENDED
WITH SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN AND THE
EXISTING MEDICAL EXEMPTION THAT
IS NOT THE PROMISE THAT WE MADE
THAT WE WOULD SAY IT'S OKAY FOR
PHYSICIANS TO PROFIT FROM
SELLING MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FROM
PATIENTS THAT THEY DON'T
REGULARLY CARE.
FOR THAT IS NOT APPROPRIATE AND
THE PROBLEM IS IT'S THE S IS
POINTED OUT IT DOESN'T JUST
AFFECT THE CHILD WHO GOT THE
EXEMPTION DO NOW ISN'T
VACCINATED.
IT AFFECTS THE OTHER CHILDREN IN
THE SCHOOL AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
WHY THIS BILL IS NECESSARY THIS
IS NOT JUST AN ISSUE ABOUT WELL
A FAMILY MADE DECISION FOR HER
OWN CHILD.
IN FACT EVEN UNDER THREE TWO
SEVEN SEVEN THEY HAVE THE CHOICE
WHETHER TO VACCINATE THEIR CHILD
OR NOT IF THEY DON'T GIVE
INFORMED CONSENT THEIR CHILD
DOESN'T GET VACCINATED.
BUT THERE IS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT AND THAT CONSEQUENCES IT
RELATE TO THEIR CHILD REALLY TO
THE OTHER CHILDREN AND WE NEED
TO PROTECT THEM.
SO I WOULD MAKE IT AGAIN I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA -- BASICALLY --
ONE NEEDS INFORMATION THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO IN ORDER TO
DO ENFORCEMENT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO BE SURE
OUR SCHOOLS ARE SAFE.
SO CERTAINLY YES WE NEED TO GO
AFTER THE BAD DOCTORS BUT WE
NEED TO BE SURE THE SCHOOLS ARE
SAFE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND I WOULD MAKE A NOTE THAT --
IN TERMS OF THE SCOPE OF THE
EXEMPTIONS AND WHAT EXETER.
YEAH WE HAVE A WE HAVE
INCORPORATED TO BUILD THE CDC
GUIDELINES WERE LOOKING AT ALSO
INCLUDING SAID REFERRING TO THE
EIGHTY GUIDELINES.
IF THERE ARE OTHER EVIDENCE
BASED GUIDELINES EVIDENCE BASED
GUIDELINES OF PEOPLE WISH TO
SHARE WERE CERTAINLY ALWAYS OPEN
TO LOOKING AT THIS -- I WOULD
ALSO MAKE NOTE IN TERMS OF
PRIVACY -- SO WE TALK ABOUT THE
DATA BASE FOR THE PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF THE HEALTH
ACTUALLY MAINTAINS A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT DATABASES CURRENTLY WE
HAVE A CANCER DATABASE THEY
AFFECT.
STD DATABASE SO AND THEY ARE
BOUND BY THE SAME PRIVACY LAWS
AND SEEM AS A MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT ACTUALLY.
AGAIN THIS IS IT THAT THE VOTE
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD GET AS THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
GET INFORMATION ON A FORM THAT
THEY WOULD DESIGNATE THE
PHYSICIAN WOULD HAVE TO COMPLETE
THE SENATE FOR THE MEDICAL
ENGINE IT'S NOT THAT.
BASICALLY THAT THE THE PART OF
THE HEALTH WITH ACTUALLY ASK FOR
THE ENTIRE MEDICAL RECORD OF THE
CHILD.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTUALLY.
GRABBING THE ENTIRE MEDICAL
RECORD FOR A CHILD THE PHYSICIAN
WAS CERTIFIED THEY EXAMINE THE
CHILD IT WAS CERTIFIED AT THIS
IS THE CONDITIONS BY WHICH WE
ARE SEEKING MEDICAL EXEMPTION OF
THOSE ARE VALID REASONS THAT ARE
BOTH OF THE GRANT.
EFFECT WE EXPECT THAT PHYSICIANS
WOULD BE HONEST IN WHAT THEY A
TEST TO SEE IF THEY AREN'T.
WELL I GUESS THAT'S WHEN THE
MEDICAL BOARD WOULD GET INVOLVED
IN OF COURSE SINCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AS IS
INFORMATION SO WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD.
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT WITH IN
TERMS OF THE ISSUES RAISED ABOUT
PRIVACY THE ISSUES RAISED ABOUT --
THE OUT -- IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
HOW THEM THE TOP PART OF THE CAL
TO TAKE CARE OF THIS INFORMATION
IS SOMETHING THAT.
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE CAN
ALL TAKE COMFORT IN I ALSO JUST
HAVE TO BRIEFLY MENTION THAT
THAT THERE ARE SOME IF THIS
INFORMATION -- SHARED --
REGARDING FIRST OF ALL VACCINES
ARE TO THE THOROUGHLY TESTED OF
ALL -- MATT PHARMACEUTICALS THAT --
MEDICATIONS -- THAT THERE'S ANY
SENSE OF THE INSTITUTE MEDICINE
DID NUMEROUS REPORTS THAT THE
CLAIM THAT THERE'S NO SAFETY.
TESTING OF A FAX SCENES IS IS
AND CERTAINLY A COMPLETE.
IT IS CERTAINLY -- MISINFORMED --
I ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT -- I WAS
REFERRED TO THE MMR SAFETY --
THERE IS BEEN NO RECENT KNOWN
CASE OF ANY DEATHS FROM MMR SO
THAT AGAIN I JUST WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR THAT SPEND -- IS
UPSET WELL ESTABLISHED THE MMR
IS A SAFE VACCINE CERTAINLY
THERE ARE CONTRA INDICATIONS AND
THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE GUIDELINES
SO I JUST WANNA BE SURE WE
CORRECT THE RECORD THERE I WANT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
QUESTION I STRICTLY AS FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
JAPAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible] FIVE PORCHES
[inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BYE BYE CASKEY.
BY WIENER.
HI WILK.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
ROTH. FIVE TWENTY FOUR NO TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
SHE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ITEM.
WHICH IS NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY SEVEN ON OUR AGENDA
[inaudible]
SENATOR GLAZERS.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN MESSENGER
GLAZER AND HAPPILY INTO
EDUCATION FINANCE.
BETTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS ANOTHER
EASY BILL TO CONSIDER TODAY.
SB FOURTEEN WOULD AUTHORIZE AN
EIGHTY BILLION DOLLAR BOND ON
THE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT.
FOR FACILITIES AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN MORE THAN A DECADE
SINCE CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO DEDICATE FUNDS TO
BUILD AND REPAIR.
HIGHER EDUCATION CLASSROOMS
RESEARCH LABS IN LIBRARIES
ACROSS OUR STATE.
AND THERE'S BEEN NO HIGHER
EDUCATION SPECIFIC BOND PASS
SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO ACCORDING TO
BOTH SYSTEMS OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THEY HAVE COMBINED CAPITAL NEEDS
EXCEEDING SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM
PROJECTS.
WE ALL KNOW HOW VITAL OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ARE TO
OUR CALIFORNIA'S.
ECONOMY.
STUDENTS NEED TO BE EQUIPPED
WITH CLASSROOMS LIBRARIES AND
LABS THAT ARE GOING TO PREPARE
THEM AND US. FOR OUR FUTURE.
AND VOTERS SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
CHANCE TO CONTINUE THE PROUD
LEGACY OF MAINTAINING.
AND IMPROVING OUR UNIVERSITIES
AND COLLEGES AND WITHOUT MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
SENATOR BRIDGES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
WANT -- TO COMMEND -- THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL -- I AM.
A CO AUTHOR I'M PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR -- I THINK -- THE EQUAL
DISTRIBUTION BETWEEN THE UC IN
THE CSU SYSTEM I'M PROUD -- TO
TO HAVE -- MULTIPLE UNIVERSITIES
IN OR AROUND MY DISTRICT HI AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF OUR
OF HIGHER EDUCATION CANNOT BE
UNDERESTIMATED.
AND I KNOW THAT -- IN A PERFECT
WORLD WE WOULD NOT BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS LIKE THIS -- WOULD BE PUT
FORWARD THROUGH A BOND -- BUT IN
THAT THERE BE OTHER MEANS
AVAILABLE.
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE SUBSTANTIALLY
SO GREAT THAT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY OTHER WAY -- FORWARD
BUT IT AS A WORD OF OF
ENCOURAGEMENT TO THE AUTHOR --
IN ACTUAL POSE A QUESTION TO IF
IT'S OKAY MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR GLAZERS YEAH YES YOU MAY
PROCEED HOW WILL THE
UNIVERSITIES YOU SEE OR SEE
ISSUE PRIORITIZE WHERE THE
FUNDING GOES.
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY I WILL BE
ADVOCATING FOR FRESNO STATE FOR
EXAMPLE -- SO I WANT TO MAKE I
WANT TO FIND OUT -- IS THERE A
CALCULATION WARS -- FORMULA --
WITHIN THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS ON
WHICH INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS WE
GET PRIORITY.
THANK YOU LIVE TO THE SENATOR
FROM PRESS THE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CO AUTHORSHIP OF THIS
MEASURE.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT BOTH
SYSTEMS HAVE -- FIVE YEAR
CAPITAL OUTLAY -- PLANS THAT
THAT EACH JOB GOVERNING BOARD --
DEVELOPS AND HERE'S THROUGH
PUBLIC -- HEARING PROCESS IS THE
BILL SYSTEMS HAVE TO RECEIVE
INPUT FROM ALL STAKEHOLDERS
HOLDERS INCLUDINGTHE CAMPUSES.
AND THAT OUT OF THAT PROCESS
THEY IDENTIFY PROJECTS THAT FIT
WITHIN THAT. FIVE YEAR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PLAN I SHOULD THIS
MEASURE OF BE PASSED A HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND BY THE
VOTERS I CERTAINLY WOULD
STIMULATE THAT EFFORT -- TO GO
BEYOND THE THAT THE THE NARROW
SCOPE FOR PROJECTS THEY FELT
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY BE FUNDED
IN FIVE YEARS.
TO I'M SURE AT EXTEND THE ROBUST
CONSULTATION PROCESS THAT BUILT
THERE KNOWN.
FOR AND SO I WOULD -- WOULD BE
MY EXPECTATION THAT.
YOURSELF AND SUPPORTERS OF
FRESNO STATE IN THE OTHER
UNIVERSITIES WOULD HAVE A EQUAL
AND AMPLE OPPORTUNITY -- TO
ENCOURAGE SUPPORT FOR THEIR
THEIR ACUTE NEEDS THAT THEY'RE
FACING.
THANK YOU HI STROLLING VIRGIN
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR MOORLACH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I AM -- COLLEAGUES I'M A PROUD.
THE ISSUE GRADUATE.
IN FACT -- CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
LONG BEACH RECOGNIZE ME IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AS THE ALUMNI OF
THE YEAR.
FROM ITS COLLEGE OF BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE WAS A HONORED TO HAVE
GEORGIAN GLORIA GLORIA
DEUKMEJIAN AT THE DINNER.
SITTING RIGHT THERE WILL BE --
WHAT I ACCEPTED THE HONOR?
I AM PROUD TO HAVE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE IN MY THIRTY
SEVEN DISTRICT.
YOU SEE I COMMEMORATED THEIR
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY RECENTLY I
PARTICIPATED THAT CELEBRATE TORY.
DINNER WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER AND
YOU SEE I WAS BRAND NEW.
IT WAS LIKE I WANT TO GO THERE
IS SUCH A BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS IN
THE HILLS. FOR MUCH DIFFERENT
NOW WITH ALL THE INFILL AND ALL
THE TREES GROWING BUT COLLEAGUES --
I FULLY APPRECIATE UNDERSTAND
THE EFFORT TO BAR AND BUILD.
BUT I HAVE.
A FEW CONCERNS ABOUT THIS NUMBER
THEM IF I COULD MADAM PRESIDENT
NUMBER.
ONE THE GENERAL FUND WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL FIX COST.
WHAT WILL WE CUT? TO ACCOMMODATE
THIS REQUIRED BUDGET ALLOCATION.
TO THE TOTAL INTEREST COST IS
ANTICIPATED TO BE FIVE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
I APPRECIATE.
PAYING THE BOND HOLDERS.
BUT PAYING CASH WOULD REDUCE THE
OVERALL COSTS BY SEVENTY ONE
POINT 25% [inaudible] THREE THEN
THERE IS OUR CREDIT RATING.
WERE THIRD FROM THE BOTTOM. FOR
THE TEN MOST POPULOUS STATES
WITHIN THE STAFF REPORT DID YOU
BEEN PROVIDED. FOR DEBT TO
PERSONAL INCOME WERE ALSO THIRD
FROM THE BOTTOM. FIVE THE DEBT
PER CAPITA ALSO THIRD FROM THE
BOTTOM. SIX DEBT AS A PERCENTAGE
OF STATE GROSS DOMESTIC PRODUCT.
ALSO THIRD FROM THE BOTTOM WE
ARE NOT IN GOOD SHAPE MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANK GOODNESS FOR NEW YORK IN
ILLINOIS.
IF OTHERWISE BE A BB LAST.
BUT I DIDN'T COME THE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO BECOME ILLINOIS.
EIGHT CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT OF ALL
FIFTY STATES CURRENTLY IT'S A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT POINT
FIVE BILLION AS OF JUNE. THIRTY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT IS TODAY
MARCH MAY TWENTY SECOND.
AND WE STILL HAVE NOT RECEIVED
THE COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT FOR THE YEAR
ENDED JUNE.
THIRTY EIGHTEEN M. WHAT WILL
PROBABLY FIND IS THAT THE
CONTROLLER HAS TO ADD ARE
UNRESTRICTED AND GIVE ME.
ARE -- RETIREE MEDICAL ARE UNDER.
PAID RETIREE MEDICAL LIABILITY
THAT IT.
WAS NINETY ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION AS OF LECTURE SHE'S COME
OUT WITH A LETTER THE LAST WEEK
OR SO SAYING IT'S DOWN TO MAYBE
EIGHTY SIX BILLION.
BUT YOU ADD THAT TO THE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE BILLION AND WE
ARE. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION
WITH AN UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT
WHERE A QUARTER TRILLION DOLLARS.
NINE WE'VE BEEN THROUGH
RECESSIONS BAT BOND PAYMENTS ARE
FIXED COSTS YOU WILL HAVE TO PAY
THEM THEY ARE NOT VARIABLE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT GOES ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK.
AND THEN IT WILL BE THE TIME
WHEN THE TAXPAYERS WILL SAY WHY
DID YOU PUT THAT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS BOND MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY THEY
PASSED 90% OF THE TIME
[inaudible]
SO COLLEAGUES.
I'D I'D.
I APPRECIATE THE GOOD BECAUSE
I'M A BENEFICIARY OF THE CSU
SYSTEM.
BUT COLLEAGUES WE'VE GOT TO FIX
OUR BALANCE SHEET.
WE'VE GOT TO GET FROM THIRD AT
THE BOTTOM.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
AND WE'VE GOT TO START REALLY
LOOKING AT OUR FINANCES.
SO I ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE.
ON SB FOURTEEN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR ON
MEMBERS ARE RISING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL AYE AYE
ACTUALLY HEAR THE CONCERNS OF
THE CENTER FROM ORANGE COUNTY I
THINK THEY OUGHT TO BE TAKEN
ACCOUNT AND ENGAGE WITH BY.
BY THAT THE LEAD AUTHOR --
HOWEVER I WILL SAY THAT -- THAT.
THAT IF YOU CAN FIND THE RIGHT
TERMS.
YEAH IT'S IT'S THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE PRECISELY BEST
SUITED. TO BE HANDLED BY A BOT.
ULTIMATELY IT'S THE STUDENTS OF
THE FUTURE WHO WILL MOST BENEFIT
FROM THE NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURAL
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL HAPPEN AS
A RESULT.
OF THIS -- THIS THIS BILL AND
AND BOND IF IF IF APPROVED.
OBVIOUSLY THERE WILL BE INTENSE
DISCUSSIONS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
A LEVEL THE PART OF FINANCE --
WITH THE WITH THE UNIVERSITIES
AND WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ENSURE THAT IF
WE DO MOVE FORWARD THIS WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING SO -- SO AS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE THE
ABSOLUTE BEST TERMS IN PLACE.
BUT IN THE END OF THE DAY WE
HAVE ENORMOUS INFRASTRUCTURAL
DEFICITS AT THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL
RIGHT NOW AND IF YOU LOOK AT
WHERE WE WANT TO GO WHERE WE
NEED TO GO AS A STATE.
MOVING FORWARD INTO THE ECONOMY --
IT INTO INTO THE INTO THIS
UNCERTAIN FUTURE WE HAVE TO DO
BETTER IN TERMS OF FACILITIES
AND UNMET NEEDS AT THE CAL STATE
AND YOU SEE.
IT ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IT IF IF
ANY OF YOU LIKE A LITTLE BIT OF
OF A OF A INFRASTRUCTURE ONE OH
ONE WITH THE GUYS UNIVERSITIES
WILL BE HAPPY.
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH THE
INFORMATION YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT AN ENORMOUS NEED
THERE IS OUT THERE FOR HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
SO I I I THINK THIS IS A WELL
CRAFTED BOND HI I HEAR THE
CONCERNS AND I THINK THEY OUGHT
TO BE ENGAGED IN AND AND
DISCUSSED AND TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT.
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING THE BEST BANG FOR
OUR BUCK FOR FUTURE TAXPAYERS
BUT IT'S STILL FUTURE TAXPAYERS
IT WILL BEGIN THE BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE IMPROVEMENTS
MADE ON OUR CAMPUS AS A RESULT
OF THE PASSAGE OF THIS BOND.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO
SUPPORT AND I I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE [inaudible]
SENATE BILL.
YES I BELIEVE THAT WE OUGHT TO
RETAIN OUR STATUS -- SAW A TOP
NOTCH PUBLIC UNIVERSITY AND
COLLEGE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA AND
REALLY THE ONLY WAY WE CAN DO
THAT.
IS TO KEEP OUR BUILDINGS UP HE
AND REPAIR AND REHABILITATION
AND ALSO EXPAND.
THE UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE GROWING
POPULATION A CALIFORNIA AND ARE
GROWING ECONOMY RIGHT NOW -- IN
MY AREAS SILICON VALLEY -- THEY
CANNOT FIND ENOUGH TRAIN PEOPLE
TO WORK IN THE HIGH TECH
INDUSTRY IF THAT CONTINUES LONG
TERM.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A PROBLEM IN
TERMS OF KEEPING THOSE COMPANIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO PART OF IT IS TO IMPROVE AND
EXPAND.
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY AND
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
HAVING A GOOD PUBLIC UNIVERSE IN
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
WITH -- SUFFICIENT BUILDINGS TO
TO TRADE EDUCATE.
OUR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS IS
ESSENTIAL IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
IS MUCH OPPORTUNITY AS WE CAN
THE PEOPLE THAT DESERVE.
AND AND SHOULD BE GOING TO OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW.
WE HAVE A SHORTAGE A SHORTAGE OF
OF SPACE AND A SHORTAGE OF
CLASSROOMS -- PROFESSORS -- AT
OUR UNIVERSITY COLLEGE WE NEED
TO EXPAND THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA IF WE DON'T PASS
BONDS TO REPAIR.
OUR UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WE'RE NOT
GOING TO EXPAND WORK ON A
CONTRACT OUR SYSTEM AS THE
BUILDINGS -- START TO
DETERIORATE -- AND FALL APART AT
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY.
THEY GOT MANY OF THE CLASSROOM
BUILDINGS AS STUDENTS ARE -- AND
THEY GO BACK TO THE NINETEEN
FORTIES AND NINETEEN FIFTIES AND
HAVEN'T BEEN -- REPAIRED THE
SETS AND THEY NEED TO BE
REPLACED AND AND REHABILITATED
SO I I'M URGES STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS -- BOND MEASURE AND I
THINK IT WILL HELP THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND A HELP OR
ARE COLLEGE BOUND STUDENTS THAT
NEED TO HAVE.
A SLOT IN THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CENTERS I'VE BEEN ASKED -- TO
PLEASE ASK YOU TO KEEP THE
VOLUME DOWN IT'S GETTING A
LITTLE BIT NOISIER IF YOU COULD
TAKEIT. TO THE BACK OF THE ROOM
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED
SENATOR NIELSEN.
THAT A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN SAID I RISE IN SUPPORT.
IT IS A MATTER OF PRIORITY NOW
HISTORICALLY.
HIGHER END AND K. TWELVE BONDS.
WE'RE PREFERRED AND THEY WERE
THE ONES THAT PASSED.
THE ONES THAT WERE MOST RELATED.
OVER DECADES MANY MANY OTHER
[inaudible]
NEEDS AND DEMANDS.
WERE EFFECTED THROUGH BOUGHT
[inaudible]
THE CREATED.
THE PROBLEM THE THE CENTER FOR
MORTGAGE COUNTY SO.
WELL ARTICULATED WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
IS DEVELOPED AGAIN OVER DECADES.
BUT I WOULD LOOK FORWARD.
SOME OF THAT NEEDS TO BE UNWOUND.
AND WE CANNOT KEEP PASSING BONDS
BUT AS WE DO SO.
WE SHOULD DO SO WITH PRUDENCE
[inaudible]
AND PRIORITY.
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT THESE
HIGHER READ BONDS [inaudible]
ARE INDEED.
A PRIORITY. TO MAINTAIN THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION.
THAT'STHE ISSUE.
AND YOU SEE.
SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES ARE VERY
SPECIAL.
IN THAT THEY HAVE RETAINED
STRUCTURES.
FROM ALMOST THE INCEPTION.
THE TEACHERS COLLEGE.
THE BRICK BUILDINGS.
I THINK PARTICULARLY OF KEEP
GOING FRESNO STATE THAT ARE DEAR
TO ME.
THEY ARE STILL FUNCTIONAL
BECAUSE THEY HAVE MAINTAIN THEM
AND READ THE MILITATED THEM MADE
THEM WORSE QUAKE SAFE.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THE QUALITY OF FACILITIES.
A REALLY INTEGRAL.
AND WE CANNOT.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES.
TO DO MUCH.
WITHOUT THE HELP OF THE BOND.
I REMEMBER THE CHANCELLOR OF UC
DAVIS HAVING DINNER WITH ME ONE
NIGHT [inaudible]
COMMENTING.
ABOUT MY ASSISTANCE HERE.
GETTING THE MONEY. FOR WHAT
BECAME MYERS HALL AT UC DAVIS.
HE TOLD ME TO MY SURPRISE AND I
GUESS I JUST HAD NOT BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION.
THAT THAT WAS THE FIRST CAPITAL
OUTLAY FOR MAJOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECT FUNDED.
IN TEN YEARS.
I BRING THAT UP TO NOTE THAT THE
NEGLECT OF THESE RESOURCES.
IS LONG LONG TERM IT'S BEEN
AROUND. FOR MANY ANY YEARS THAT
WE HAVE DEFERRED [inaudible]
MAINTENANCE [inaudible]
AND CONSTRUCTION.
OF NEW FACILITIES.
I LIKE TO SHOOT THE RETENTION OF
THE OLD HISTORIC FACILITIES BUT
WE NEED.
AND THIS IS.
A PRIORITY I WOULD ARGUE I URGE
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN CENTER GLAZIER YOU
MAKING CLOTHES THANK YOU ARE
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR TO
THE MEMBERS FOR LISTENING FOR
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED.
BY THIS DISCUSSION TODAY.
CERTAINLY -- THANKS TO MY JOINT
AUTHORS SENATOR FROM SANTA
MONICA -- APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
IN THE JOINT AUTHORSHIP FROM THE
SENATOR FROM -- FRESNO AND STAND
AS A LOS ANGELES TO HIM -- BUT I
WOULD SAY THIS THAT -- TO THE
SENATOR OF THE ALUMNI SENATOR
FROM LONG BEACH OF I WOULD SAY
THIS THAT FIRST -- YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BALANCE SHEET AT THE
STATE ARE OF COURSE --
IMPORTANCE AND AND REQUIRE OUR
OUR CONSTANT ATTENTION AND
DIGITAL AND SAID I AND YOU KNOW
AND WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS ON
THIS AND OTHER ISSUES THAT.
IT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO MANAGE
BETTER AND YOU KNOW I'M VERY
COMMITTED TO THAT -- BUT WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE EDUCATION
THAT YOU'VE GOT TO ENJOY IN
EXPERIENCE AT LONG BEACH.
THOSE BUILDINGS DIDN'T JUST
APPEAR ON THE DAY IN WHICH YOU
WERE IN ROLES.
THEY APPEARED BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA -- OUR ANCESTORS
OUR FOREFATHERS IN FOR MOTHER'S
MADE A CHOICE TO INVEST IN THOSE
FACILITIES AND THEY DIDN'T
HAPPEN BY.
TAKING MONEY OUT OF THE THE TREE
IN THE BACKYARD IT HAPPENED
BECAUSE OF A BONDS AND
INVESTMENTS THAT THEY WERE
WILLING TO MAKE IT PAY OFF.
OVER MANY MANY DECADES.
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM BUT THEY
DIDN'T JUST HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
MANY OF THEM BEGAN IN THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
MANY OF THEM WERE ESTABLISHED IN
THE NINETEEN EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS WE CELEBRATE THAT BUT
IS THE SENATOR FROM TO HIM THAT.
MADE QUITE CLEAR.
SOME OF THEM ARE ALMOST IN
ORIGINAL FORM FROM WHICH THEY
WERE BUILT THAT BACK IN THOSE
TIMES.
SO WE BENEFITTED BECAUSE OUR
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS
INVESTED IN THOSE FACILITIES AND
THEY WERE THERE FOR US.
AND THAT'S THE SAME THING THAT'S
BEING ASKED OF US TODAY IF WE DO
NOT INVEST.
IN THOSE FACILITIES FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
TODAY TOMORROW AND INTO THE
FUTURE WHAT WHAT'S LEFT FOR THEM.
WHAT'S LEFT FOR THEM.
AND I KNOW PART OF THAT ANSWER.
AND THAT'S IT THAT TUITION IS
GOING TO GO UP FEES ARE GOING TO
GO UP AND THE BIRDS THAT USED TO
BE BORNE BY ALL OF US AS A STATE.
BECAUSE OF THE VALUE OF THAT ARE
UNIVERSITIES BRING TO THE STATE
ARE NOW GOING TO BE BORNE BY OUR
OUR KIDS AND THEIR FAMILIES OR
NOT AT ALL.
AND WE KNOW THE DETERIORATION
THAT WILL LEAD.
TO SO WHEN THE QUESTION COMES UP
WHAT WILL THIS COST AND WHAT
WILL BE NEED TO BE CUT -- I
THINK THAT THE ANSWER IS IT'S
ALL ABOUT CHOICES THAT WE MAKE.
AS A LEGISLATURE.
IT'S ABOUT THE VALUES AND HOW WE
PLACE THEM WITHIN OUR FUNDING
SYSTEMS.
AND I KNOW FOR ME AND FOR MANY
THE INVESTMENT IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR THE
STUDENTS OF TODAY AND TOMORROW --
IS A HECK OF A GOOD INVESTMENT
AND AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR
HOW WE GO FORWARD INVESTING THE
PRECIOUS TAXPAYERS MONEY THAT WE
ARE IN POWER TO OVERSEE.
THERE ARE THIRTY THREE
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS MEASURE.
ALL ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE FROM
SAN DIEGO ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
NORTH AND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND MEMBERS THIS IS A PRUDENT
INVESTMENT -- IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR STUDENTS AND OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR FUTURE AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
HI BILL.
BY POOR JUST AYE BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I HUESO BY HER TITLE
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
I AM.
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE [inaudible]
BY KATHY [inaudible]
OUR WINNER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
LOOK I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
BY.
I'M BURKE I THIRTY THREE EYES
NOSE FOR THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO TEMPORARILY
PASSED ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AND
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
THIRTY TWO CENTER GALGIANI.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR GALGIANI KNACK RELATING
TO ALTERNATIVE ENERGY.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ESPYS ONE SIXTY
TWO EXTENDS TO SUNSET FOR THE
SALES AND TAX EXCLUSION PORTION.
AT THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION
FINANCING AUTHORITY TO JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS PROGRAM HELPS
PROMOTE GREEN TECHNOLOGIES
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION AS WELL AS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND JOBS
WITH NO CHANGES TO THE LAW.
THE SALES AND TAX EXCLUSION
PORTION OF WHAT IS OTHERWISE
CALLED CALF DEBT WAS SUNSET ON
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS BILL
EXTENDS TO SUNSET UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTY SO THAT THE PROGRAM
PROGRAM CAN CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE BOTH ECONOMIC GROWTH.
AND CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS SB ONE SIXTY TWO HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION -- FOR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN
[inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HIGHER TADO.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY AMBERG.
BY WHAT CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NIELSEN I PRICE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY THREE UNDER JACKSON
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES TODAY ARE
PRESENT TO SB.
ONE SEVENTY ONE THIS IS A BILL
TO FIGHT PAY DISCRIMINATION WITH
DATA.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T FIX WHAT YOU
DON'T KNOW.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS WITH A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES OR MORE SUBMIT
A PAY DATA REPORT ANNUALLY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING.
THE GOAL IS TO PROVIDE TO
COMPENSATION OR TO OUTLINE THE
COMPENSATION AND HOURS.
OF WORK TO OF ITS EMPLOYEES BY
GENDER RACE ETHNICITY IN JOB
CATEGORY.
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
RECOGNIZING THE PAY
DISCRIMINATION IS HARD TO DETECT
AND ADDRESS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED A REVISION TO A LONG
STANDING DEMOGRAPHIC REPORT THAT
LARGE EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT FOR A PERIOD
OF FIFTY YEARS.
THIS IS CALLED THE EMPLOYER
INFORMATION REPORT OR THE EEOC.
ONE IT IS NOW A BASED UPON THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THE FORM IS
REQUIRED OR EXPANDED TO SIMPLY
INCLUDE THE REPORTING A PAY DATA.
BY RACE AND GENDER BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PUT A HALT TO
THIS NEW RULE.
AND IN MARCH OF THIS PAST YEAR
FOLLOWING A LAWSUIT BY THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S LAW CENTER IN
OTHERS THE UNITED STATES
DISTRICT COURT.
HAS ORDERED THE ADMINISTRATION
TO COLLECT THIS DATA BY
SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
THIS MEASURE SB ONE SEVENTY ONE
ENSURES THAT OUR STATE CIVIL
RIGHTS AGENCY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING WILL
ALSO RECEIVE THAT IMPORTANT QUE
IN JOB DADDY INFORMATION.
THAT WHEN PLAYERS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS TO ALLOW
COMPANIES TO ANALYZE THEIR OWN
PAY IN HIRING PRACTICES FOR A
SELF EVALUATION AND CORRECTION
PROCESS THIS MAY INFORMATION IS
NOT.
GOING TO BE MADE PUBLIC IT'S
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE SO THAT
COMPANIES CAN LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
AND SEE WHETHER THEY'RE
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW AND I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT MANY
COMPANIES WHO ARE NOT COMPLYING
DON'T REALIZE THEY'RE NOT
COMPLYING.
THAT'S PART OF THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS TO TAKE A LOOK TO
SEE WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY ARE DISCRIMINATING
FREQUENTLY ON KNOWINGLY BUT TO
SEE WHETHER OR NOT TEY ARE OR
ARE NOT COMPLYING WITH THE LAW.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN CAREFULLY
CRAFTED TO ENSURE THE DATA WILL
NOT BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AS I
MENTIONED.
EVEN TO A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
PUBLIC SHAMING THIS BILL IS
ABOUT HAVING COMPANIES LOOK TO
SEE WHETHER THEY ARE IN FACT
COMPLYING WITH EXISTING LAW.
THIS IS PART OF A CONTINUING AN
ON GOING STEP WE HAVE TO DO TO
FIGHT THE WAGE GAP.
AND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT IF WE
CONTINUE WITH THE CURRENT PACE
IT WILL TAKE UNTIL TWENTY FIFTY
NINE FOR WOMEN IN THE U. S. TO
FINALLY REACH PAY EQUALITY
[inaudible]
THIS MEASURE.
IN IS DESIGNED TO HELP COMPANIES
MEET THE LAW IT'S A MEASURE THAT
I BELIEVE WILL GIVE COMPANIES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT IT
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER ADVERSE
ACTIONS.
IT'S A MEASURE OF WHOSE TIME HAS
COME AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL.
I POOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHANGE [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR I MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
CERNER [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY Y. CASKEY BY WINNER.
HI WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI.
ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR SB ONE SEVENTY TWO SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATED FARMS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
SAID TO BRING THAT TO PRESENT SB.
ONE SEVENTY TWO WHICH HAS
SEVERAL -- MOVING FACTORS WITHIN
THE BILL ALL RELATED TO INSURING
FIRE ARMS ARE PROPERLY LOW
LOCKED AND STORED BOTH IN
RESIDENTIAL HOMES AND THEY ALSO
IN RESIDENTIAL -- SENIOR
FACILITIES IMPROPER STORAGE OF
FIREARMS IN THE HOMES FRANKLY
ARE KILLING TEENAGERS KILLING
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
ARE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
ACCIDENTAL FIREARM DEATHS
SUICIDE AND SENSELESS ACTS OF
VIOLENCE AMONG CHILDREN ARE
RELATED TO EASY ACCESS TO
FIREARMS.
EXPANDING ON CHILD ACCESS
PREVENTION LAWS WILL LOWER RATES
OF UNINTENTIONAL FIREARM DEATHS
AMONG OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
SB ONE SEVEN TWO WHAT AUTHORIZED
THE TEMPORARY TRANSFER OF A
FIREARM WITHOUT A FIREARMS
DEALERS PARTICIPATION TO A
PERSON WHO IS EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
OLDER. FOR SAFEKEEPING TO
PREVENT IT FROM BEING USED TO
ATTEMPT SUICIDE.
IT ALSO MAKES THE CURRENT CRIME
OF CRIMINAL STORAGE APPLICABLES
THE STORAGE OF AN UNLOADED AS
WELL AS LOADED FIREARM.
THE BILL WOULD PLACE ON A TEN
YEAR PROHIBITION LIST PERSONS
CONVICTED OF THIS CRIME WHICH
MEANS THAT THEY ARE PROHIBITED
FROM OWNING A FIREARM OR
AMMUNITION. FOR TEN YEARS FROM
THE DATE OF CONVICTION CURRENT
LAW MAKES IT A CRIME TO KEEP A
HANDGUN WITHIN A PREMISE WITH
KNOWLEDGE OF THE CHILD OR PERSON
PROHIBITED PROFESSING PROBE.
POSSESSING A FIREARM IS LIKELY
TO GAIN ACCESS IF THE CHILD ARE
PROHIBITED PERSON ATTAINS ACCESS.
TO A HANDGUN AND CARRIES IT OFF
PREMISES AT B. ONE SEVEN TWO
WOULD MAKE THIS CRIME AFTER A
COUPLE TO ALL TYPES OF FIREARMS
AND PUT THIS CRIME ON THE TEN
YEAR LAST.
CURRENT LAW MAKES IT A CRIME FOR
AN OWNER OR LEGAL ARGUMENT OF A
RESIDENTS TO STORE FIREARM.
THAT.
THE RESIDENT IN THAT RESIDENTS
IF THE PERSON KNOWS ANOTHER
PERSON RESIDING IN THAT
RESIDENTS IS PROHIBITED FROM
POSSESSING A FIREARM UNLESS THE
FIREARM IS SECURED.
THIS BILL WOULD PUT THAT CRIME
ALSO ON THE TEN YOUR TEN YEAR
PROBATION LESS SO THE KEEP OUR
SENIOR SAY FACT -- WHICH IS ASO
PART OF THIS REQUIRES
REGULATIONS AND PROCEDURES FOR A
FIREARM AND AMMUNITION TO BE
CENTRALLY STORED IN A LOCK GUN
SAFE.
WITHIN RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES THINK ABOUT THAT
ISSUE RIGHT NOW OUR OUR SENIORS
GOING TO THESE CARE FACILITIES
AND THERE'S NO STANDARD THERE'S
NO REQUIREMENT THERE'S NO.
DISCLOSURE ON FIREARMS AND ENTER
THOSE FACILITIES THAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
FACILITY TO PREPARE AND MAINTAIN
AN IN A WEAPONS INVENTORY FOR
EACH FIREARM AND TYPE OF ANY
MINUTE AMMUNITION.
STORED AGAIN WE'RE NOT TAKING
SOMEONE'S RIGHT AWAY.
BUT CERTAINLY THOSE PEOPLE IN
THOSE SENIOR FACILITIES SHOULD
KNOW WHAT COMES IN IN THE SHOE
BOX WHEN GRANDMA AND GRANDPA
SHOW UP SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
PRESERVATION OF THE SENATE.
THIS IS ANOTHER.
PILE ON BILL [inaudible]
RELATED [inaudible]
TO GUNS.
THE PROBLEMS OF GUNS ARE NOT.
SENIOR CITIZENS WHO STORE THEM
IN WHATEVER MANNER.
OR EVEN FAMILIES.
THE PROBLEM WITH GUNS --
CRIMINALS IN INDIVIDUALS.
WITH DASTARDLY INTENT.
WHO USE THOSE GUNS?
THIS PARTICULAR STORAGE FOR
VISION.
IT IS NOT GOING TO AFFECT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WITH ILL INTENT.
JUST AS ALL OF THE OTHER GUN
CONTROL BILLS [inaudible]
FLOW THROUGH.
THEY LAUGHED AT CONSCIENTIOUS
PARENTS [inaudible]
OR CITIZENS.
WHO HAVE GUNS?
DO TAKE.
THE PRECAUTIONS [inaudible]
THE STORE.
AND PROPERLY PROTECT
[inaudible]
THOSE GUNS.
IN PART BECAUSE THEIR FAMILY
HEIRLOOMS AND TREASURES.
WE HAVE SOME IN OUR GUN SAFE.
THEY'RE VERY SPECIAL.
BUT WE ARE NOT WORRIED.
ABOUT THEM BEING USED. FOR
INFORMACIóN PURPOSES.
AGAIN.
DO I WANT TO CALL IT JUST A
COSMETIC FEEL GOOD BILL.
NO I DID NOT GO SO FAR I HAVE
FAR TOO MUCH RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR.
IT IS SINCERE INTENT IN THE
THOROUGHNESS WITH WHICH HE
PUSHES ALL LEGISLATION.
I JUST THE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING NOT
NECESSARY.
AND I AM CERTAIN. FIVE YEARS
HENCE. TEN YEARS HENCE.
VERY FEW IF ANY.
CRIMES WITH GUNS COULD EVER BE
AVOIDED.
BY THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
NOR COULD IT BE SO EVIDENCED
HIGHER GENOVA.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
THING THEN.
CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAKE
INCLUDES THANK YOU I'M OUT OF
PRESIDENT I SHARE ADMIRATION FOR
MY COLLEAGUES FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA -- I SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY WITH AS WELL --
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE ON THE
ANALYSIS OF THE BILL --
CERTAINLY WE READ -- FAR TOO
OFTEN OF HOW GUNS IN THE LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS HOMES AND UP IN
THE WRONG HANDS -- ACCIDENTS
HAPPEN.
UNFORTUNATELY CHILDREN SOMETIMES
PERISH IN THOSE ACCIDENTS --
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT.
TO SAY WERE SERIOUS ABOUT
KEEPING GUNS AWAY FROM THOSE
THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE THEM WHETHER
THAT SOMEBODY ON THE PROHIBITION
LIST OR A YOUNG PERSON AND AGAIN
THE SENIOR FACILITIES -- PIECE
OF REGULATION.
IS DEFINITELY NECESSARY SO FOLKS
ARE SAFE IN THOSE HOMES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CAMBIADO [inaudible]
JANE [inaudible]
DODD.
THE RISE OF HI GALGIANI
[inaudible]
HI GLAZER.
HI GROWTH.
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
BY JONES NO.
LEYVA.
AYE.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROB [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
BY STERN BY STONE.
NO NUMBER VIA CASKEY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
WILK WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS.
CABALLERO NO NO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
ROTH.
SIZE TWENTY FIVE NEWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR
MCGUIRE.
I'M SORRY ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY FIVE A
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ACT RELATED
CAMPUS.
OR IS YOURS HEY GOOD MORNING
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE IS THE TRUTH IN
LABELING TRANSPARENCY BILL THE
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW.
THAT ALLOWS FOR COMPANIES YOU
THE NAMES AND APPELLATIONS THE
PRODUCTS ADVERTISING IN FURTHER
CLARIFIES ORGANIC CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM FOR CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
THIS BILL EXPANDS PROHIBITIONS
ALREADY IN STATUTE ON PROPERLY
USING COUNTY NAMES FOR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS TO INCLUDE ANY SIMILAR
SOUNDING NAME APPELLATIONS THAT
IS LIKELY TO MISREPRESENT THE
ORIGIN OF THE PRODUCT.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE ALSO
CLARIFIES THE ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
CANNABIS IN MANUFACTURE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS IN POWER IN THE
INDUSTRY TO CERTIFY THEIR
PRODUCT AS ORGANIC.
UNDER THE CALVET APARTMENT FOOD
AGRICULTURE IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WHAT'S THE
DEPARTMENTS COMPLETE REGULATIONS
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT PRESENT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION.
SING THEN AT THERE IS A PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES.
HI BILL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO BY -- TADO
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
MONEY MITCHELL LIE MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I'M RAIL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BOB I COUNTY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS.
BURGESS [inaudible]
DURACELL HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
JONES.
GROW BY JONES I NIELSEN
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
NINE SB THREE FORTY NINE SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY NUMBER SENATOR PORTANTINO
ANAK WILLING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU ARE
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- SB
THREE FORTY NINE WOULD REDUCE
THE MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX ON
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA'S GROWING
ECONOMY SHORTLY MANY OF US WILL
BE HONORING SMALL BUSINESSES IN
OUR DISTRICT -- WHERE WE WILL BE
FLYING UP A SMALL BUSINESS -- TO
THE CAPITAL TO CELEBRATE THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR DISTRICT
OUR RESEARCH SHOWS THAT OVER
THREE MILLION OF CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES ACCOUNT FOR
ABOUT 99% OF THE STATE'S
EMPLOYERS.
AND 45% OF CALIFORNIA'S EXPORTS
UNDER CURRENT LAW THERE IS NOT A
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX OF EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS ON EVERY
CORPORATION.
THIS TAX IS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
STRUCTURE THAT MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES STRUGGLE TO AFFORD.
SO SB THREE FORTY NINE CREATES A
FEE STRUCTURE BASED ON A
CORPORATION'S ANNUAL GROSS
RECEIPTS AND THIS WILL HELP
FOSTER.
GROWTH I BELIEVE AND HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENCOURAGE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THIS IS A THIS IS A GREAT BILL
MADAM PRESIDENT ARMED.
SMALL BUSINESS IN THE INNOVATION
THAT INSPIRES IT IS THE BACKBONE
OF CALIFORNIA. 78% OF ALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA -- TEN
EMPLOYEES OR LESS.
THIS ONE SIZE FIT ALL IF IT'S
ALL THAT THE AUTHOR TALKS ABOUT
IS A PROBLEM THAT IS REAL.
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY FRIENDS
AND PEOPLE I WORK WITH IN THE
COMMUNITY AND MYSELF INCLUDED
WHERE THIS EIGHT HER DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR WITH YOUR TAKING IN
MONEY OR NOT IS PUNISHING.
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT BUT YOU
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
IT DOESN'T RAISE A LOT OF MONEY
IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS.
BUT IT REALLY SENDS THE WRONG
MESSAGE AND I CAN'T TELL YOU
OFTEN AS WE DEAL WITH MEASURES
BEFORE THIS BODY THE PEOPLE LAST
COUNT WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR
SMALL BUSINESS WHAT ARE WE DOING
FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS WILL BE
DOING FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
INNOVATION.
THAT ISN'T JUST INFORMED BY
SMALL GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE --
POWERED BY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THIS IS A GREAT IDEA I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
THING THEN YOU MAKE INCLUDE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NINE FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR LEVEL LEYVA
WE WANT I WELCOME THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR HE LAURIE
BOARDS.
OAKLEY AND FELLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BOARD MEMBERS IN THE
SENATE GALLERY WELCOME TO THE
SENATE THANK YOU FOR VISITING US
TODAY.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY ON THE FILE SB FOUR SIX
FOUR SENATOR MITCHELL PLEASE
READ SENATE BEFORE SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MITCHELL ENACT WILLING
TO MATERNAL HEALTH.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU SENATE BILL.
FOUR SIX FOUR THE CALIFORNIA
DIGNITY IN PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH ACT WHICH CREATES
AWARENESS AND ACTIVELY FIGHT THE
BLACK MATERNAL MORTALITY
DESPAIRED IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZE AT THE RATE OF WOMEN
DYING IN CHILDBIRTH OR DUE TO
PREGNANCY RELATED CAUSES WAS
AMONG THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION.
AND BEGAN AGGRESSIVELY TARGETING
THESE HIGH RATES.
TODAY DESPITE A 55% DECLINE IN
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATES THE
NUMBER OF BLACK WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA REMAINS THREE TO FOUR
TIMES HIGHER THAN THOSE OF OTHER
RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS WHO
DIED DURING CHILDBIRTH. FOUR AS
A RESULT OF PREGNANCY RELATED
CONDITIONS.
UNLIKE OTHER DISPARITIES THIS
CANNOT BE EXPLAINED AWAY BY
SOCIAL ECONOMIC STATUS EDUCATION
LEVEL RISKY HEALTH BEHAVIORS.
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
OR OTHER SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH.
EVIDENCE EVIDENCE POINTS
SQUARELY. TO IMPLICIT BIAS AS
ONE OF THE CAUSES FOR THESE
DISPARITIES.
BY REQUIRING IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAININGS FOR ALL PERINATAL
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND BY
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
RESUME TRACKING AND PUBLISHING
MATERNAL MORTALITY AND MORBIDITY
DATA.
THIS BILL ASSURES EQUITY WITH IN
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN SB FOUR SIX FOUR SO THAT
WE CAN WORK TO GUARANTEED
DIGNIFIED THOROUGH AND UNBIASED.
NEEDLE CARE FOR ALL WOMEN ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR PENN I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS -- AYE AYE
AYE TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRING THIS FORD IT TRULY IS A
TRAVESTY AND A TRAGEDY HEN AND
JUSTICE THAT WE HAVE THE
DISPARITIES WE DO SEE.
AND MATERNAL CARE AS WELL AS IN
MANY OTHER AREAS AS WELL BUT
CERTAINLY MATERNAL CARE WELL
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA.
LEADS ACTUALLY THE COUNTRY IN
REDUCING MATERNAL MORTALITY WE
STILL HAVE THIS PERSISTENT THE
SEVERITY.
SO WELL WE CERTAINLY CAN BOAST
ABOUT OUR ACHIEVEMENTS -- IN AND
AND AND TRYING TO REDUCE
MATERNAL MORTALITY I MEAN WE SEE
FOR EXAMPLE AND PLACES LIKE
TEXAS AND OTHER STATES.
WHERE IT'S JUST THROUGH THE ROOF
IT'S THAT TRULY A -- MAJOR UP
CRISIS WE HAVE OUR OWN CRISIS IN
THIS DISPARITY AND I WANT TO
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR BRING THIS FORD AND
BE SURE THAT WE TRY.
TO WE WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
CLOSE THE GAP.
HIGHER TONIGHT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SENATOR DR.
YES I I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT.
I THINK WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
ABOUT.
WHAT?
THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUR RAISING
THIS ISSUE THAT WE SUPPORTED.
IS THAT IT'S A SYSTEMIC ISSUE.
THESE ARE NOT INDIVIDUAL CASES
HERE AND THERE.
WITH A YOU KNOW BAD PLAYER HERE
BAD CHARACTER THERE THIS IS
SYSTEMIC.
AND I THINK EVERY TIME THAT WE
IDENTIFY SOMETHING IS BEING
SYSTEMIC WE HAVE TO STEP IN TO
SAY THERE'S SOMETHING.
DEEPLY TRAGICALLY WRONG.
AND I SO I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU RAISE
THIS ISSUE. TO ADDRESS SAID IN A
STRONGER THE WAY THAN JUST HERE
AND THERE -- CASES THAT THAT
SEEM TO COME UP WHERE THERE WAS
WHERE THERE WAS BIAS SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON BEHALF OF WOMEN.
IN ALL WOMEN AND PARTICULARLY
WOMEN OF COLOR.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN SIR MITCHELL YOU MAKE
INCLUDE THANK YOU I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT I'M -- PROUD THAT TO
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUSES
AND COLLEAGUES I WOULD JUST SAY
I THOUGHT IT WAS IRONIC THIS
MORNING I WAKE INTO THE NEWS
WHERE THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER FOR THE COUNTY OF
MILWAUKEE IN MILWAUKEE WISCONSIN.
HAS DECLARED RACISM A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND I KNOW TALKING
ABOUT RACE -- CAN BE DIFFICULT
AT TIMES FOR SOME BUT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
NOTHING OTHER THAN RACE.
IT'S BEEN SHOWN TO BE THE
INDICATOR FOR POOR OUTCOMES FOR
BLACK WOMEN DELIVERING BABIES
MUST BE SOMETHING THAT WE
CONFRONT SYSTEMICALLY AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID.
SO WITH THAT I HOPE THAT SHE
WOULD SHOW YOUR SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR SIX FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SENATORS OUT WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS ITEM IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTION [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION -- THIRTY
SEVEN I KNOW ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER --
FORTY TWO SB FIVE OH THREE
SENATOR PENN.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE A
THREE BY SENATOR PENN ACCOLADE
MEDI CAL.
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS ARE RISING PERCENT SB
FIVE A THREE WHICH WOULD
STRENGTHEN OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY OF MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS WHEN THOSE PLANS
SUBCONTRACT SERVICES AND
DELEGATE RESPONSIBILITIES.
MEDI CAL NOW PROVIDES HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FOR OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE THAT'S ABOUT A
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE AND PARTICULARLY
HAS GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY.
PROVIDES CARE 482% OF ALL
ENROLLEES.
WELL THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES CONTRACTS WITH THE
MEDICAL MANAGED CARE PLANS THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS THEMSELVES
ARE PREPARED TO SUBCONTRACT IN
ORDER CORNY CARE PROVIDE CARE TO
ENROLLEES.
THE LAYERS OF SUBCONTRACTING ARE
COMPLEX AND OFTEN LACK
APPROPRIATE TRANSPARENCY AND
OVERSIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT EVENTS
ILLUSTRATE THE PATIENT CARE CAN
SUFFER BECAUSE OF THIS IT WAS A
BLUR COMPLETED TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SHED LIGHT ON A SUBCONTRACTOR
FALSIFYING DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
PATIENT THE NILES OF CARE.
THIS IS FOLLOWED BY ANOTHER VENN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALLEGING AND A
DIFFERENT ENTITY SUBCONTRACTING
AND HE'S IMPROPERLY MANAGING THE
CARE OF PATIENTS.
SB FIVE A TREE WILL HELP
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BY STRENGTHENING
DHS IS DECENT H. C. S. AS
ABILITY TAKE ACTIONS ON THEIR
REPORTS OF PROBLEMATIC BEHAVIOR
ESTABLISH AUDIT REQUIREMENTS
REQUIRE REPORTING WHEN THE
SUBCONTRACTS.
SUBCONTRACTOR ACTIONS RESULT IN
BENEFICIARY GRIEVANCE OR PEEL
AND MAKE IT CLEAR THAT MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
RESPONSIBLEFOR SERVICES PROVIDE
THE BENEFICIARIES REGARDLESS OF
ANY SUBCONTRACTING THEY CONDUCT.
EXPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SEEING NONE THE THIS.
IS A CANDIDATE IF.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS.
ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS EYES THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR WHICH IS
SB.
FIVE TWENTY THREE NO EXCUSE ME
ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE SB
[inaudible] FIVE EIGHT FORTY
FOUR I FORTY FORTY FOUR YOU'RE
RIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY FOUR SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE SENATOR MCGUIRE
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY THREE RESCIND REQUIRE AN
ACT REALLY INTO ELECTIONS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS HEY THANK YOU
SO MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
A STRONG TO MOSCOW DEMOCRACY
DEPENDS ON A VOTERS BELIEVE THAT
THE BALLOT COUNTS.
THIS YEAR WE'RE BACK WITH THE
SECOND VOTER EMPOWERMENT BILL
PARTNERING IS SECTOR A STATE
MISTER AL SPEEDY ON BALLOTS TO
DON'T HAVE THE SIGNATURE
INCLUDED.
IN THE GOLDEN STATE WERE OVER
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S NOW THOUGH
BY MAIL.
BECAUSE OF THE MISSING SIGNATURE
OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND BALLOTS
WERE REJECTED IN THE NOVEMBER
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ELECTION.
THIS IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE IN
THIS MODERN DAY.
SIGNATURE ISSUES SUCH AS A
MISSING SIGNATURE IS ONE OF THE
TOP REASONS THAT VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS IS REJECTED.
FOLKS SIMPLY MAY NOT KNOW THAT
THE SIGNATURE USED TO VERIFY
THEIR BALLOT WHICH CREATE A
PROBLEM UNIQUE TO THOSE WHO VOTE
BY MAIL.
SB FIVE TWENTY THREE REQUIRES
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO NOTIFY
VOTERS OF THE MISSING SIGNATURE
AT LEAST EIGHT DAYS PRIOR TO
CERTIFICATION OF ELECTION.
AND THEN PROVIDE THEM WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VERIFY THE
SIGNATURE UP UNTIL TWO DAYS
BEFORE CERTIFICATION OF THE
ELECTION THIS PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR VOTERS TO
CORRECT EMISSIONS INJURES AND
PROVIDES MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
COUNTIES. TO NOTIFY NOTIFY
VOTERS SEVERAL OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED A SERIOUS
VERY SIMILAR PRACTICE BETTER
PRESENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND APPROPRIATE
TIME.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THINKING IN A PRESENT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
HI CHIANG.
DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
BY HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO -- BURKE BY WHAT CASKEY.
BY WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
ICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GONNA MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO
ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY SB ONE TWENTY SENATOR
STERN PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACCOLADE FARMS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT TO YOU
SB ONE TWENTY WHICH SEEKS TO
KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE WRONG
PEOPLE'S HANDS BY ADDING THREE
MISDEMEANOR VIOLATIONS TO THE
ARM PROHIBITED PERSONS LISTS.
THE STATE WIDE DATABASE TRACKING
THOSE WHO FOR VARIOUS VIOLATIONS
OF LAW.
ARE NOW NO LONGER ABLE TO CARRY
A FIREARM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE VIOLATIONS THAT WOULD BE
ADDED TO THAT LIST OR THE
UNLAWFUL CARRYING.
OF A CONCEALED FIREARM AS WELL
AS THE CARRYING A LOADED FIREARM
IN PUBLIC OR THE OPEN CARRYING
OF A ON LOADED HANDGUN.
IN RECENT YEARS INSTANCES OF
THESE VIOLATIONS OF STEADILY
RISEN.
LOOKING CITY OF LA FOR EXAMPLE.
pANNUALLY FROM A HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWO WEEKS AGO.
LAW ENFORCEMENT JUST SEES MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND GUNS IN A
SINGLE STING OPERATION IN LA
COUNTY.
AND NOT FAR BEFORE THAT TO
INVESTIGATIONS ALL THAT MORE
THAN NINE HUNDRED ILLEGALLY
OWNED.
GUNS FROM TWO HOMES IN THE SANTA
CLARITA AREA OF OUR DISTRICT.
SB ONE TWENTY WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO MAINTAIN ITS COMMITMENT
A GUN SAFETY WITHOUT CREATING A
NEW CLASS OF FELONIES.
OR INFRINGING ON THE RIGHTS YES
THE RIGHTS OF THOROUGHLY
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS.
THIS IS NOT A BLIND ATTEMPT TO
TAKE AWAY GUNS FROM RESPONSIBLE
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS.
IN FACT IN MY FAMILY.
GROWING UP THEIR RANCH YOU NEED
THESE WEAPONS.
BUT FOR LAWFUL PURPOSES AND
THOSE WHO DO NOT FIND A WAY.
TO CONCEAL AND CARRY IN A LAWFUL
MANNER AND OTHERWISE FLAUNT THE
LAW.
OUGHT TO HAVE THOSE.
THOSE RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE.
SO THIS WOULD KEEP GUNS OUT OF
THE WRONG HANDS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
SEEK TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE AN
INSURED RESPONSIBLE GUN
OWNERSHIP.
AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER NIELSEN.
THE END OF PRESENT LATE IN DOWN
THE SENATE.
I GUESS I'LL HAVE TO SAY.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
YET ANOTHER BILL.
GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
NOT IN THE LEAST.
AND WHAT AN IRONY.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION.
NOW. FOR SOMEONE WITH A LOADED
FIREARM IN A PUBLIC PLACE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A VIOLENT
[inaudible]
MISTER MAYOR.
AND A TEN YEAR PROHIBITION
[inaudible]
POSSESSION.
OR OWNERSHIP UPON CONVICTION.
THE IRONY.
AND THE ABSURDITY.
IS AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE DOING
THIS KIND OF A BILL.
THE LEGISLATURE'S TRYING TO UNDO.
HISTORIC BUT DISTILLATION.
THAT RAMP UP THE CONSEQUENCES.
FOR USING A FIRE ARM.
NOT SIMPLY POSSESSING BUT MUSIC.
THERE WAS EVEN AN INITIALLY
PASSED BY THE PEOPLE OF THIS
STATE.
AT A TIME WHEN I THINK IN THESE
MATTERS THEY WERE FAR WISER THAN
THEY ARE TODAY.
USE A GUN.
GO TO PRISON. TWO MORE YEARS ON
YOUR TERMS.
NOW THE LEGISLATURE'S TRYING TO
WIND EVEN THAT.
NOT JUST THE CHIU POSSESSED.
BUT YOU USED.
WELL THAT'S NO BIG DEAL.
BUT THIS IS.
A BIG DEAL.
FROM THE SUBLIME. TO THE ABSURD
I ORIGINAL VOTE [inaudible]
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU ADAM -- PRESIDENT I
CERTAINLY ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH MY MY FELLOW SENATOR FROM
TO HANNAH.
I ALSO RISE IN OPPOSITION SB ONE
TWENTY OF THOSE BILL MAY BE A
POLITICAL STATEMENT HAS GREAT
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES FOR MANY
CALENDAR CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL ADDS A CONCEALMENT IN
OPEN CARRY OF A HANDGUN IN A
PUBLIC PLACE TO THE LIST OF
VIOLENT MISDEMEANORS THAT WOULD
IMPOSE A TEN YEAR PROHIBITION.
FOR POSSESSION OF OWNERSHIP OF A
GUN UPON THE CONVICTION THE
ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF FIREARMS PROHIBITION ON
MISDEMEANORS WAS THE TEMPORARILY
PROHIBIT INDIVIDUALS WHO
COMMITTED ACTS OF WERE VIOLENT
IN NATURE.
ORG CLEAR MISUSE OF A FIREARM
HOWEVER.
MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE CONTINUOUSLY
ATTEMPTING TO WRONGLY EXPAND
THIS LIST TO INCLUDE CRIMES THAT
ARE NEITHER UNINTENTIONAL THAT
ARE EITHER UNINTENTIONAL
MISTAKES OR DID NOT INCLUDE ANY
ELEMENTS.
OF VIOLENCE IT'S VIOLATING OPEN
CARRY LAWS WHICH ARE VERY
COMPLEX IN NATURE WORTHY OF A
TEN YEAR PROHIBITION.
IS HAVING A CONCEALED WEAPON IS
A FORMER FREE SPEECH EXPRESSION
OR MEANS OF SELF DEFENSE.
REALLY WORTH A TEN YEAR
PROHIBITION.
I BELIEVE NOT FOR THOSE REASONS
I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE IN SB.
ONE TWENTY THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN SENATOR STERN YOU MAKE
INCLUDE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES -- I DO RESPECT
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY.
HI MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE NORTH
AND THE EAST.
OF MY DISTRICT.
IN FACT THE ORIGINS THOUGH OF
THESE PROHIBITIONS STEM TO A
FORMER REPRESENTATIVE FOR MY
REGION -- FORMER.
SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM
MCCLINTOCK -- THE TEN YEAR BAN
THAT WAS IN PLACE THEN WOULD
ACTUALLY IMPOSED FELONY --
IMPLICATIONS ON THOSE WHO
VIOLATED IT IN THIS CASE THERE
WILL BE NO PRISON TIME
ASSOCIATED WITH A VIOLATION.
THESE ARE MERELY MISDEMEANORS
THE CONCERN IS THE FOR ACTUALLY
SAYING.
YOU'RE ON THE ARE PROHIBITED
PERSONS LIST AND WE MEAN IT.
WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY MEET IT
THERE HAS TO BE SOME CONSEQUENCE
TO VIOLATING APPS.
WE OF COURSE NEED MORE TOOLS TO
ENSURE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
THE RESOURCES THE FUNDING THEY
NEED TO ACTUALLY.
FULFILL THE REQUIREMENTS OF THAT
ABSOLUTISTS BUT WE FEEL THAT
THIS IS A MODEST BUT IMPORTANT
STEP TO ENSURING THAT PEOPLE ARE
RESPONSIBLE WITH THEIR GUNS BUT
THAT THOSE WHO FLAUNT THE LAW
OPENLY.
WHETHER A VIOLENT CRIMINAL OR
SOMEONE WHO USES THEIR WEAPON.
AS SOME KIND OF STATEMENTS.
THAT'S THE POLITICAL STATEMENT
HERE.
IT'S NOT FROM THIS BILL.
IT'S THOSE WHO TREAT OUR LAWS.
IN A WAY THAT IS SOME KIND OF
POLITICAL THEATER AND IN FACT
LIVES ARE AT STAKE.
COMMITTEES -- RISK.
THERE ARE TOO MANY LARGE
STOCKPILES OF WEAPONS IN THIS
STATE THEY'RE BEING USED FOR
CRIMINAL NEFARIOUS PURPOSES AND
THAT'S WHAT UNDERLYING THIS
LEGISLATION.
RESPECTFULLY AS RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
HI PORCHES.
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
BY THE ROUTE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
HI FI.
HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADA.
JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NOTE NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
NO I'M BURKE [inaudible]
HI.
BY COUNTY.
I WIENER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS COVER YELLOW NO.
NO GROWTH -- TADO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO.
ICE TWENTY THREE KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
FIVE SB.
FIVE THREE TWO SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AND ACTUALLY TO REDEVELOPMENT.
THE COLOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB FIVE THIRTY
TO A DISTRICT BILL.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE CITY OF
GLENDALE TO USE -- UNUSED BOND
PROCEEDS TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS EXCLUSIVELY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS IS A
BILL OF COLOR -- FIXING
COLLATERAL DAMAGE OF ONE
REDEVELOPMENT REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES WORD DISBANDED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA GLENDALE WAS
LEFT WITH THIS TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN BOND PROCEEDS.
WERE PROHIBITED FROM USING IT
FOR A LOT OF ALL PURPOSE OF
BUILDING I IN THEIR ESTIMATION
UP TO FOUR HUNDRED UNITS
DEDICATED EXCLUSIVELY. TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS ALLOWS
THEM TO DO IT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DOES DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES ON HI BRADFORD.
CAPITAL I I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI OR DOT ON HI JACKSON.
HI JONES.
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO HI HI ROTH
[inaudible]
HI RUBIO.
SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
HI.
BY KELSEY.
HI WIENER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
I WELL OKAY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS.
BRADFORD.
HI JANE [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I WE HAVE. FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SIX SB FIVE FOUR FIVE SENATOR
HILL.
PLEASE REACH SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY FIVE A SENATOR HILL AND
THAT CLING TO DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE IN THE CLEARING THEIR
THROATS TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT SB FIVE
FORTY FIVE TAKE SWIFT ACTION TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS FROM DRUNK
DRIVERS THE SENATE UNANIMOUSLY
APPROVED ALL REPEAT THAT THE
SENATE UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED AN
IDENTICAL BILL.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SB TEN FORTY
SIX SB FIVE FORTY FIVE WILL
REQUIRE FIRST TIME DO YOU WHY
OFFENDERS TO INSTALL AN IGNITION
INTERLOCK DEVICE AYE ID. FOR SIX
MONTHS IN ORDER TO REINSTATE
THEIR FULL DRIVING PRIVILEGES IN
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR OVER ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIE FROM DRUNK
DRIVERS AND MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND ARE INJURED.
A REPORT RELEASED BY MOTHERS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING FOUND
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
IGNITION INTERLOCK STOPPED A
DRUNK DRIVER NEARLY TWO POINT
SIX NINE MILLION TIMES
NATIONALLY. THIRTY THREE STATES
HAVE ALREADY ENACTED LAWS
MANDATING AYE ID'S FOR FIRST
TIME OFFENDERS IN THE NATIONAL
TRAFFIC SAFETY BOARD AND CENTER
FOR DISEASE CONTROL ARE CALLING
FOR ALL STATES TO ESTABLISH
SIMILAR LAWS.
THE DMV'S REPORT ON A FOR COUNTY
ID PILOT PROGRAM SHOWED THAT FOR
FIRST AND SECOND DO YOU WHY
OFFENDERS.
I ID'S WERE OVER 70% MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN LICENSE
SUSPENSION ALONE IN PREVENTING
REPEAT OFFENSES.
SB FIVE FORTY FIVE IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACH THAT
WILL KEEP OUR ROADS SAFE.
THE BILL DOES NOT INCREASE ANY
EXISTING PENALTIES FOR DO YOU
AYE OFFENSES AND OFFERS
EXTENSIVE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
OPTIONS TO ENSURE AYE ID'S ARE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
OFFENDERS THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE THEIR LIVES
AND NOT BE FORCED INTO A
SUSPENDED LICENSE OR LIMITED
DRIVING PRIVILEGES IT WILL ALSO
ENSURE.
ALL THE WIRE OFFENDERS DO NOT
DRIVE DRUNK BOTTOM LINE
COLLEAGUES.
SB FIVE FORTY FIVE WILL HELP
PREVENT DRUNK DRIVING AND IT
WILL SAVE LIVES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE -- COLLEAGUES.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
BATES.
HI BILL.
HI BURGESS.
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
GROW BY [inaudible]
GLAZER.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
MORE LOCKED WANTING I MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
I BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN.
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE BOB I COUNTY.
BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GLAZER HI.
MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY RUBIO.
AS ONE OF THEIR TO SEE.
I IS.
THIRTY FOUR NEWS ONE ON THE
URGENCY EYES THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
ONE ON THE MEASURE.
THE BILL PASSED.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY SEVEN SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT
SENATOR WESSEL.
PLEASE READ SAID ABOUT FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR HUESO AN
ACT RELATING TO CALIFORNIA
MEXICO AFFAIRS.
GOOD MONEY PRINT MATTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SAID I AM
VERY PROUD TO PRESENT AS BEFORE.
TWO TWO IT'S AN IMPORTANT BILL
THAT AIMS TO REMOVE A
SIGNIFICANT.
BARRIER I'M SORRY.
YEAH THIS IS BY FAR BEYOND FIVE
FIVE EIGHT YEAH THEY PUT THE
WRONG.
SPEAKING POINTS HERE.
GIVE ME A SECOND MADAM CHAIR
THEY YEAH THIS THANK YOU.
I'M BACK. FIVE FIVE IT IS A BILL
TO CREATE A COMMISSION ON
CALIFORNIA MEXICO FAIRS
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA -- SHARES OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILES OF OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER WITH MEXICO.
THIS REGION IS A GROWING IN A BI
NATIONAL ECONOMY THAT HAS
IMPACTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER
REGION IS HOME TO SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE THAT GENERATES.
TWENTY FOUR POINT THREE BILLION
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
DODD THIS.
UP OUR STATE PARK.
PRETTY MUCH IS INVOLVED IN
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS OF TRADE
WITH MEXICO WE SHARE A LO OF
VERY.
COMMON -- FACTORS WE SHARE OF
PEOPLE TO HAVE A COMMON COMMON
CULTURE WE HAVE A COMMON HISTORY.
THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT -- WE
HAVE TO CELEBRATE TOGETHER.
THERE IS MORE THE CALIFORNIA
COULD DO TO BRIDGE OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO AND
ENCOURAGE THAT A CROSS
POLLINATION OF IDEAS AND TRADE
AND ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
EDUCATION AND HEALTH.
BOB.
WE HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES IN
OUR STATE THAT COULD LEAD TO
THIS EFFORT THAT'S WHY I'M
PROPOSING CREATING A COMMISSION.
THAT WILL CREATE A CITIZENS
COMMISSION -- THAT'LL HELP US
ACTIVATE THE FULL SET OF
BENEFITS THAT COME WITH THE
STRONG CALIFORNIA MEXICO UPON
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE A LOT OF
RESOURCES IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
NATURAL ACT HUMAN AND IN
COMMUNICATING WITH MEXICO LET'S
PUT THEM TO WORK.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LET
LET'S PUT THEM TO WORK.
IN IN HELPING TO CREATE THIS OF
IMPORTANT TO A STRENGTHENING THE
SUPPORT PARTNERSHIP AND ALSO
MAKE PROPOSALS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON HOW WE CAN IMPROVE OUR
RELATIONSHIPS SO -- I ASKED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE --
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR CREATING A
COMMISSION OF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO AFFAIRS SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON YOUR PART
RELATIONSHIP THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
CENTER NIELSEN.
HE'S ME [inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
THAT ADDRESS LATER DOWN THE
SENATE I URGE AND I VOTE.
MEXICO IS ONE OF OUR DEAREST.
AND LONGEST TENURED.
FRIENDS [inaudible]
ALLIES.
THE BUSINESS PARTNERS.
THERE'S JUST BEEN NEGOTIATED A
NEW NAFTA UPDATE.
WITH CANADA AND MEXICO WHO WILL
BENEFIT [inaudible]
ALL NATIONS.
THAT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THIS COMMISSION.
MOVING FORWARD TO IMPROVE THINGS
EVEN MORE AND THE RELATIONSHIPS
OF THESE TWO COUNTRIES.
IT'S SO MANY WAYS [inaudible]
CULTURALLY.
IN TERMS OF VALUES [inaudible]
OUR CULTURES.
A VERY CLOSE.
THE NEXT GOES WITH A GREAT
PARTNERS.
WORKING WITH US.
I BELIEVE THE COMMISSION.
MAY BE ABLE TO DELIBERATE.
AND COME UPON NEW IDEAS
[inaudible]
MAYES METHODS.
AND PATHWAYS FOR OUR TWO NATIONS
TO COOPERATE.
EVENMORE I URGE AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
BRIEFLY MY FATHER SERVED IN THE
COMMISSION OF THE EXACT SAME
NAME.
IT IN THE SEVENTIES TO THE
EIGHTIES WHAT HAPPENED TO IT I
DON'T KNOW BUT IT WAS A GOOD
IDEA THEN AND IT'S A GOOD IDEA
NOW SO I SUPPORT THE BILL.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAY NONE CENTER WITH SO YOU MAY
CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO THANK
BURKE MY COLLEAGUES FOR FOR
THEIR SUPPORT.
AND ALSO -- JUST A A COMMON I
DIDN'T MAKE CURRENTLY OUR OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO
SUPPORTS. FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK WE CAN BUILD ON THAT
AND AND THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF OF
THIS COMMISSION IS TO FIND A WAY.
TO TO BUILD ON THAT NUMBER.
AND TO CREATE A DYNAMIC --
ECONOMY -- THAT -- EXTENDS INTO
OUR CLOSEST ALLY TO THE SOUTH
MEXICO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR SUPPORT -- AND THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME PRESENTS BILL
MANAGER.
VERY MUCH WITHOUT OBJECTION
SENATORS THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTION ICE THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY WHICH IS SB
FIVE NINETY CENTER STONE PLEASE
READ.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT SB.
FIVE SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY BY
SENATOR STONE AND THEY'RE GOING
TO MENTAL HEALTH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RECORD AREAS
ARE -- TO MOVE AHEAD OF YOU --
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION IS A MAJOR
PART OF THE CONTEMPORARY
AMERICAN LIFE HOWEVER.
ALCOHOL DEPENDENCE AND ABUSE
IMPOSES AN ENORMOUS BURDEN ON
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES AND OF
COURSE OUR STATE.
ALCOHOL ABUSE HAS SERIOUS
MEDICAL CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING
CARDIO VASCULAR DISEASE
HYPERTENSION DIABETES LIVER%
DISEASE FETAL ABNORMALITIES AND
CANCER.
IN THE UNITED STATES ABOUT 5% OF
ALL DEATHS ARE ATTRIBUTABLE TO
ALCOHOL MISUSE.
IT WAS ALSO ESTIMATED THAT A
WHOPPING A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION IS SPENT
EVERY YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
ON ALCOHOL RELATED PROBLEMS.
LIKE LOST PRODUCTIVITY TO
ALCOHOL RELATED ILLNESSES
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES MOTOR
VI<c.cyan> MOTOR VEHICLES CRASHES</c>
CRIME AND OTHER SOCIAL CLASS.
MORE CLOSE TO HOME IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ABOUT 19% OF
CALIFORNIANS REPORTED EITHER
BINGE DRINKING OR CHRONIC
DRINKING.
SB FIVE NINETY JUST PROVIDES
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO
TRY TO HELP.
THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM CHRONIC
ALCOHOLISM.
THIS BILL AMENDS THE LAN COMMEND
PETROUS SHORT ACT TO INCLUDE
THOSE SUFFERING FROM CHRONICLE
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM IN THE
EXISTING SCREENING PROCESS.
THIS INCLUSION WHAT THEREFORE
ALLOW ANY PERSON INCLUDING A
PARENT SIBLING OR SPOUSE TO
PETITION A COUNTY DESIGNATED
ENTITY TO OF AN INDIVIDUAL OR
LOVED ONE WHO IS SUFFERING FROM
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM.
AND IS ALSO IN DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS ARE GRAVELY
OR IS GRAVELY DISABLED. TO BE
SCREENED AND ASSESSED.
THAT'S A VIOLATION WITH US
INITIATE A FIFTY ONE FIFTY AND
TENS OF TREATMENT OR
CONSERVATORSHIP.
IF NECESSARY.
SB FIVE NINETY IS A SMALL CHANGE
IN THE ALREADY EXISTING
FRAMEWORK OF THE LAW TO GIVE
HOPE TO INDIVIDUALS AND OF
COURSE THEIR FAMILIES.
OR SUFFERING FROM THEIR LOVE
ONES SUFFERING FROM CHRONIC
ALCOHOLISM.
THIS BILL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY AT
A HEALTH JUDICIAL AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES SB
FIVE NINETY GIVES HOPE THE SAVE
MORE LIVES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
YEAH JUST BRIEFLY AYE AYES
SUPPORT JOB THIS BILL IN IT WILL
HELP.
CONNECT PEOPLE WITH CARE AND
THANK TO CENTER FOR INTRODUCING
A NEW.
KEEPING ON TOP OF THIS ISSUE
HIGHER CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING MENU MAKE INCLUDE I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CENTER FROM
SAN JOSE I'M HONORED BY HIS
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ENERGIZED
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS --
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTION I IS THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE N TO
LOOKING LOOKING ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY ONE SB SIX THIRTEEN
SENATOR STERN.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTEEN BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO GREENHOUSE GASES.
FOR USERS MISTER AT CENTER STERN.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS.
SB SIX THIRTEEN WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT THE STATE KNOWS WHAT
IT'S BUYING.
WHEN WE INVEST NOT ONLY AND CARS
AND BUILDINGS BUT ALSO IN
PURCHASING THINGS LIKE OUR LUNCH
LIKE WE'RE ENJOYING HERE TODAY?
WE THINK THERE ARE HUGE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
FARMERS GROWERS AT A BROAD
SECTOR OF BUSINESS IS. TO SUPPLY.
OUR DELICIOUS FOODS THAT WE EAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN A WAY THAT
ALSO REDUCES CARBON EMISSIONS.
SO THIS BILL WOULD IT MERELY AD
OF FOOD TO THE EXISTING REPORT
CARD THAT THE STATE KEEPS TRACK
OF ITS OWN EMISSIONS.
BY ASSESSING ALSO THE FOOD
SECTOR -- WE THINK THAT ADDING
TO THE STATE AGENCY GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION REPORT CARD.
WILL PROVIDE BETTER DATA --
ALLOW MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LOCAL GROWERS TO DO LOW CARBON
FARMING -- AND FRANKLY BY BEING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
BEGIN WITH.
THE KINDS OF RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT.
THE AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY HAS TO
GO THROUGH MAKES OUR AG SECTOR
THE MOST SUSTAINABLE GREEN IS
THE MOST PRODUCTIVE IN THE
COUNTRY.
SO WE THINK THIS IS A SMART
MEASURE TO PROVIDE.
BETTER CARBON DATA.
BETTER OUTCOMES AND HOPEFULLY A
LITTLE BETTER LUNCH WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RATHER.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
RESPECT AS RATHER.
THIS CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAMBIADO [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
NO NUMBER.
IRAQ OWSKI.
I WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
[inaudible]
GALGIANI.
BY -- TITLE BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
HI.
ICE.
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY FOUR SB [inaudible]
SIX SIX TWO SENATOR CHILLER.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACTUAL IN
ENERGY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I I PRESENT SENATE BILL.
SIX SIX TWO WHICH WILL ALLOW
INVESTOR OWNED ELECTRICAL
UTILITIES TO MEET THEIR
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
MANDATES.
BY INVESTING IN RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN.
AS A TRANSPORTATION FUEL IN
ADDITION TO THEIR CURRENT
COMPLIANCE PATHWAY OF INVESTMENT.
IN BATTERY ELECTRIC CHARGING
PROJECTS.
THIS BILL IS MEANT TO COME
COMPLEMENT THE GROUND BREAKING
STRIDES MADE BY.
SB.
THREE FIFTY BY BRINGING ANOTHER
TECHNOLOGY INTO THE FRAY AND
ADDING AN ADDITIONAL WEAPON. TO
OUR ARSENAL TO FIGHT AND TO
REDUCE.
THE TRANSPORTATION RELATED
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
SB SIX SIX TWO DOES NOT IMPOSE
AN ADDITIONAL MANDATE.
OR ONTO UTILITIES RATHER ADDS AN
ADDITIONAL COMPLIANCE PATHWAY
FOR THEIR EXISTING MANDATES.
THIS BILL WILL FACILITATE A
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL STANCE ON
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIC
ELECTRIFICATION.
AND ALLOW FOR RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
TECHNOLOGY TO PLAY A ROLE.
IN HELPING US ACHIEVE OUR
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW THE LAST TWENTY YEARS AS WE
HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH.
CONVERTING OUR TECHNOLOGY IN
TRANSPORTATION AND ALL SORTS OF
PRODUCTIONS TO BE MORE
ENVIRONMENTAL FRIEDMAN BAR
MENTALLY FRIENDLY.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE CENTER
OF SO MUCH OF THE INNOVATION
THAT IS EXPANDED THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
OTHER HAS BEEN QUESTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS IS TOO
GREAT DESPITE YOUR CHEN AND YET
QUITE FRANKLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
KNOWLEDGEABLE IN THE SCIENCE IT
IS A BRILLIANT.
ADDITION TO THE ARSENAL THAT WE
CARRY IN CALIFORNIA TO FIGHT
GREENHOUSE GASES THIS IS A SMART
AND GOOD BILL I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR I ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE.
PLEASE ENTER HERTZBERG MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING MANSON OR
SLIDE WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT URGENT
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR MISTERSECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
NOBEL.
HI PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
JANE [inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NOTE NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN BY STONE.
NOVEMBER.
I AND I LIKE.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BY [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
CABALLERO.
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I JONES.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO.
ROTH.
PRODUCT.
SIZE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE SENATOR
MCGUIRE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 670% OF REQUIRE
AN ACT RELATED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CENTER BEFORE.
HEY WHAT'S GOING ON MAN
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH SB
SIX SEVENTY IS A SIMPLE STEP.
A SIMPLE STEP TO MITIGATE THE
RISKS DURING TIMES OF TOTAL
CRISIS AND PHONE ENERGIES BY
REQUIRING TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS TO REPORT NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OUTAGES ARE ADDED IS
AFFECTING.
EMERGENCY ALERT AND WARNING
SYSTEM TO THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IN REAL
TIME.
WE'RE HONORED TO BE A TO BRING
FOR THIS BILL WITH THE SENATOR
FROM TO HIM.
CURRENTLY WHEN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES GO
DOWN AFFECTING ONE ONE NINE ONE
ONE SERVICE OR THE ABILITY FOR
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS ISN'T ALERTS.
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT REAL TIME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCATION
OF THE OUTAGE.
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE
AFFECTED AND WHAT THE ESTIMATED
TIME OF REPAIR IS?
SB SIX SEVENTY WOULD REQUIRE
PROVIDERS OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES TO NOTIFY CAL -- YES
WHENEVER THERE IS A NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OUTAGE OR ANY OUTAGE
AFFECTING EMERGENCY WARNING
CAPABILITIES WITHIN SIXTY
MINUTES OF THAT OUR AGE.
CARILLO YES WITHIN BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOTIFYING THE
AFFECTED LOCAL COUNTY IN
CONTINUE COMMUNICATING WITH THEM.
SB SIX SEVENTY PASSED OUT OF
BOTH POLICY COMMITTEES WITH
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
IS SUPPORTED BY THE STATE SHARES.
STATE FIRE CHEESE AS WELL TO
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN ITEM.
PLEASE ENTER MCGUIRE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
NIELSEN.
THAT ARE PRESENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
THE COOPERATION.
IS SO VERY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THE COMMUNICATION
[inaudible]
IS KEY.
THE SAVING LIVES.
THE IN THESE SITUATIONS
[inaudible]
THE SLOW [inaudible]
BRAINERD THAT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE SAFETY
WOULD BE SYMPATHETIC WITH THIS
LEGISLATION.
WE'VE HAD PROBLEMS WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN.
THE MAIN DIFFERENCE IN
INTERRUPTION.
AND WHEN FOLKS THAT ARE NOT
NOTIFIED OR CANNOT.
THEMSELVES TO NOTIFY
[inaudible]
THEY AND WE HAVE A REAL PROBLEM.
AND AS THESE DISASTER SITUATIONS
SEEM TO BE.
INCREASING.
ALL THE MORE NEED. FOR US TO
HAVE THAT RAPID TRACK.
I WANT TO THANK SOME OF THE
PROVIDERS THOUGH.
SOMETIMES MAYBE CRITICIZED.
AND I DON'T NECESSARILY LOOK AT
THIS BILL IS A CRITICIZED AS A
MOTHER.
BUT IN THESE RECENT DISASTERS
HOW VERY HELPFUL THEY HAVE BEEN.
SOME OF THEM WILL.
LITERALLY [inaudible]
BUILT CITIES.
IN THE AREA WHERE WE HAVE HAD
FIRE DISASTERS.
WHO WERE THERE A LONG TIME?
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
THOUGH THAT'S NOT THE POINT THAT
WAS A POINT ABOUT GOOD FAITH AND
GOOD CITIZENSHIP.
BUT GOOD COOPERATION.
I THINK IS EASILY DONE.
IT SAVES LIVES IT'S SAFE
PROPERTY.
I REGION I VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVENTY ONE APPLIED TO THE
AUTHOR.
THE SET GOOD SENATOR FROM HILLS
BURKE FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
I MET WITH -- SOME.
FRIENDS OF CONSTITUENTS -- IN MY
OFFICE -- YESTERDAY.
AND THEY TOLD US ABOUT AN
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY HAD IN THE
FIRES AND ST ALINA NAPA COUNTY
[inaudible]
WHERE?
WHEN THEY WENT TO BED -- THEY
KNEW THE FIRES WERE GETTING
CLOSER BUT THEY DIDN'T REALIZE.
HOW FAST THAT FIRE WAS WORKING?
TOWARDS OUR HOUSE. ELEVEN FORTY
FIVE THE THE MRS WALKER HUSBAND
I'M A SAID I SMELL SMOKE.
AND THEY WALKED OUTSIDE AND THEY
SAW THE FIRE AT THEIR BACKYARD
GOT IN THEIR CAR.
WORD WAS THEY WERE DRIVING DOWN
THE STREET TRYING TO ALERT AS
MANY OF THEIR NEIGHBORS AS THEY
POSSIBLY COULD.
THE FORTUNATELY ALL GOT OUT
EXCEPT FOR ONE PARTY.
THAT SUCCUMBED IN THE FIRE
[inaudible]
SO.
THESE TYPES OF NOTIFICATION
PROCESS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY IN SOME OF OUR MORE
ISOLATED AREAS I REPRESENT MERRY
CALLED IDYLLWILD MAYBE WHEN YOU
HEARD ABOUT IT IT'S A MOUNTAIN
COMMUNITY AND IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY WERE THERE'S BASICALLY
AWAY IN IN THE WAY OUT.
AND THIS WAS -- WHERE THE
CRANSTON FIRE WAS SO STARTED BY
AN ARSONIST AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
HILL?
HAVE THEY STARTED AT THE TOP OF
THE HILL.
WE NOT BE TALKING ABOUT -- A
FIRE THAT WAS -- CLOSE TO A
COMMUNITY BUT WE MIGHT BE
TALKING ABOUT THE DEATHS OF TWO
TO THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
MAY NOT HAVE THE TIME WITH THE
EXISTING -- TECHNOLOGIES TO GET
OUT OF THEIR COMMUNITIES IN TIME.
SO I BELIEVE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS GOING TO SAVE
LIVES IS GOING TO GIVE COMFORT
TO THOSE A LIVE IN SOME OF THESE
MORE.
FIRE PRONE -- AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE EARTHQUAKES.
NATURAL GAS LEAKS WHATEVER IT
MAY BE HARD TO BE NOTIFIED IN
THE EVENT THAT THERE IS ACOSTA A
CATASTROPHIC EVENT COMING THEIR
WAY.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I HEARD A
AYE VOTE ON SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
AGAIN PART THE OTHER.
THE CENTER STONE MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
REQUIRE WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE CENTER
FROM TO MACULAR FORCE ELOQUENT
WORDS.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
RECOGNIZE TO OTHER SENATORS ON
THE FLOOR.
THE CENTER FROM TO HIM IN THE
CENTER FROM NAPA.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN BOTH BOTH OF
THEM HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
ON THIS LEGISLATION.
BOTH OF THEM HAVE BEEN CHAMPION
FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
REPRESENT BEFORE AND AFTER THESE
DISASTERS IS GOING TO HAVE
GRATEFUL WE ARE TO BE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS.
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM THE
SAN REQUIRE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
HI [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
HI BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG BY DOT [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO BY -- TADO
[inaudible]
BY JACKSON.
I JONES.
BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
MONTH.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
BY MORALE.
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY AMBERG.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
BY WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BELL I GROWTH.
THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH.
I THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE SENATOR-GLAZER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
MESSENGER GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO PARKS AND RECREATION.
CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
NUMBERS -- THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL MIGHT SEEM FAMILIAR TO SOME
OF YOU BECAUSE IT WAS.
PASSED BY THE SENATE IN SIMILAR
FORM -- LAST YEAR.
AT THE TIME JOINTLY AUTHORED BY
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES FROM
THE AREA ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CATHERINE.
BAKER AND AND THIS MEASURE
CURRENTLY CO AUTHORED BY THE THE
THE NEW ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM THE
AREA.
BUT THIS LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF PARK AND
RACK. TO SELL A PORTION OF THE
CARNEGIE STATE.
CREATION VEHICLE AREA KNOWN AS
ALAMEDA TESLA -- FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES IF.
THE DEPARTMENT DETERMINES IT'S
IN THE PUBLIC'S INTEREST.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A PLAN
TO EXPAND THE CARNEGIE.
OFF ROAD -- AREA WAS APPROVED
BUT IT LED TO BROAD LOCAL
OPPOSITION.
THE PROJECTS CURRENTLY IN
LITIGATION -- THAT INCLUDES THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA A CHALLENGING --
THE EXPANSION.
A LARGE DELEGATION OF BAY AREA
CAUCUS MEMBERS AND I HAVE ASKED
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONSIDER
SELLING THIS EXPANSION AREA.
RECOUPING THE MONEY BACK INTO
THE OFF ROAD FIND -- BECAUSE IT
IT'S OUR BELIEF THAT THIS
PROJECT CAN BE MIRED IN
CONTROVERSY FOR A VERY VERY.
LONG TIME WHEN WE ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONSIDER THIS
THEIR ANSWER WAS THAT THEY
NEEDED LEGISLATION TO MAKE THAT
OPTION.
EVEN AVAILABLE TO THEM.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE MEASURE IS
BEFORE YOU TODAY DOESN'T MANDATE
A SALE OF THE PROPERTY.
I SIMPLY SAYS THAT IF IN THEIR
WISDOM THEY DECIDE THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO KEEP FIGHTING THE
LAWSUITS.
ARE THAT THERE IS AN OPTION
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM IN THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD PROVIDE FOR
THAT.
HAS A BROAD RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
WITH THAT ASTEROID OF TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
WORK OWSKI.
MEN PRESENT I'M I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I'M A CO
AUTHOR OF A THIS MANY A
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE BAY
AREA.
HI IT'S A WIN WIN TO ALLOW THE
STATE.
TO SELL THIS LAND AND IN THE
CONSERVATION PURPOSES THAT ARE
OUTLINED BY THE BILL -- INCLUDE
PRESERVATION OF NATIVE
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY WILDLIFE
HABITAT CULTURAL RESOURCES AND
THE ENJOYMENT OF SCENIC BEAUTY
AND NON MOTORIZED PUBLIC
RECREATIONS IT'S A GOOD BILL I
WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER WHITE HOUSE THE
MEMBERS FOR THE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THUNDERSTONE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
WOULD YOU TAKE IT OFF THE
QUESTION YES PLEASE PROCEED AS A
PART OF THE SALE OF THIS I
UNDERSTAND A NEEDS TO GO TO A
NONPROFIT WHICH IS -- NOBLE --
WILL THAT PROCESS BE CLOSE BID
OR AN OPEN NEGOTIATION TO SELL
THAT PROPERTY.
CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION THE IF THAT IF THE
CHOICE WAS MADE.
TO SELL THE PROPERTY WOULD FALL
INTO THE SAME SURPLUS LAND
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE AN ACTIVE
FOR OUR ENTIRE STATE.
AND THERE'S A PROP PROCESSES IN
PLACE TO DO THAT THAT'S NOT
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
OKAY SO -- NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THAT PROCESS ARE YOU AWARE THAT
THAT WOULD BE A CLOSE BID
PROCESS.
I'M NOT I'M NOT DIRECTLY
FAMILIAR WITH EXACTLY HOW THAT
AT THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
UNDERTAKES THAT.
UPSET THAT -- ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL IS THAT --
THAT THE PROPERTY NOT BE SOLD
FOR ANYTHING LESS THAN IT WHAT
IT COSTS TO PURCHASE.
SO THAT THE FINE WOULD BE
BROUGHT BACK TO ITS SAID
CURRENTLY -- THAT THE POSITION
WAS IN WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
PURCHASED THE PROPERTY SO WE DO
SET A FLOOR IN LEGISLATION THAT
HE CAN'T GO BELOW -- WHAT IF
THEY PAY FOR IT ORIGINALLY AS TO
HOW HIGH AND WHAT THAT THE
BIDDING PROCESS I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT OKAY THANK YOU ON
MY OWN TIME AT A PRESIDENT ICE
PERCENT -- I UNDERSTAND THE THE
CONTENTIOUSNESS OF OF A SITE.
NOT IN MY DISTRICT BUT AS A HV --
PROPONENT.
AND KNOWING THAT WE HAVE LIMITED
PLACES WHERE YOU CAN.
LEGALLY TAKE YOUR H. FEES AND IF
WE DON'T PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
SPACE FOR THEM.
TO USE THESE VEHICLES WHICH IS A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE GOING TO GO IN PLACES
WHERE WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
RECREATION HABITAT IN SENSITIVE
AREAS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
SELLING THIS PROPERTY BUT I
THINK IT'S APPRECIATED PROBABLY
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE PAST NINE
YEARS IT WAS USED BY FEES
COLLECTED FROM ALWAYS FOR YEARS
WHICH IS BASICALLY.
STATE MONEY AND SHOULD BE USED
FOR THAT PURPOSE BUT I BELIEVE
THAT THAT LAND IS APPRECIATED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT.
WHEN FALL IF THERE IS ONE SHOULD
BE AUGMENTING THE O. H. P. --
FUN TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE SITE FOR THEM -- TO
DIRECTORY SO FOR THOSE REASONS I
I HAVE MY CONCERNS AND SB SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU THE CENTER
STONE.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING ANSWERED WAS
A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MATT AND I PRESIDENT.
SO FIRST EIGHTY CLARIFY THAT
THIS BILL DOESN'T MANDATE
ASSAILANTS ONLY IF THE
DEPARTMENT CHOOSES TO SELL THAT
IT HAS THE RIGHT TO DO THAT.
IT DOES CREATE A FLOOR IN THE
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DON'T LOSE ANY MONEY ON THE SALE
AND AS THE SENATOR.
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE IS
INDICATED THEY COULD GAIN -- IN
TERMS OF THE THE SALE ALL THE
MONEY WILL BE DEPOSITED BACK
INTO THE OFF HIGHWAY ROAD FIND.
DOESN'T GO TO THIS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GENERAL FUND
WOULD GO BACK FOR THOSE PURPOSES
IN WHICH TO A SUPPORT AND
EXPANDED THE THE SPORT OF OFF
HIGHWAY.
WRITING.
IT IS TRUE THAT.
IF WE DON'T PROVIDE THESE
RECREATIONAL AREAS THAT --
PEOPLE WILL.
GO IN PLACES WHERE THEY
SHOULDN'T SO IT'S A IT'S A IT'S
A CONCLUSION WE MADE AS A STATE
TO PROVIDE THESE RECREATIONAL
AREAS.
THERE IS ONE IN MY DISTRICT
THERE'S NOT THAT MANY IN THE
STATE BUT I DO HAVE ONE OF THE
DISTRICT ADJACENT TO THIS
PROPERTY -- AND SO THERE'S
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO ENGAGE IN
THIS SPORT TO CONTINUE. TO DO SO
BUT THIS EDUCATION PROPERTY
THAT'S PROPOSED FOR EXPANSION IS.
IN A PRISTINE AREA WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FROM FREMONT. FOR IS
CAUGHT THE SHIP FOR THE BILL AND
HE SPOKE TO THAT IN HIS
TESTIMONY OTHERS IT IMPORTANT
ECOLOGICAL VALUE WHICH IS WHY
IT'S IN DISPUTE IN REGARD TO THE
EXPANSION.
SO WITH THAT MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERATION THE BILL AND
IT OUT FOR A NIGHT OF THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN
[inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORALE.
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER.
OUR CASKEY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
YEAH.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WIENER AYE WILK NO
[inaudible]
ATKINS.
I TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS REMOVING
THE FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE
SENATOR RUBIO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND ACTUALLY NEW
PEOPLE AND STUDENTS SAFETY.
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT SB THREE ONE SIX WHICH
WILL BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS.
AS AMENDED SB THREE SIXTEEN
ALLOWS PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO PRINT
THE TELEPHONE NUMBER FOR THE
NATIONAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOTLINE ON THE BACK OF ID CARDS.
THE AMENDMENT ALSO DELETED THE
TAX OPTION AND ADDED SOME CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS OUR STUDENTS ARE
BEING VICTIMIZED AND ARE YOU
THIS EXPERIENCE SEE AN INCREASE
IN TEEN RELATIONSHIP.
INVOLVING INCIDENTS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE CDC REPORTS THAT
EVERY YEAR WHAT I'M FOR
ADOLESCENTS CLEAN STAFF SUFFERED
FROM A TYPE OF ABUSE BY A DATING
PARTNER.
AGAIN WE NEED TO BE VIGILANT AND
OFFER SUPPORT WHEN POSSIBLE SB
THREE SIXTY WILL PROVIDE PUPILS
WITH AN IMMEDIATE CONFIDENTIAL
AND SAY PHONE NUMBER WHERE THEY
MAY.
CALL TO BEGIN THE HEALING
PROCESS THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT.
CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ADD
TO SUPPLY THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK WE NEED TO DO SO -- THINGS
THAT WILL HELP -- INDIVIDUALS
REPORT THESE TYPE INCIDENCES AND
HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO DO SO I
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN GETTING THE AMENDMENTS
WE NEEDED TO GET OFF THE
OPPOSITION.
THAT WAS FROM THE FAITH
COMMUNITY AND AND OTHER
OPPOSITION AND I JUST APPLIED
YOU FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THAT
THANK YOU AND I ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GROW FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING ANSWER REVIEW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
HI BILL.
I POOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I CAL YELLOW.
I CHIANG BY DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROW.
BY HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
HI -- TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
[inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
HI WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO.
MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
HI.
I WAS THIRTY THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES ALL YOU.
MOVING ON MEMBERS WERE NOW ON
ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY FOUR SB.
THIRTEEN CENTER Y. KOWSKI.
SB SEVEN ROUNDS SIXTY FORD -- I
RICHEST THING IF YOU'RE AWAKE
I'M SORRY WE'RE WE'RE ON ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR SB.
SEVEN SENATOR PORTANTINO PLEASE
READ THANK YOU A BILL SEVEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND THEY'RE
GOING TO HIGHWAYS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES -- HIGH -- PROUDLY
RISE IN SUPPORT AND AND
AUTHORSHIP OF SB SEVEN JUST A
LITTLE BILL THAT IS RESOLVED THE
SIXTY YEAR.
DISTRICT ISSUE RELATIVE TO THE
PROPOSED ONCE SURFER SEVEN TEN
FREEWAY -- NOW -- THEN PROPOSED
TO BE A SUBTERRANEAN -- TUNNEL
AS YOU KNOW -- METRO OF LAST
YEAR -- CHOSE A PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE WHICH WAS TO WORK
WITH LOCAL CITIES ON LOCAL
TRAFFIC MITIGATION INSTEAD OF
PURSUING THE TUNNEL THAT WAS
ALSO -- THE SENTIMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT THAT
WAS ISSUED -- THIS YEAR --
DECLARING THE LOCAL ALTERNATIVE --
SURFACE IMPROVEMENTS HAS THE
PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE -- THIS
WAS WELCOME NEWS TO FOLKS --
THROUGHOUT THE CORD OR THIS BILL
CODIFIES THAT DECISION -- AND
ONCE AND FOR ALL BRINGS CLOSURE
FORMAL CLOSURE. TO THE SEVEN TEN
ISSUE I CAN TELL YOU -- THIS
PAST WEEKEND I WAS AT AN EVENT
IN THE CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA
WHERE SEVERAL OF THE COMMUNITIES
WERE REPRESENTED WHO WERE
TRADITIONALLY ON OPPOSITE SIDES
OF THIS ISSUE.
ALL CELEBRATING A SICK LEVY
EVENTS SO -- I KNOW FOR A LONG
TIME FREEWAY SUPPORTERS --
THEY'RE STILL A LITTLE BIT OF
THEIR HEAD HANGING DOWN BUT MOST
OF THE FOLKS IN THE REGION HAVE
MOVED ON LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES IN PARTICULAR
LEADERSHIP OF SUPERVISOR
KATHERINE BARKER -- HAS BEEN
VERY HELPFUL TO THE PROCESS THE
BILL ALSO DOES A FEW OTHER
THINGS THERE'S BEEN LONG
STANDING NON PROFITS IN THE
REGION.
THAT -- WANT TO PURCHASE THEIR
PROPERTIES -- RONALD MCDONALD
HOUSE BEING ONE BOTANICAL
GARDENS BE ANOTHER -- LOCAL
SCHOOL IN THIS BILL HELPS
FACILITATE THOSE LONG STANDING
NON PROFITS TO PURCHASE THEIR
HOMES AND THEN FINALLY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES.
IS MANY OF THE RENTER'S HER --
FOR WHO ARE IN THE AFFORDABLE
RENT PROGRAM ARE FACING A RENT
INCREASE BY CALTRANS IN THIS
BILL FREEZES THOSE RENTS FOR
THOSE RUNNERS IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSE IT'S EXTENDS.
THE RENT FREEZE FOR THOSE HOMES
IN THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING UP.
TIME FOR EVERY PROUD TO
REPRESENT THIS DISTRICT VERY
PROUD OF THESE DEVELOPMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR MORE
LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT A MASK
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WHAT DO YOU ENTERTAIN A QUESTION?
YES I WILL.
YOU'RE RECOMMENDING THAT WE NOT
INCREASE [inaudible]
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
[inaudible]
FOR THE RENTS.
AND TELL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE YOU
SAID IT WAS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT WOULDN'T.
WHAT IN SOME KIND OF COLA BE
APPROPRIATE OVER THIS LENGTH OF
TIME?
SO THE GOOD QUESTION -- SO THERE
ARE CURRENTLY RANCHERS IN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RIGHT PROGRAM --
IT'S A SMALL PORTION OF THE
RANCHERS THE OTHER MANAGER
PAYING MARKET RATE AND THEY HAVE
BEEN SEEING.
RAIN INCREASES BUT THIS SMALL
PORTION OF EXTREMELY LOW INCOME.
RESIDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
EXCELLENT TENANTS FOR DECADES
WHO ARE IN THE PROCESS AND HOPE
TO PURCHASE THOSE HOMES JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME I
FRANKLY I'D LOVE TO FREEZE THE
REIGN OF ALL OF THE TENANTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL IN THE
PROCESS OF PURCHASING THE HOMES.
BUT YOU CAN JUSTIFY IN MY
OPINION THOSE SMALL GROUP OF
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE IN THE FOUR
DOUBLE RENT PROGRAM GIVING THEM
THAT RENT RELEASE OR RELIEF --
IT'S ANTICIPATED THAT OVER THE
NEXT YEAR AND A HALF MOST OF
THESE PROPERTIES WILL BE SOLD
ANYWAY.
AND SO IT'S OUR DESIRE TO OF BUT
THE SUNSET EXTENSION BEYOND THE
POINT OF TIME A WE THINK ALL OF
THESE HOMES WERE OVER TO PRIVATE.
HANDS SO WE THINK IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE.
SPLITTING OF THE ISSUE FOLKS WHO
QUALIFY FOR MARKET RATE.
ARE GOING TO GET THE INCREASES
FOLKS OVER IN THE AFFORDABLE --
RENTER'S PROGRAM AREN'T WE THINK
IT'S A IT'S A DIGNIFIED WAY TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
THANK YOU [inaudible]
RESIDENT.
SHARE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU -- I JUST WANT TO
THANK OUR MR THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS UP IT IS IN MY
DISTRICT AND WE'VE HAD.
VERY LENGTHY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
YOU SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND I
YOU KNOW I DO APPRECIATE THAT --
HIS BILL WILL HELP WITH THE
HOUSING CRISIS IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE WE'RE GIVING ANYTHING AWAY
IT BEING THAT THESE RESIDENTS
HAVE BEEN.
SORT OF STRUGGLING WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE GONNA BE DISPLAYS
AND THEY TOOK THAT UPON
THEMSELVES TO LIVE IN A CORRIDOR
WHERE WE KEPT THREATENING TO TO
EXPAND THE FREEWAY AND SO I WANT
TO THANK THEM BECAUSE IT
DEFINITELY HELPS OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
AND SECONDLY WE'RE DEFINITELY
TAKING CARE OF A LOT OF THE
CITIES THAT ARE GONNA BE IMPACT
TED DOWN THEY'RE GOING TO
RECEIVE MONIES IN TERMS OF TO
HELP MITIGATE SOME OF THE THE
TRAFFIC ISSUES AND SELL.
I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR THAT AND
WITH THAT I ALSO -- TONIGHT
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE.
SENATOR PORTANTINO YOU MAY
CONCLUDE.
YES OUT COMPLEMENT MY SEAT MATE
WHO ALSO SHARES -- A BIG PORTION
OF THE SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR
THROUGH HER DISTRICT AND AS SHE
JUST -- AT EXPRESSED THERE'S A
LOT OF PLANNING GOING ON ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHICH IS VERY
EXCITING AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE ROLL CALL PLEASE
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
REGIS.
I BRADFORD.
AYE CAMBIADO HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI FOR TITLE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
OUR MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
HI NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE AYE HAMBURG.
IA CATHY BYE WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
THE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
JONES I ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY FIVE SB.
THIRTEEN NOW CENTER RIGHT CASKEY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
MESSENGER WHY KELSEY AND AFTER
LINDA LAND USE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MAN PRESIDENT
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN CONTINUES
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE HAS DONE -- TO
SPUR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS ARE
ALSO KNOWN AS EIGHTY USE.
WHAT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
DRESSES A FEW THE REMAINING
YEARS THAT WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY
THERE'S BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THAT
INHIBITS?
THE PRODUCTION OF EIGHTY USING
THOSE THINGS INCLUDE REDUCING.
DEVELOPER IMPACT FEES SAID THAT
OUR CHARGE STRENGTHENING THE
OVERSIGHT OF AIDS S. C. D..
AS ELIMINATING OWNER OCCUPANCY.
AND PROVIDING A SAFE PATH FOR
PEOPLE WHO -- HAVE AN PERMITTED
EIGHTY USE AND BRINGING THEM UP
TO CODE.
THE EIGHTY USE IS NOT GOING TO
SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS WITH THE
HOUSING CRISIS BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT -- COG IN THE WHEEL
AND I REGION I VOTE.
IS THERE ANY -- DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND I WOULD DISAGREE
WITH MY SEAT MATE THIS IS MUCH
BIGGER THAN A CLOG.
IN CHALLENGING THE ISSUES THAT
WE FACE WITH RESPECT TO
PROVIDING HOUSING ALL I THINK
THAT THIS IS A GREAT IDEA I
SUPPORTED BEFORE I'VE BEEN
SUPPORT WE CALL THE GRANNY FLATS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS.
AND I'LL TELL YOU YOU KNOW WE WE
COME UP WITH ALL THESE CUT THESE
GRANDIOSE IDEAS FOR ALL THIS
MONEY AND ALL THESE BIG BILLS ON
HOUSING.
AND I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S BEING
BUILT AND WHERE AND HOW QUICKLY
CAN WE TAKE CARE OF FOLKS THAT'S
WHAT PEOPLE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
I REPRESENT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT.
IT LET ME TELL YOU WE JUST WERE
ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL WITH THE
FUTURE GROWTH COUNCIL THE CITY
APPOINTMENT THE COMMUNITY
APPOINT MAYA.
UP FOR TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THE IF IT ON THE T. C.
C. GRANT THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES AND PART OF
OUR ELEMENTS THAT WERE REQUIRED
IN THAT COMMUNITY WHICH IS I
THINK 88% LATINO.
WAS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A HOUSING
ELEMENT THERE WAS NO WAY WE
COULD HAVE MET UNDER TRADITIONAL
RULES RUNNING MODIFIED RULES
BEEN PROPOSED THE HOUSING
ELEMENT.
BUT THE THING THAT WE DID IN IN
GETTING THAT TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE TCC GRANT
FROM THE TRANSFORMATIVE I MEAN
FROM THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL WAS PROMOTE WAS PUT
TOGETHER A PLAN.
ON ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY COULD PROVIDE HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE IN THEIR COMMUNITY I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENTS.
OR DISCUSSIONS CENTER RIGHT
BECAUSE CAN YOU MAKE INCLUDE YES
MADAM PRESIDENT I I SHOULD HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT THAT THE
AMNESTY PROGRAM THAT SET UP ALSO
ALLOWS EVERY LOCALITY EVERY CITY
IN THEIR JURISDICTION.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
COUNT EXCESS RECALLING UNITS
THAT ARE ON PERMITTED BUT EXISTS
COURTS ARENA NUMBERS IN THIS
NEXT BATCH OF FIVE THE HOUSING
ELEMENT CHARGES GO UP WITH THAT
I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
SENATORS WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
THE THREE ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
I FELL.
I PORGES.
BY BRADFORD.
AYE COMING AT ALL I CHIANG.
BY DOT.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
NO GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
STONE.
I AM BURKE.
HI MY COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH -- TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
ICE THIRTY TWO KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY EIGHT SB FIFTY SIX SENATOR
ROBB PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR ROTH AND
ACTOR LINDA POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- IT'S BEEN WIDELY
REPORTED THAT CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPLY OF PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS IS SIGNIFICANTLY
BELOW WHAT IS CONSIDERED
ADEQUATE TO MEET PATIENT NEEDS.
THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION IS
EVEN MORE DIRE IN INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND FRANKLY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS WELL.
WHICH IS THIRTY FIVE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PATIENTS FAR FEWER THAN
THE RECOMMENDED RANGE OF SIXTY
TO EIGHTY PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS PER ONE THOUSAND
PATIENTS ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PATIENTS.
WE STARTED YOU SEE OURS FOR YOUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE YOU DID AND
THE SCHOOL OPENED IN AUGUST OF
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND WHEN
IT OPENED.
HE WAS THE FIRST NEW PUBLIC
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THIS STATE AND
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS.
SINCE ITS OPENING THE SCHOOL
MEDICINES GRADUATED EIGHTY NINE
STUDENTS WITH DOCTOR OF MEDICINE
DEGREES FORTY IN. TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN HOWEVER
DUE TO BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS AT
THE TIME IT WAS ESTABLISHED.
USE YOUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE WAS
FORCED OCCUPY EXISTING FACILITY
LOCATED ON THE CAMPUS WHICH IS
LIMITED ITS TOTAL ENROLLMENT TO
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY STUDENTS.
AND THE STATE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE MEDICAL SCHOOL TO FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER FISCAL YEAR
IMPACTING ITS ABILITY. TO FULLY
REALIZE ITS PUBLIC MISSION
EXPANSION OF THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE FACILITY IS URGENTLY
REQUIRED IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE.
FIVE HUNDRED PHYSICIANS IN
TRAINING TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS IN
THE UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE
STATE.
THIS BILL SIMPLY AUTHORIZES THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW USE YOUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE FACILITY WITH
SOMEONE GOING FUNDING SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION.
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE BUDGET I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
ENTER STONE.
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO THANK MY DISTINGUISHED
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- MANY OF
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THIS BUT WE
WERE TRYING TO GET THE UC OUR
MEDICAL SCHOOL OFF THE GROUND
FOR YEARS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE COULDN'T
GET.
THIS LEGISLATURE TO AUTHORIZE
THE FUNDS I WAS ON THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AT
THE TIME IN.
IT WAS -- PROPOSED TO US IF WE
CAME UP WITH TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS -- AS A COUNTY BOARD --
THAT LEGISLATION WOULD BE
GRANTED TO GET THIS NEW MEDICAL
SCHOOL OFF THE GROUND.
I AM VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT WE
MADE THAT COMMITMENT IN THE
STATE FOLLOW THROUGH ON THEIR
COMMITMENT AND LOVE TH UC OUR
MEDICAL SCHOOL TO COME TO
FRUITION.
PRIOR TO THAT THE UC HAD A
PROGRAM OF THE UCLA WERE YOU
COULD DO TWO YEARS OF PRE MED
THAT -- YOU SEE ARE IN BE
GUARANTEED A SPOT AT THE UCLA
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE.
BUT THAT DIDN'T HELP.
OUR SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WHICH IS ONE OF THE LOWEST
POSITIONS TO PATIENT RATIOS
PROBABLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A DRAMATICALLY NEEDED
EXPENDITURE WE NEED TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS NOT ONLY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THESE FUNDS WILL ALLOW THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL TO EXPAND. TO
HAVE LARGER FACILITIES SO THAT
WE CAN TRAIN AND EDUCATE MORE
FUTURE DOCTORS.
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
NEEDED IN THE NEAR FUTURE
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT OLD PEOPLE
LIKE ME.
PART OF THE BABY BOOMER
GENERATION AND THERE'S A LOT OF
DOCTORS IN THAT GENERATION THAT
ARE GOING TO BEGIN TO RETIRE.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE COMPETENT GOOD DOCTORS TO
TAKE CARE OF US OLD FOLKS AND WE
GET TO THE AGE WHERE WE NEED
MORE INTENSIVE MEDICAL SERVICES.
THIS IS GOOD FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THIS IS GOOD FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PLUG MY CAR MIKE MY FELLOW --
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND URGE A STRONG I VOTE FOR SB.
FIFTY SIX HUNDRED GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY FIRST TERM IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN 200-072-0008 WE WERE
TRYING TO BRING A SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE NOT ON LEAD TO UC
RIVERSIDE BUT ALSO TO UC MERCED.
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT BY THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN WE
WOULD HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND PHYSICIANS
AND FORTUNATELY THAT'S WHEN THAT
HOUSING CRISIS HIT FOLLOWED BY
THE BUDGET CRISIS.
AND A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HOPE TO PLAN FOR THE STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE THIS FELL BY
THE WAYSIDE BECAUSE WE WERE JUST
TRYING TO COBBLE ENOUGH MONEY
TOGETHER AND THE STATE'S BUDGET
TO GET BY.
THIS IS LONG OVERDUE I HOPE THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT ADDING WHAT
WE NEED FOR YOU SEE MERCED TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN ADDITION BUT I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO REMIND.
MEMBERS AGAIN A SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND PHYSICIANS SHORTAGE BY
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THAT WAS FOUR YEARS AGO AND AND
WE'RE LONG OVERDUE FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR BRIDGES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT --
TO EXTEND MY APPRECIATION TO
THESE TEAMS SENATOR FROM --
RIVERSIDE -- OF COURSE I
INDICATED EARLIER THAT BELIEVE
THERE WAS A CLERICAL ERROR.
IN -- YOUR BILL IT SHOULD BE YOU
SEE FRESNO.
MEDICAL PROGRAM.
BUT I AM ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTIVE
OF OF BRINGING TO FRUITION --
MORE ADVANCED MEDICAL EDUCATION
NOT JUST TO RIVERSIDE COURSE
WILL BE SUPPORT OF TODAY BUT
ALSO CREATING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
YOU.
IN TANDEM WITH WHAT OUR NEEDS
ARE IN THE VALLEY YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS AND
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THE THOSE WHO
ARE IN A POSITION -- TO TO HEAR
THE MESSAGE THAT -- CENTER
GALGIANI HAD ON INDICATOR
EARLIER WE HAVE A DESPERATE NEED --
FOR MEDICAL TRAINING ESPECIALLY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN IT AND
OTHER AREAS OF CALIFORNIA SO I
HOPE IN TANDEM WE CAN -- FIND
THE THE FINANCING AND THE
POLITICAL WILL TO BRING ABOUT
WHAT HAS BEEN DECADES DOT IN THE
NEED -- SO WITH THAT I AM
THANKFUL FOR YOUR EFFORTS I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
WORK IN TANDEM -- TO ACHIEVE
MEDICAL -- INDICATION IN BOTH
OUR RESPECTIVE AREAS
[inaudible]
SENATOR MOORLACH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- SB
FIFTY SIX PROVIDES FOR ME A
LITTLE BIT OF A CONUNDRUM -- I
FIND IT INTERESTING THAT THIS
BILL -- THAT IT'S BEEN SUBMITTED
REQUIRES REQUIRES THE
CONSTRUCTION.
OF A NEW THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IN
RIVERSIDE [inaudible]
SO I LIKE TO KNOW HOW THAT'S
DONE.
BECAUSE I SUBMITTED A BILL TO
TRY AND ADD A COUPLE LANES.
TO A COUPLE OF OUR HIGHWAYS
WHICH WOULD HELP COMMUTERS AND
TRAVELERS AND GOODS
TRANSPORTATION MOVERS AND I WAS
TOLD HEY YOU CAN'T DO THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO CONFUSE.
THE CTC THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION GRIP
THE RESHUFFLE THEIR ALL THAT.
AND WHAT YOU THINKING AND AND
AND SO I YOU I FIND THIS.
VERY INTERESTING I WAS JUST KIND
OF SURPRISED TO FORGIVE ME FOR
MY CONFUSION MADAM PRESIDENT BUT
THE THE TERM DESPERATE NEED WAS
USED IN A WE HAVE A LOT OF
DESPERATE NEEDS.
AND THE HOW DO WE PRIORITIZE HOW
DO WE SHUFFLE THE DECK.
AND SO I'M.
A LITTLE CONFUSED BECAUSE WE
NEED TO UNCLOG MAJOR ARTERIAL
HIGHWAYS.
AND I I I JUST WILL HAVE TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE AND HAVE HIM TUTOR ME --
BUT I HOPE THIS BILL IS
SUCCESSFUL.
AND I HOPE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THEY PUT HIS NAME ON IT THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
CAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- IT TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND I WANT TO THANK
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM RIVERSIDE
FOR BEING AFFORD I DO NOT
REPRESENT RIVERSIDE FACT I
REPRESENT.
SACRAMENTO WHICH IS A LONG WAY
FROM RIVERSIDE.
BUT I KNOW THAT THIS INSTITUTION
IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT -- TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF OUR
MEDICAL COMMUNITY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WHILE
CERTAINLY I IT THE THE SUPPORTED
APPRECIATE -- THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
PRIMARY CARE IN COMMUNITIES --
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE -- I ALSO
THINK WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE REASON WE NEED A MEDICAL
SCHOOL AND EXPANSION THIS
MEDICAL SCHOOL IS THAT ACTUALLY --
COMMUNITIES ALSO NEED AND I'M A
PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR SO I'M ALL
FOR PRIMARY CARE -- WE ALSO NEED
TO BE SURE THAT THIS COMMITTEES
HAVE ACCESS TO SPECIALTY CARE
AND AND AND SO THAT THE PRESENCE
OF THIS MEDICAL SCHOOL IN RIVER
SITES NOT JUST ENOUGH TO SAY
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE TO
GO DOWN THE LA OR SOMEWHERE ELSE
FOR SPECIALTY CARE.
IT'S GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THIS MEDICAL SCHOOL THE
OTHER PART IS IS THAT.
WHILE THIS MEDICAL SCHOOL
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN DOING A GOOD
JOB.
SO FAR IT ACTUALLY -- THESE
EXPANSION BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY
ISN'T QUITE OPERATING A SCALE
WITH -- SO THERE'S A CERTAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU NEED FOR
MEDICAL SCHOOL -- TO BE BE ABLE
TO BRING IT TO SCALE IS GONNA BE
SOMETHING I SHE'S A VERY COST
EFFECTIVE USE OF FUNDS -- FOR US
AGAIN BUILD THAT CAPACITY IT'S
ALSO GOING TO BE A RESEARCH
CENTER IS A MEDICAL SCHOOLS WELL
SO THE DISHES ESPECIALLY CARE IN
FACT WE NEED RESEARCH TAKING
PLACE IN COMMUNITIES LIKE.
A RIVER SIDE AS WELL -- BECAUSE
THAT COMMUNITY NEEDS TO BE SURE%
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
INVESTIGATING WHAT IS CUT --
DRIVING -- ABOUT HEALTH AND
DISEASE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES SO
THERE ARE LOTS OF DIFFERENT
REASONS WHY THIS IS A GOOD IDEA --
BUT CERTAINLY IS A PHYSICIAN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I APPRECIATE
THAT WHAT THIS IS THIS -- THE
THIS MEDICAL SCHOOL DO -- FOR
THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS IN
THE AIR TONIGHT THANK YOU. SIX
FURTHER DISCUSSION ARE AT
SENATOR DR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- ONE OF
THE IN THE HEARING WE HAD ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT STRUCK ME THE
MOST ABOUT THE PRESENTATION THE
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE MADE --
AND THE OTHERS WAS A COMMITMENT.
TO DIVERSITY.
IN THE TRAINING OF OUR FUTURE OF
PHYSICIANS -- AND THERE WAS A
PARTICULAR WITNESS THAT SPOKE A
A YOUNG -- GENTLEMAN BUT LET THE
IN THE WHOLE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THE PASSION OF GOING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY AND BEING A DOCTOR IN
HIS COMMUNITY SO -- THAT WAS
THAT STOOD OUT.
BY -- THE SENATOR AND ALSO BY IS
WITNESSES SO ON TOP OF ALL THE
OTHER REASONS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT STOOD OUT
TO ME AND ONE MY SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
IT'S THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT BUT IT'S ONE THING TO
HAVE A SCHOOL AVAILABLE.
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE THE STUDENTS.
AND THE COST OF A MEDICAL
EDUCATION TODAY I WOULD SUBMIT
HAS PROBABLY DISCOURAGED A LOT
OF OUR YOUNGEST AND BRIGHTEST.
FROM ACTUALLY ATTEMPTING TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS I THINK IF
WE TRULY ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
CORRECTING SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS WE HAVE.
PRIMARILY IN RURAL BUT IN URBAN
AREAS AS WELL AS WAS NOTED BY.
MY A GOOD TO THE GOOD SENATOR
AND BABY BOOM COLLEAGUE OF MINE
FROM TO MACULA A LOT OF
PHYSICIANS WHO ACTUALLY
BENEFITTED FROM SO MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OFFERED BACK OF THE THIRTY FORTY
YEARS AGO THE RICH THE COST OF A
COLLEGE EDUCATION BEING.
LITERALLY AFFORDABLE THEN AND
CERTAINLY NOT AFFORDABLE TODAY
WE HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF THAT
QUESTION WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
HOPEFULLY A NEW MEDICAL SCHOOL
BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE. TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO MAKE THE
COMMITMENT BECAUSE IT IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT TO GET THAT DEGREE
THAN TO GO ON AND DO AN
INTERNSHIP AND RESIDENCY AND
THEN FINALLY STARTED PRACTICE.
AND OF COURSE IF WE WANT PEOPLE
PRACTICING IN AREAS WHERE THERE
ARE THERE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
HELP PEOPLE MORE THAN THEY WANT
TO BE ABLE TO PAY BACK THEIR
LOANS.
AND THAT'S A CHALLENGE IN AND OF
ITSELF WE HAVE TO DO MORE AS A
STATE AS A COMMUNITY TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN SO I AGAIN WANT TO
COMMEND THE OFFER FOR FIRST
PLACE HIS PERSISTENCE.
BUTI THINK IF WE ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT TRYING TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF MEDICAL CARE MAKING
IT MORE ACCESSIBLE MAKING IT
MORE DIVERSE MAKING IT MORE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE AROUND THE
STATE.
WE ALSO HAVE TO CONSIDER OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO INVEST IN
THESE PEOPLE -- SO THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO MAKE THAT INVESTMENT
OF TIME AS WELL AS NOW THE
EXTRAORDINARY EXPENSE ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT EDUCATION AND WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THETHANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO
EXPANDING ACCESS -- TO EDUCATION
IN THE AREA OF OF OF OF HEALTH
CARE AND YOU KNOW I WAS ONE OF
THE ORIGINAL OF SIGNATURES TO TO
FUNDING THE STUDY.
AND SO IT'S IT'S NICE TO SEE
THAT AS AS PROCESSES UNFOLDED
THIS THIS UNIVERSITY IS TAKING
SHAPE STICKING FOR OLD BEEN
CREATED AND WERE EXPANDED.
I YOU KNOW THIS IS A FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS OUR EASTERN
MOST IN TERMS OF LOCATION THE
EASTERN MOST -- MEDICAL SCHOOL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WHERE WE
SITUATE THE SCHOOLS AND
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS THAT HAVE.
OF A LACK OF ACCESS TO TWO
DOCTORS WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
DOCTORS IN STATE BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A SHORTAGE OF CULTURALLY
COMPETENT DOCTORS IN THE STATE.
AND RIVERSIDE IS GOING TO
PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT LOCATION
FOR PEOPLE IN THAT PART OF THE
STATE TO ACCESS -- A QUALITY
[inaudible]
MEDICAL SCHOOL.
MY DISTRICT IS VERY CLOS TO
THIS DISTRICT IN THE A YOU KNOW
IT WHEN I GOT ELECTED SENATOR
EVER PRESENT AT THE THE
COACHELLA VALLEY AND AND THE
IMPERIAL COUNTIES TO REPRESENT
PER COUNTY.
BUT HAVING ACCESS TO YOUR
RIVERSIDE GENERALLY PEOPLE OF
THAT COME FROM MY DISTRICT
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY OF OF
RIVERSIDE IF THEY'RE GONNA GO TO
COLLEGE.
AND NOW THEY HAVE A MEDICAL
SCHOOL TO ATTEND AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET MORE.
OF OF MY CONSTITUENTS IN TO THE
SCHOOL AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET
MORE OF THESE STUDENTS.
IN CHIU SURVEY IN THE THE AREAS
THAT HAVE AN AXE A LACK OF
ACCESS TO QUALITY.
OF MEDICAL CARE AND WE'RE HAVING
A HARD TIME BRINGING THESE
DOCTORS TO TO MY DISTRICT SOME
OPEN.
THAT THIS WOULD HELP BUT I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
COMMIT MIXING THIS PROJECT
THROUGH AND I'M GLAD THE THE THE
UNIVERSITY IS ESTABLISHED NOW
THE SCHOOLS ESTABLISHED.
AND AND THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE MAKE THIS
INVESTMENT NOT ALL THE PEOPLE OF
OUR STATE THANK A PRESENT FOR
LAN WE MAKE THESE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
I'M SORRY SENATOR MITCHELL
[inaudible]
GOAL HIGHLANDERS.
AS SEEN -- FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR UP TO MAKE
INCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES OVER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR VERY VERY KIND
STATEMENTS.
AD MORE OVER FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THIS UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE MEDICAL
SCHOOL.
THE SCHOOL THAT IS SERVING OUR
MOST MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IN THE DESERT.
AND ELSEWHERE AND AGAIN I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENATORS THIS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTION.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY NINE SB SIXTY ONE SENATOR
PORTANTINO PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AN ACT RELATED FARMS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS IS ANOTHER LITTLE
SIMPLE FIREARMS BILL.
SB SIXTY ONE WOULD PROHIBIT ANY
PERSON FROM MAKING AN
APPLICATION TO PURCHASE MORE
THAN ONE FIREARM WITHIN A THIRTY
DAY PERIOD.
LET'S SAY THAT AGAIN.
IT WOULD PROHIBIT ANY PERSON
FROM PURCHASING MORE THAN ONE
FIREARM WITHIN A THIRTY DAY
PERIOD.
FIREARMS WILL NOT BE DELIVERED
WHENEVER THE DEALERS NOTIFY THE
DID.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THAT WITHIN THE PRECEDING THIRTY
DAYS THE PURCHASER HAD MADE IN
OTHER ANOTHER APPLICATION TO
PURCHASE A FIRE.
ONE THE BILL ALSO PROHIBIT THE
SALE OF SEMI ONYX CENTERFIRE
RIFLES. TO PERSONS WHO ARE UNDER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AE LET ME
REPEAT THAT.
THE BILL WILL PROHIBIT THE SALE
OF A SEMI AUTOMATIC CENTERFIRE
RIFLE THE PERSONS WHO ARE UNDER.
TWENTY ONE YOU KNOW I'M TIRED OF
READING ABOUT VIOLENCE ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
PERPETRATED BY LONG GUNS BY
TEENAGERS LAST YEAR WE RAISED
THE PURCHASE AGE TO TWENTY ONE
LET'S KEEP THOSE.
WEAPONS OF DESTRUCTION OUT OF
THE HANDS OF TEENAGERS AND
FRANKLY ONE PURCHASE OF A
FIREARM PER MONTH IS MORE.
MORE MORE THAN ADEQUATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
LEGEND WAS CENTER I URGE.
A NO VOTE.
AGE.
TWENTY ONE SOMETHING MAGICAL
ABOUT THAT.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THAT
LEGISLATION [inaudible]
HOW MANY?
NEGATIVE USES OF A FIRE -- CAN
WE DOCUMENT [inaudible]
DOES THIS.
ALL REALLY HELP.
AGAIN I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE.
ALMOST THE BECAUSE MEDIC.
YOU CAN SAY AND NOT BE TESTED
SAID WHAT WE REALLY DID
SOMETHING BIG WEEK PASSED
FIFTEEN BILLS.
GET THE GUNS OUT OF THE BAD GUYS
HANDS.
THE PEOPLE WHO WILL USE THESE
GUNS.
REAL PURPOSE.
PAY NO HEED TO THESE BILLS WHAT
SO EVER.
AND IF YOU REALLY TALK TO THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS.
THEY NEED THE HANDCUFFS TAKEN
OFF OF THEM.
THEY DON'T NEED MORE TOUGH GUN
BILLS.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT.
ALL OF US.
IN OUR FAMILIES.
I SAY ENOUGH.
AND I URGE.
THE NO VOTE.
CENTER STONE THINK ABOUT A
PRESIDENT -- I APPRECIATE THE
GOOD INTENT OF MY FRIEND.
FROM PASADENA AND BRING THIS
MEASURE FORD BUT I MUST
UNFORTUNATELY STAND UP TODAY AND
URGED A NO VOTE ON SB SIXTY ONE
INSTEAD WE SHOULD BE TAKING.
WHAT IS GOING TO COST US TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL AND?
GIVE IT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND LET HIM GO AFTER THE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT
UNLAWFULLY HAVE GUNS IN THEIR
POSSESSIONS THE ONES THAT ARE
CAUSING.
THE CRIME.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE COSTLY WANTS TO
MAKE -- SECOND AMENDMENT --
ISSUES.
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT A LOT
OF THE BILLS THAT EMANATE FROM
THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE AND THE
ADJOINING CHAMBER.
ARE REALLY.
AFFECTING LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
THAT.
WANT TO EXERCISE YOUR SECOND
MEMBER RIGHTS TO OWN AND HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR WEAPONS WHETHER
THE USE OF FOR PERSONAL
PROTECTION. FOR THEY WANT TO BUY
A THEIR GUN COLLECTORS ANYONE
[inaudible]
TO PARTICIPATING COMPETITIONS --
BUT THIS IS GOING TO DENY THEIR
SECOND MEMBER RIGHT TONIGHT
WOULD PROBABLY OPINED THIS
PROBABLY GONNA GET SOUNDS LIKE
MANY THE BILL'S A COMMITTEE HERE.
IN OUR OVERTURNED BY THE COURTS.
NOBODY CAN DENY THAT GUN
VIOLENCE IS REAL.
A CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER IN
TODAY'S WORLD BUT SB SIXTY ONE
LOOKS TO KEEP FIREARMS OUT OF
THE HANDS OF LAWFUL CITIZENS
INSTEAD OF GOING AFTER THE REAL
PROBLEM.
LIKE I TAKE ELATED THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR GOING AFTER PEOPLE THAT ARE
BAD PEOPLE THE DO HAVE GUNS.
THE REAL PROBLEM TODAY'S WORLD
IS THAT TOO MANY CRIMINALS HAVE
ACCESS TO FIREARMS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DONE UNLESS AN
ADEQUATE JOB OF KEEPING FARMS
OUT OF THE HANDS OF CRIMINALS
DESPITE THIS LEGISLATURE.
GIVING THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND TO DEVELOP A SYSTEM TO DO SO.
BUT THEIR PERFORMANCE HAS BEEN
LESS THAN STELLAR IN FACT I
WOULD CALL IT.
A FILLING.
LET'S CONSIDER WHAT IT MEANS
WHEN A CRIMINAL GETS HIS OR HER
HANDS ON A WEAPON A GUN.
YEAH MANY OF OUR GREAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN THE
STATE HAVE.
LOST THEIR LIVES TO PROTECT US
FROM GUN VIOLENCE.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN TWO
OFFICERS ONE WHO JUST STARTED
HER FAMILY.
AND HAD A BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER.
FROM THE HAMMOND AREA IN MY
DISTRICT.
AN OFFICER THAT WAS ABOUT READY
TO RETIRE.
IN THE CITY OF PALM SPRINGS.
WERE SHOT AND KILLED AFTER BEING
SPRAYED WITH BULLETS FROM AN A.
R. [inaudible]
FIFTY UNFORTUNATELY.
EVEN THOUGH THE COURTS FOUND HIM
GUILTY [inaudible]
THE PERPETRATOR.
NOT FIRST DEGREE MURDER.
AND HE WILL BE CONSIDERED.
A CANDIDATE FOR THE DEATH
PENALTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR COMMITTING THIS
HEINOUS [inaudible]
HERBAL CRIME [inaudible]
THIS GOVERNOR.
WILL REFUSE TO SIGN THE
AFFIDAVIT NECESSARY. TO GIVE
CAPITAL PUNISHMENT TO GIVE THIS
GENTLEMAN THE DEATH PENALTY. FOR
HIS DASTARDLY DEED.
BAD PEOPLE GET THEIR HANDS ON
DANGEROUS.
GUNS ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL GUNS.
DO AWFUL THINGS THIS BILL WON'T
FIX THAT [inaudible] ONE BED.
THERE ARE OVER. ONE HUNDRED ONE
HUNDRED GUN CONTROL LAWS I THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I EXPECT THAT WE WILL
PROBABLY SEE MORE.
THERE'S NO REASON THAT ONE MORE
LAW WILL DO ANYTHING TO CHANGE
THE BEHAVIOR OF BAD PEOPLE WHO
DON'T FOLLOW ANY OF THE CURRENT
LAWS MEANT TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF
THEIR HANDS.
WE NEED TO FIND DIFFERENT WAYS
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IS THAT A
CONTINUING TO RESTRICT ACCESS TO
FIREARMS.
THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY AND IT
WILL NOT PREVENT BACKERS FOR ME
ILLEGALLY OBTAINING FIREARMS
WITH WHICH TO COMMIT.
HORRIBLE CRIMES.
WITH THOSE COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
ON SB.
SIXTY ONE SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAY
CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS-- OF THE 260-006-0080
TWO GUNS USED IN CRIMES THAT
WERE ENTERED IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
WERE LONG GUNS -- OVER THE PAST
TEN YEARS CALIFORNIANS HAVE
TYPICALLY PURCHASE MORE LONG
GUNS AND HAND GUNS AND FRANKLY
THESE BULK PURCHASES OF THESE
WEAPONS -- GO FROM A LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS HANDS INTO.
NON LAW ABIDING CITIZENS HANDS
THROUGH THESE BULK PURCHASES --
YOU KNOW CALL ME CRAZY BUT YOU
GOT ONE FINGER.
CAN ONLY FIRE ONE OF THE TIME.
AND PURCHASING ONE PER MONTH
SHOULD BE ADEQUATE TO RESPECT
THE SECOND AMENDMENT BUT ALSO
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THROW PLEASE [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
BY DORADO.
BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
HI HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO HI BY ROTH
[inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASSIE [inaudible]
BY WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EDWARD.
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
HI -- ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS.
TEN THE BILL PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
TWO SB.
ONE THIRTY NINE SENATOR ALLEN.
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY NUMBER SENATOR ALLEN AND
ACT REALLY INTO ELECTIONS.
MEMBERS -- WE ALL.
OUR ELECTED FROM DISTRICTS THAT
ARE DRAWN UP BY INDEPENDENT
COMMISSIONS -- THEY HAVE A MORE
FAIR NONPARTISAN SYSTEM THAT NOW.
GETS A SELECTED.
AND I I THINK IT'S SERVICE STAY
WELL -- THOSE PLACES WHERE THE
POLITICIANS DRAW THEIR OWN LINES.
OF TIMES BE VERY SELF SERVING --
AND I OFTENTIMES CAN LEAD TO
MAJOR BATTLES BETWEEN COLLEAGUES
IT WAS INTERESTING BEING AT A
CONFERENCE WAS TALKING TO ME.
BECAUSE SOME OTHER STATES ABOUT
THAT EXPERIENCE -- THAT'S THE
BUT WE DO FOR STATE ASSEMBLY
SENATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS WE HAVE
INDEPENDENT REGISTERED
COMMISSIONS.
AND THIS BILL EXTENDS THAT TO
OUR COUNTIES -- SPECIFICALLY
THOSE COUNTIES WITH MORE THAN
TWO FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS ARE
FOR THOSE COUNTIES BETWEEN TWO
FIFTY AND SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND
ODD IT'S IS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION.
AND FOR THOSE LARGER THAN.
SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND IN
RESIDENTS ARE THEY WILL BE
REIMBURSED BY THE REGULAR
PROCESS FOR THE COMMISSION ON
STATE MANDATES.
THERE ARE SOME LOCALITIES THAT
HAVEFAIR TRANSPARENT
REGISTERING PROCESSES BUT THERE --
WE DO SEE GERRYMANDERING
CONTINUING IN SOME JURISDICTIONS --
IN IN IN IN THOSE JURISDICTIONS
INCUMBENTS HAVE USE THE LOCAL
LINE DRYING PROCESS TO
DISENFRANCHISED.
ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT GROUPS
BOB REDUCE VOTING POWER OF
DIFFERENT GROUPS.
AND EVEN TROPICAL OPPONENTS OUT
OF THE DISTRICT THEY WERE
PLANNING ON RUNNING IT.
ARE THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAS
PASSED PRIOR BILLS A REQUIRE
LESS ANDERSON CDA GO TO ADOPT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS ON NOW
IT'S TIME. TO REQUIRE THE OTHER
LARGE COUNTIES TO DO THE SAME.
I REQUIRES INDEPENDENT DISTRICT
COMMISSION HAVE THE FULL POWER
TO DRAFTING DOT MAPS INDEPENDENT
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- BUT
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF MEASURES
IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COMMISSION MEMBERS OR
POLITICALLY DEPENDENT AS
POLITELY FARE -- THAT EIGHT A
AND IT ENDED IN A PROHIBITS
GERRYMANDERING AT CENTER AND
THAT'S WHY A LOT OF THE GOOD
GOVERNMENT GROUPS COMMON CAUSE
WITH WOMEN VOTERS -- IT SECTOR
HAVE COME ON IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT DAHLE [inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU -- META PRESENT I RISE
IN THE SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE WE PASS
THE CONGRESS PASSED.
ARE THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
IT WAS IN MANY RESPECTS A HOLLOW
DOCUMENT.
IN EIGHTY IN.
IT IS ENCOMPASSED A VERY
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE BUT IT TOOK
MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS OF DOZENS
OF CASES.
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO DEAL WITH
COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST IN ALL
THE VARIOUS OTHER FACTORS TO
UNDERSTAND ARMED HOW THIS
PROCESS OF VOTING AND
REDISTRICTING WORKS WE SEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
DESIGNATE CERTAIN COUNTIES
BECAUSE THEY HAD CHALLENGES IN
THE LIKE.
WE HAVE FIVE TIMES IT TOOK IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ADOPT
REDISTRICTING.
AND I SUPPORTED THAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS A DAY
APPROPRIATE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW OF
COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST AND THE
LIKE TO AVOID A LOT OF THE
SHENANIGANS THAT OCCURRED.
YEAH A BEFORE AND STILL IS
OCCURRING IN OTHER STATES.
ARMED AND AT THE CORE OF IT IS.
CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT.
WHEN WE HEAR AMONG THOSE WHO WE
REPRESENT OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT WE'RE ENGAGED IN
GERRYMANDERING SELFDEALING?
AS POLITICIANS WHICH THEN CREATE
OUTCOMES THE DON'T REFLECT
REPRESENTATION OF THE VOTERS.
AND WHAT THE WHAT THIS
COMMISSION IS DONE AT THE STATE
HAS AND MY JUDGMENT CREATED A
GREAT BODY BECAUSE ALL OF US
HERE TODAY OR AS A RESULT OF
THAT REDISTRICTING.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW YOU HEARD
ALL THE TIME BEFORE THIS ISSUE
OF REGISTRY OF GERRYMANDERING
AND IT'S GONE.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE ENJOY A
GREATER LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE IS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY IS BECAUSE
THOSE KINDS OF ARGUMENTS HAVE
BEEN ELIMINATED.
SO IF YOU BALANCE ON THE ONE
HAND THE CONFIDENCE IN
GOVERNMENT A BALANCE ON ON ON
WHICH IS SO ESSENTIAL FOR ALL OF
US TO DO OUR WORK AND TO THE
APPROPRIATE PROTECTIONS THAT
HAVE.
DEVELOPED IN THE COURTS OF THE
LAST FIFTY YEARS I I THINK THAT
THIS SYSTEM WORKS WELL.
IT IS IT'S SOMEWHAT OF A
CHALLENGE AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THE COUNTY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
PARTISAN LIKE WE ARE HERE
THEY'RE ALL WE ARE PART OF A
REFORM MOVEMENT TO HIRAM JOHNSON
WAS TO ELIMINATE -- PARTISANSHIP
OF THE COUNTIES BUT I THINK
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT LEVELS OF
PROTECTIONS.
TIME IS NOW AND I THINK IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD HI -- JOY
VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR MOORLACH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
HER AS A FORMER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS THAT ARE.
TRYING TO BE ADDRESSED WITH
COLLEAGUES.
THE AUTHOR OF SB ONE THIRTY NINE
HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
IN GETTING TO BILLS APPROVED
RECENTLY. ONE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND ONE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THEY
PROVIDED OPTIONAL [inaudible]
FRAMEWORKS.
PROVIDED FOR REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEES.
I EVEN VOTED FOR BOTH OF THOSE
BILLS.
BUT THERE'S A BIG PROBLEM.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CENSUS.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN HAD A CHANCE TO
SEE IF THOSE TWO BILLS.
WHERE APPROPRIATE HELPFUL?
IN.
RESOLVE THE CONCERNS THAT ARE.
WORRIED ABOUT SO COLLEAGUES WITH
WITH THE SENATE BILL ONE THREE
NINE WE HAVE WE HAVE TO JYJ
PROBLEMS.
THE FIRST IS THAT SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF SB ELEVEN OH EIGHT IN
SB.
TEN TWENTY EIGHT WE HAVEN'T HAD
A CENSUS.
SO WE WE NEED TO SEE IF THAT
WORKS FIRST AND IF IT DOESN'T
THEN IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE
COME BACK.
WITH SB ONE THIRTY NINE AND CRAM
DOWN.
THIS NOT OPTIONAL REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION SCHEME ON COUNTIES.
WITH POPULATIONS OVER A CERTAIN
ARBITRARY AMOUNT.
AND IMPOSE THE PREFERRED
APPROACH BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE IN
SACRAMENTO WERE SO MUCH SMARTER
THAN THOSE THAT LIVE IN COUNTIES
OF SAY TEN MILLION PLUS
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
THE CONSTANT ATTACKS NUMBER TWO
ON LOCAL CONTROL IS TOO MUCH AND
THIS IS THE SECOND YOUR LAW.
SO LET COUNTIES TEST RIVE THE
TWO GOOD BILLS ELEVEN OO EIGHT
AND TEN TWENTY EIGHT FIRST.
AND THEN LET'S MAKE TWO WEEKS
AFTER AND THEN WE CAN IMPOSE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
[inaudible]
SENATOR DASCHLE.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I JOIN WITH OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT TO
PUT -- YOU KNOW ONE SIZE FITS
ALL REQUIREMENTS ON OUR STATE
AYE I DO FIND MYSELF -- MOVED BY
THE THE THOUGHTS FROM THE
SENATOR FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY ABOUT TRUST IN GOVERNMENT
AND HOW THAT SO FUNDAMENTAL TO
ALL THAT WE DO.
I DID HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR FIVE IF I MAY.
SENATOR ALLEN.
YOU MAY PROCEED SO THE THE
EAGLES ARE ADMIRABLE -- AND
THAT'S TO CREATE THIS FAIRNESS
STANDARD CAN YOU SPEAK TO WHY
YOU FOR YOUR LIMóN IT -- TO
COUNTIES THAT ARE OVER -- TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND RATHER
THAN HAVING APPLIED TO EVERYONE
EQUALLY.
YEAH SO THE ORIGINAL THOUGHT WAS
IT HAD EVERYTHING TO HAVE COST
WHEN THE BILL FIRST -- CAME
FORWARD WE DID NOT HAVE THIS
PROVISION THAT WAS PUSHED INTO
THE BILL BY THE GOVERNMENTS OF
FINANCE COMMITTEE -- THAT MADE
THE COUNTY BETWEEN TEN FIFTY
THOUSAND SEVENTY THOUSAND
SUBJECT TO CORPORATION -- YOU
KNOW I SO IT'S A THE INITIAL
IDEA WAS THAT FOUR SMALL
COUNTIES -- IT WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT HIT TO THEIR BUDGET --
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO SMALLER
BUDGETS TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF OF HAVING AN
INDEPENDENT DISTRICT COMMISSION
THAT WAS SEPARATE FROM THE OTHER
PROCESSES.
SO THAT WAS YOU THAT WAS THE
THAT WAS THE THOUGHT BEHIND THAT --
IT WAS A IT WAS A COST ISSUE
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER THAT
ON MY OWN TIME -- I WOULD SAY
THAT A LOT OF THINGS WE WANT TO
DO IN THIS BUILDING AND IN OUR
STATE WE CAN ALWAYS DO IT ONCE
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT THERE
IS AN INCREMENTALISM.
THAT COMES INTO OUR WORK WHERE
WE YOU KNOW HAVE TO LIVE MOVE
THINGS IN A SLOWER PACE BUT IF
THIS IS IT THE STANDARD IS
FAIRNESS.
BUT I THINK THAT -- THE AUTHOR
IN HIS GOOD WORK AND AND WE AS A
AS THE ULTIMATE GOVERNING BODY
SHOULD THINK CAREFULLY ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT SMALL COUNTIES
LARGE COUNTIES THAT WE TREAT
THEM THE SAME.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT
EXAMINATION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD OR AND A SUBSEQUENT YEAR
BUT I KNOW THAT THE INTENTIONS
HERE GOOD ONCE AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SENATOR ALLEN YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
YEAH I'VE I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION I I CERTAINLY DO --
SHARE MY MY FRIEND FROM ORANGE
COUNTY I I WILL SAY THAT -- IN
THE END OF THE DAY -- ITS LOCAL
FOLKS ON THE GROUND.
WE NEED THROUGH A LOCALLY DRIVEN
PROCESS WHERE THE BOARD WOULD
HAVE A ROLE ACTUALLY THAT WILL
BE DRAWN THE LINE IS NOT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S NOT PEOPLE SACRAMENTO
DRAWING THE LINES IT'S PEOPLE
LOCAL TO THAT COUNTY TO THAT
AREA WHO'D BE ENGAGED IN THE IN
THE LINE DRY SO IT'S NOT THAT
THEY'RE THERE THIS IS NOT A IT'S
SACRAMENTO TAKING OVER THAT
PROCESS.
BUT WHAT IT DOES DO IS ENSURE.
THAT THE THE MOST SELF
INTERESTED THE FOLKS.
TO WHO.
WHO BENEFIT OR LOSE -- BASED ON
THE WAY THE LINES ARE DRAWN ARE
NOT THE ONES WHO ACTUALLY DRAW
THE LINES THEMSELVES.
THIS IS THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE.
AND WE LIVE WITH HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND I I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE -- THAT IN OUR LARGE
COUNTIES WE DO THE SAME TO
INSURE FAIRNESS IT THEY WILL BE
LOCALLY DRAWN -- BUT BUT
INDEPENDENTLY DRAWN.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECT PRESS
RIVAL.
THE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT OFF HI I CHIANG
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER.
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO BY HER TITLE.
BY.
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LABOR [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN BY PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY WHAT CASKEY.
HI I WINNER.
BY WILK.
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES.
NO [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
DODD.
PRICE TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM SEVENTY THREE WHICH IS SB
ONE FIFTY THREE SENATOR WILK.
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR WILL CONNECT CLAIMED
INDUSTRIAL HEMP AND MAKING IN
PREPARATION THEREFORE
[inaudible] FOUR ZERO THANK YOU
AMOUNT OF PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
SB ONE FIFTY THREE IS A FOLLOW
UP TO LAST YEAR'S AS BE FORTINO
NINE WHICH WAS A BIPARTISAN
MEASURE TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO
GROW INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
CAMPUS INCREDIBLE PLANT IT USES
LESS WATER MOST CROPS.
LITTLE TO NO PESTICIDES.
IT REGENERATES THE SOIL AND IT
SEQUESTERS CARBON AND ISSUES IN
THE MANUFACTURING A TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
SO THAT PASSED AND THEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY DID
SOMETHING THEY PASSED THE NEW
FARM ACT.
AFTER THIS BODY TOOK ACTION LAST
YEAR SO AL THIS BILL DOES IS
BRING US IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
NEW ITERATION OF THE FARM ACT.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THE ROW OF THIS -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS -- MEASURE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
THERE IS A DIRECTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BELL.
HI PORGES.
BRADFORD AYE AYE CABALLERO HI I
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD [inaudible]
BY DORADO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I AMBERG [inaudible]
OUR CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER.
BY WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BURGESS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
MISTER.
ICE THIRTY FIVE NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY FOUR SB ONE SIX THREE
SENATOR PORTANTINO PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACKLEY
AND HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. FOR
YEARS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND SENATORS.
SB ONE SIXTY THREE WILL
ELIMINATE SIGNIFICAN ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS IMPOSED BY HEALTH PLANS.
THAT ARE PREVENTING FAMILIES
FROM ACCESSING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
AUTISM.
RESEARCH HAS CLEARLY SHOWN THE
CHILDREN WITH ASD.
WHO RECEIVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT EARLY CAN SHOW
REMARKABLE PROGRESS THIS BILL
ALSO CODIFIES REQUIREMENTS OF A
QUALIFIED AUTISM SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL AND POWER PER PARA?
PROFESSIONAL STATISTICS TELL US
THAT ONE IN FIFTY NINE CHILDREN
BORN TODAY ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
AUTISM.
EARLY INTERVENTION IS THE KEY TO
HELPING THESE CHILDREN LIVE UP
TO THEIR POTENTIAL.
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
IS A CRITICAL PART OF THAT
CHILD'S DEVELOPMENT AND NEEDS
NOT ALL CHILDREN WITH AUTISM ARE
THE SAME.
SAY THEY RESPOND TO TREATMENT
DIFFERENTLY -- CHILDREN NEED
TREATMENTS TAILORED TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS PRESCRIBED BY
THEIR PHYSICIAN OR PSYCHOLOGIST
WHO KNOWS THEM BEST NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH. EIGHT
YEARS AGO SB NINE FORTY SIX
PASSED THIS HOUSE AND PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE. TO PROVIDE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM.
IT HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS BUT MANY
OTHERS HAVE BEEN PREVENTED FROM
RECEIVING ITS BENEFITS BECAUSE
OF WHAT I BELIEVE WAS A DRAFTING
ERROR.
AN ARTIFICIAL BARRIER -- NOT
EVERY CHILD IS RECEIVING THE
COVERAGE FOR TREATMENT THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER PRESCRIBES
MANY FAMILIES ARE.
HAVING TO GO OUTSIDE AND PAY FOR
THIS PRIVATELY WHEN THEY EVEN
WHEN THEIR DOCTOR PRESCRIBES IT.
THIS IS COVERAGE THAT THEY ARE
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES HAVE PAID
FOR BUT TOO MANY CASES THE
PARENTS ARE LEFT TO COVER THE
COSTS ON THEIR OWN.
ADDITIONALLY FOR MANY CHILDREN
THERE IS A SIX TO TWELVE MONTH
MATING PERIOD.
A WAITING PERIOD FOR THE ONE
TREATMENT THAT HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERS TREATMENT THE LATEST
TREATMENT TONIGHT AND THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE NEED TO GET THAT
TREATMENT AS SOON IN THEIR
DEVELOPMENTAL PROCESS AS THEY
CAN.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRE.
ADDRESSES ROAD BLOCKS THE
COVERAGE -- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR SB ONE SIXTY THREE TO
GET AN AYE VOTE IT'S GOOD FOR
KIDS AND IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THUNDERSTONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE THE PUBLIC
HEARING PROCESS WHEN I WENT INTO --
THE HEALTH HEARING AND THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM PASADENA.
I WAS GOING TO PRESENT THIS BILL --
I WAS ACTUALLY OPPOSED -- BUT
AFTER HEARING HIS TESTIMONY.
AND IN DURING SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT.
MY SON.
HAS HAD TO DEAL WITH WITH HIS
SIX YEAR OLD AUTISTIC DAUGHTER --
THIS BILL STRONGLY RESONATED
WITH ME.
NONE OF US UNLESS YOU.
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
AUTISTIC CAN UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES THAT COME ALONG.
WITH THIS DISORDER.
NOT ONLY IS IT CHALLENGING FOR A
MOTHER AND A FATHER TO DEAL WITH
AN AUTISTIC CHILD.
BUT THE BILL'S THE MEDICAL BILLS
CAN BE.
ALMOST COST PROHIBITIVE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE IS A
SHORTAGE OF BEHAVIORAL
SPECIALISTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT OF VERY
WELL TRAINED PROFESSIONALS THAT
ARE VERY EFFECTIVE.
IN HELPING THESE KIDS -- DO
BETTER.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT MY SIX YEAR
OLD [inaudible]
GRANDDAUGHTER LUKA.
HAS BEEN NON VERBAL. FOR SIX
YEARS AND SHE GETS INTENSE
THERAPY.
FROM SOME OF THE PROVIDERS.
THAT THE GOOD SENATOR IS SAYING
SHOULD BE COVERED BY INSURANCE
AND I'M VERY.
HAPPY TO TELL YOU [inaudible]
THAT MY PAPA ON THE PHONE LAST
NIGHT [inaudible]
WHICH BROUGHT ME TO TEARS
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY THE FIRST
TIME HE'S EVER DRESSED ME.
AS MY FIRST BORN GRANDCHILD
[inaudible]
SO.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT A LOT OF THE
THERAPY THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY.
FOR THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
JUSTIN ON NOT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
HELPFUL.
NOT BECAUSE IT'S NOT THERAPEUTIC.
IT IS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FALL
WITHIN THEIR GUIDELINES.
WHICH IS TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE.
SO THIS BILL THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM PASADENA HAS
BROUGHT FORWARD.
IT'S GOING TO ALLOW FOR A MUCH
EARLIER INTERVENTION AND
THERAPIES THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT BE GIVEN OR NOT AFFORDED.
AND HOPEFULLY ALLOW SOME OF
THESE KIDS. ONE OUT OF FORTY ONE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THE
COMING.
DIAGNOSED WITH THIS.
THIS ILLNESS ON THE SPECTRUM
HOPEFULLY WILL GIVE THEM A FAIR
CHANCE.
AT BECOMING HAPPY PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL AND AGAIN I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR BRING IT
FORWARD.
I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH HOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR YOU DAHLE
VOTE YES ON SB ONE SIXTY THREE
IN MEMORY OF MY GRANDDAUGHTER
LUKA WHO'S DOING VERY WELL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE -- CENTER PORTANTINO YOU
MAY CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT I
WANT -- TO COMPLIMENT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TO MACULA -- WHO --
REALLY TOOK A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH AND AND SHARED HIS
PERSONAL STORY WHICH ADDED BOTH --
HIS SCIENCE BACKGROUND AND HIS
PERSONAL STORY. TO A DEBATE
WHERE THERE IS OPPOSITION
AGAINST THIS BILL AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I'M GONNA
COMPLIMENT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY WHO JUST GAVE ME A
GOOD IDEA AND I'M HOPING MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TO MAKE IT WAS
OPEN MAYBE WE SHOULD.
MEMORIALIZE THIS BILL IN COLLEGE
LUCAS LAW AND SO MAYBE WE'LL
TAKETHAT AMENDMENT IN THE IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY SO --
CHILDREN NEED CARE INSURANCE
SHOULD PAY FOR IT.
AND WE SHOULD RESPECT THAT --
PROCESS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANKS VERY MUCH PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALAN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
HI CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE AYE AYE WITH SO --
TADO.
HI JACKSON.
I JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI HI.
PAN I BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I LIKE OWSKI BY WINNER
[inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST.
DORADO.
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
JONES.
THIS.
WAS WHY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE SB TWO
HUNDRED CENTER MONEY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED A
SENATOR MONNING ACTUALLY IN A
WATER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON -- IT'S
MY HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO RISE
ONCE AGAIN IN SUPPORT OF OUR
PURSUIT.
OF A CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER
SOLUTION. FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
I KNOW YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROBLEM -- TO REVIEW BRIEFLY.
CLOSE TO A MILLION CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS DO NOT HAVE.
THE RIGHT TO TURN ON THE TAP AND
DRINK THE WATER FAITH WITH THE
WATER OR COOK WITH THE WATER.
THIS IS SPREAD.
AROUND ABOUT THREE HUNDRED WATER
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MANY PEOPLE SAY WELL THIS IS A
CENTRAL VALLEY PROBLEM RIGHT.
YES IT'S A PROBLEM IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S A PROBLEM IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY THE PA HOW TO
A VALLEY.
THE NORTHERN BORDER BY OREGON
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
INLAND EMPIRE -- THERE'S NO ONE
COUNTY OR DISTRICT THAT HAS A
CLAIM AN EXCLUSIVE CLAIM.
ON ON SAFE.
CONTAMINATED WATER THE SOURCES
OF CONTAMINANTS RANGE FROM SOME
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS BUT THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY IN THE MINORITY OF
POLLUTANTS.
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE NATURALLY
OCCURRING ARSENIC CHROME AND
CHROMIUM SIX URANIUM LEAD.
THE PROBLEM HAS PERSISTED.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED THE RIGHT TO
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER
RECOGNIZING A HUMAN RIGHT TO
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
BUT THE SOLUTION HAS EVADED S..
I BELIEVE UNTIL NOW.
WE HAVE A STARTING WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN'S LEADERSHIP AND
PRIORITIZING THIS ISSUE --
PICKED UP BY GOVERNOR NEW SOME
WE HAVE.
HIS STATED INTENT. TO FIND A
SOLUTION THIS YEAR.
WE HAVE THE SAME EXPRESSION FROM
THE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
AND NOW WE HAVE THE PRO TEM OF
THE SENATE PRIORITIZING THIS AS
AN ISSUE. FOR OUR STATE SENATE
FOR OUR STATE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT SB TWO
HUNDRED WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND.
IN THE STATE TREASURY.
UNDER.
THE DIRECTION OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD.
YOU CAN READ IN THE BILL THE
DIFFERENT PROVISIONS OF SETTING
UP THE ADMINISTRATIVE APPARATUS
AND THE FUNDING MECHANISM -- TO
MANAGE FUNDS THAT COME IN THERE.
SB.
TWO HUNDRED DOES NOT INCLUDE A
TAX OF FEE OR FUNDING MECHANISM
BUT RATHER LOOKS TO A BUDGET
ALLOCATION.
A RECURRING ALLOCATION OF ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT OF COURSE
TO THE BUDGET -- NEGOTIATIONS
AMONG OUR HOUSES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THIS BILL IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY ESTABLISHES
THE VEHICLE TO SET UP THIS
MECHANISM.
ONCE AND FOR ALL TO GET PEOPLE
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO SAFE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IN THIS STATE.
MEMBERS I KNOW THIS IS A SHARED
OBJECTIVE I BELIEVE SENATE BILL
TWO HUNDRED MOVES US FORWARD AS
A UNITED SENATE BODY. TO
PARTICIPATE WITH VIGOR IN
UPCOMING NEGOTIATIONS TO ONCE
AND FOR ALL DELIVER THE PROMISE
TO THE COMMUNITIES MANY OF HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS. TO BE ABLE.
TO LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY OF
TURNING ON THEIR TAP.
LIKE SO MANY OF US TAKE FOR
GRANTED. TO DRINK CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER MEMBERS I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR BRIDGES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I'D
LIKE TO POSE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THE OFFER.
IF POSSIBLE WOULD YOU EXPECT A
QUESTION YES THANK YOU YOU MAY
PROCEED.
I THANK YOU ARE -- FOR BRING
THIS ITEM YOU AND I HAVE HAD --
A NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF A FUNDING
SOURCE.
I GIVEN THE DRAMATIC NEEDS THAT
WE HAVE A IN THESTATE AND OF
COURSE I ESPECIALLY SENSITIVE
COMING FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ONE OF THE ISSUES -- THAT I WANT
TO JUST GET CLARIFICATION ON
THIS IS EVOLVED OVER TIME
INITIALLY THERE WOULD THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN -- A SERIES OF
INDUSTRY RELATED TAXES WHETHER
BE ON CUSTOMERS ARE DAIRY AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH.
THAT HAS SINCE EVOLVED.
IN TWO NOW WE ARE IN A SITUATION
WHERE THIS IS NOT A TAX THIS IS
A GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION.
THAT IS CORRECT ALL RIGHT HERE'S
HERE'S MY MY MY LASTING A
RESERVATION [inaudible]
IS.
ARE WE EXPECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OR SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. FOR THAT
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION TO BE
OFFSET BY SOME OTHER FORM OF TAX
THAT WOULD BE USED TO FUND IT.
THAT IS A FAIR QUESTION.
SHOULD THAT HAPPEN IN THE
PROCESS OF NEGOTIATIONS.
SENATE BILL.
TWO HUNDRED WOULD COME BACK TO
THIS BODY.
IF IT WERE THE VEHICLE THAT WERE
AMENDED AND WE'D HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THAT.
IN RE VOTE ON AN AMENDED BILL
WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY IS A
VEHICLE THAT IS EXPLICIT.
IN INDICATING THAT THIS WOULD BE
FUNDED BY A BUDGET ALLOCATION OF
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
PER YEAR RECURRING ALLOCATION I
DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL YOUR
QUESTION IS A FAIR.
ONE I CAN'T PREDICT WHAT MIGHT
OF ALL OF BUT I CAN TELL YOU THE
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY.
IS TO ESTABLISH THE APPARATUS.
IMPLEMENT A FUNDED SAFE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FUND OKAY --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR THAT --
I THINK YOU CAN SENSE MY ANXIETY --
ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT HITS
HOME SO SO GREATLY -- I WAS --
INITIALLY SUPPORTIVE OF BUT THE
SENATOR FROM THE ANOTHER CENTER
FROM THE VALLEY'S -- PROPOSAL
PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT WASN'T A
TAX IN NOW THAT YOURS IS IN THAT
SITUATION AS WELL THIS MAKES IT
FAR MORE APPEALING.
BUT I CANNOT OVERSTATE.
AND ASK UPON -- ASK YOUR YOUR
EMPLOYER PLAN YOUR GOOD NATURE
TO FOR ADDITIONAL CONFIRMATIONS
BUT THIS IS NOT A TROJAN HORSE
THAT WE'LL.
ARE EVOLVE INTO SOMETHING
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
AND COME BACK AND AND GO AGAINST
THE CONCERNS LOOK IT'S A FAIR
QUESTION I CAN'T STAND HERE AND
GIVE YOU MY WORD WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN.
IN NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE TWO
HOUSES IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THAT'S NOT MY ROLE MY ROLE IS TO
GET A MECHANISM THAT WE CAN FIND.
A BUDGET ALLOCATED RECURRING
BUDGET ALLOCATION TO FUNDS THIS
THAT'S WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US IF
IT GETS CHANGED IT HAS TO COME
BACK.
AS AS OPERATION OF LAW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THAT GIVES ME A
LOT MORE -- ON A CONFIDENCE
AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR INCREASE
[inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW -- WE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN WORKING FOR MANY YEARS
TRYING TO RE FRAME IN A NUMBER
OF CONTACTS WATER POLICY -- AND
WE HAVE IGNORED SOME OF THE
UNDERLYING.
SOCIAL SOCIAL ISSUES AND OTHER
ISSUES DEALING WITH WATER
QUALITY WE HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB
I THINK IN DEALING WITH SOME OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
TRYING TO MITIGATE THE AMOUNT OF
WATER TRANSFERS WITH IT WAS IN
THE COLORADO RIVER OR FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHECK MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
TO GO MAGICALLY REDUCING THE
WATER CONSUMPTION BY PASSING A
SERIES OF CONSUMPTION BILLS
CHECK DON WHERE DID DIESEL OUR
RESERVATION WERE WORKING IN THAT
FIELD AND WE'RE WORKING ON STORM
WATER AND WATER RECYCLING.
BUT THE BIG HOLE THE BIG
EQUITABLE HOLE HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED -- IN THESE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS IN THE IN VERY
ELOQUENT WAY AND TREMENDOUS HARD
WORK BY THE CENTER FOR MODERATE.
WHAT HE IS DONE AND HOW YOU
STRUCTURED THIS THE KIND OF
COALITION IT'S BEEN BILLED? TO
TO TO SUPPORT THIS THE IN EQUITY
MENTIONED THE THREE HUNDRED
WATER DISTRICTS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT ALL THE TIME AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
AND WORKING IN THE SEWER ISSUES
AND SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES.
THAT ARE PART OF THE LARGER
ARCHITECTURE OF THIS ISSUE BUT
NOTHING HITS IT IS SQUARE.
AS THIS MEASURE BEFORE US I
THINK IT IS BRILLIANT I GIVE
GREAT CREDIT TO THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS EXTRAORDINARY WORK THE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS
PUT IN.
THE WORK ON THIS MEASURE AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ALL I'VE NOT BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF SB TWO HUNDRED AS
IT MOVES THROUGH THE TWO
COMMITTEES THAT I MONO VIA MAIL
QUALITY.
IN APPROPRIATIONS BUT TODAY I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM CARMEL MONTEREY -- FOR HIS
LAB PASSION FOR THIS ISSUE ARE
SO I AM PREPARED TO VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE IT RIGHTFULLY USES
GENERAL FUND.
DOLLARS NOT A WATER TAX AS THE
FUNDING SOURCE.
I THINK SENATE THE SENATOR HAS
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT WE DO
NEED TO FIX THE WATER QUALITY
ISSUES AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
CERTAINLY IN SYNC WITH OUT --
BUT THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION OF THAT'S IN THE
SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL
THOROUGHLY GOES A LONG WAY --
TOWARDS DOING JUST THAT.
I AM PLEASED THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT INCLUDE A TAX ON WATER AND
I'D LIKE TO SHARE THAT -- THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ARE NOW IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO HUNDRED FOR THE SAME
REASON -- WITH THESE RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS I CERTAINLY ASKREN
AYE VOTE AND SB.
TWO HUNDRED SENATOR HEARING TINA.
THANK YOU A MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
HUNDRED ALSO RISE TO TO
COMPLIMENT -- THE AUTHOR FROM A
MONTEREY WHOSE LIFE'S PASSION IT
IS TO HELP CALIFORNIA HAVE SAFE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND SENATE
LEADERSHIP AND MY COLLEAGUES.
FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
WHO OF ALL SORT OF WORKED IN
CONCERT ON THIS CRAFTING THIS
SENATE PLAN TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
WITHOUT A TAX.
AND SO OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL LEFT
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
IN ITS CURRENT FORM BECAUSE OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE HAD DONE SUCH A
GOOD JOB TO FIND RESOURCES IN
THE GENERAL FUND. TO PAY FOR IT
AND THE QUESTIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE THE PASSION IN THE
ANSWERS -- I THINK IT SAYS A LOT
ABOUT THIS BODY TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT AN ISSUE TO
DEVELOP THE TRUST ANYTHING THAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO THIS BILL
PROSPECTIVELY WOULD HAVE TO COME
BACK. FOR A VOTE IF IT HAD ANY
OTHER PROVISIONS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE TWO THIRDS SO I THINK
THERE'S A THERE'S AN ELEMENT OF
A SAFETY I KNOW IT'S NOT THE
INTENTION. TO DO ANYTHING BUT
USE THE GENERAL FUND TO FUND
THIS LAUDABLE PURPOSE AND AGAIN
COMPLEMENT THE QUESTIONERS FOR
CERTAINLY THE PASSION.
OF THE AUTHOR AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR FINDING A CREATIVE
SOLUTION TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
USING GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
SCIENCE TO SEE AYE SICKLY
SUPPORT SB [inaudible]
TWO HUNDRED SENATOR NIELSEN.
BUT A PRESERVATION GENTLE WITH
THE SENATE.
MY ISSUE.
IS TRUST [inaudible]
NOT.
IN THIS HOUSE.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS HOUSE HAS
TAKEN A STEADFAST.
POSITION A RESPONSIBLE.
POSITION.
AS I SEE IT.
BUT AS I LOOK AT THE ENTIRETY OF
THE PROCESS.
AND I LOOK AT MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OVER YEARS HERE
PROTECTING IN RECENT YEARS OF
AGREEMENTS ROCKED.
BETWEEN BOTH PARTIES.
AND ONE PARTY.
HAVING KEPT AS WERE THE OTHER
PARTY SAYING WELL THINGS CHANGED.
THANKS CHANGE THE NEXT YEAR.
THEN THAT WHICH WE DID NOT
ANTICIPATE.
WHICH DID NOT HAVE THE VOTES THE
TIME ALL OF A SUDDEN THINGS
CHANGE BUT ONLY FOR ONE PARTY.
NOT FOR THE OTHER PART.
THEY QUITE FRANKLY REPUBLICANS
HAVE BEEN DUPED.
AT THEIR POLITICAL PERIL.
BY PLACING AN MISPLACING THEIR
TRUST.
IT'S A BIG DEAL ITEM HERE
[inaudible]
THE ORGANIZATIONS.
MY OWN INDUSTRY AGRICULTURE.
HAS LONG HAD ITS TRUST BREACHED.
END QUOTE DEALS MADE.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
AND WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND I'M SORRY TO BE SUCH A
SKEPTIC.
IN A CYNIC.
THAT IS NOT MY NATURE.
BUT WE SEEM TO MANY OF THESE
THINGS AND I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
THOUGHT.
THIS WILL COME BACK IN ANY
SIMILAR FORM WHAT SO EVER IF IT
COMES AND IT WILL ONLY COME FOR
CONCURRENCE.
IN ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS.
MIGHT GET REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
BUT I DOUBT THAT VERY MUCH OF
THE BEST YOU'RE GOING TO GET IS
A SHOT AT ON THE FLOOR.
I DO URGE A NO VOTE [inaudible]
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
HI DAVE PROUDLY SERVED ON THE
RED FLORA NOW GOING INTO MY
FIFTH YEAR.
AND I CAN MAKE [inaudible]
ONE IMPORTANT [inaudible]
CONCLUSION.
AND THAT IS -- MY MY FRIEND THE
SENATOR FROM CARMEL.
IN MY VIEW.
IS A MAN OF HONOR.
HE'S BEEN A MAN OF TRUTH.
HE'S BEEN A MAN OF PASSION.
AND HE'S ALWAYS KEPT HIS WORD.
AND WHAT I'VE WITNESSED OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS THAT HE IS A MAN
THAT IS THOUGHTFUL.
ABOUT THOSE THAT ARE LESS
FORTUNATE THAN HIMSELF
[inaudible]
OR US.
I ALSO BELIEVE THE CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER SHOULD BE A RIGHT.
NOT A LUXURY.
BUT A RIGHT.
WE ALL KNOW.
THAT WE HAVE.
A BLESSED REVENUE STREAM COMING
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TWENTY ONE BILLION IS ESTIMATED
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT WE THOUGHT
WE WOULD HAVE.
AND AS ALL OF YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING INTO OUR BUDGET
HEARINGS VERY SURELY THE BUDGET.
IS REALLY.
A REFLECTION OF OUR PRIORITIES
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
IT IS ALSO.
A REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES.
MAKING THIS A GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE.
REFLECTS NOT ONLY THE VALUES I
THINK OF ALL OF US ON THE RED
FLOOR RED CARPET TODAY.
BUT IT'S ALSO REPRESENTED OF THE
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT THE ALSO BELIEVE.
THAT WE SHOULD PROVIDING SAFE
DRINKING WATER [inaudible] TO
EVERYONE.
NOW TELL YOU THAT IF WE ARE BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHT OR
NINE WHEN WE HAD [inaudible]
HISTORIC DEFICITS.
AND WHILE I CAN TELL YOU I
HAVEN'T VOTED FOR TAX IN TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OF BEING AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
I CAN TELL YOU BACK THEN IF I
WAS ON THE RED CARPET AND WE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE A TAX TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
PEOPLE HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED
ONE AS LONG AS A WAS A
REGRESSIVE ON THE POOREST OF
PEOPLE THEY WERE TRYING TO HELP.
THAT IT WAS PASSED ON MAYBE SOME
MORE -- HIGHER INCOME.
EARNERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE THE
CASES WE CAN WELL AFFORD.
THIS POCKET CHANGE IF YOU WILL.
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THOSE REASONS
I HIGHLY RECOMMEND IT TO VOTE
YES ON SB [inaudible]
TWO HUNDRED CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
SERVED WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CARMEL IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THOUGH WE OFTEN DISAGREED ON
MANY ISSUES -- HE'S ALWAYS BEEN
HONORABLE AND TRUTHFUL EVEN IF I
DIDN'T LIKE TO HEAR WHAT HE HAD
TO SAY.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT I HAVE FULL
FAITH AND CONFIDENCE THAT.
IF HIS BILL GETS OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY WHERE IT STATES ON AND
PAGE [inaudible]
TEN SORRY.
LITTLE VEIN I WANT -- GLASSES
ALL THE TIME.
SO I'M PAGE TEN LINE ITEM THIRTY
THREE IT SAYS THIS DOES NOT
IMPOSE A LEVY CHARGE EXTRACTION
OF ANY KIND SUCH AS A TAX OR A
FEAT.
THAT LANGUAGES IN THIS BILL ON
PAGE TEN LINE ITEM THIRTY THREE
AND THIRTY FOUR IF THEY
DECIMATED IN THE ASSEMBLY WHICH
SOMETIMES THEY TEND TO DO WE
KNOW THAT BILL WILL COME BACK TO
THIS HOUSE.
AND I'M SURE THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL MAKE SURE THAT AND IT IS
TAKING CARE OF SO THAT THE VOTES
THAT WE GIVE ON THIS SIDE.
ARE NOT JEOPARDIZED I THINK THAT
HE WILL HONOR HIS WORD I DON'T
THINK I KNOW HE WILL HONOR HIS
WORD.
I KNOW THAT WITH A TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS AND I
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO ONE IN OUR
CAUCUS THERE'S GOING TO VOTE FOR
A TAX INCREASE -- IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM BECAUSE THERE'S
TOO MANY TAXES THAT ARE PAID BY
CALIFORNIANS IN 53% OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
CITY CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE HERE
BECAUSE OF THE REGRESSIVE TAXES
THAT WE HAVE.
SO I HAVE TOTAL FAITH AND
CONFIDENCE IN THE AUTHOR WHO IS
GOING TO GET THIS BILL OFFICE
FLOOR.
IT OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY INTACT
AND THEN THE DEAL IS GOING TO GO
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROVIDE RELIABLE SAFE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER FIRST
PEOPLE AROUND THE STATE
INCLUDING IN OUR DISTRICT WHERE --
SOME OF THE NORTHERN PART OF OUR
DISTRICT CAN'T EVEN TURN ON
THEIR TAP WATER AND HAVE WATER
COME OUT SO I THINK THE AUTHOR.
FOR OF OF VERY.
MEDIAEVAL GOOD SOLUTION CREATIVE
THAT CAME TOGETHER OUT OF THIS
DISCUSSION AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR
DOING THIS ARE AND I AM HONORED
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYONE ON THIS FLOOR THAT DOUBTS
THE TRUSTWORTHINESS
STEADFASTNESS OF OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM CARMEL -- BUT BUT THERE IS
CONCERN I JOIN WITH MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES -- IN THE
SENATOR FROM FRESNO AND HAVING
SOME TREPIDATION AS TO WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I DO
TRUST THAT.
SENATOR FROM CARMEL WILL DO HIS
UTMOST TO ENSURE THAT THE BILL
REMAINS WITHOUT THE TAX AND FEE
THAT IT HAS TODAY -- BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT WE SEND A
MESSAGE NOT JUST FROM
REPUBLICANS BUT ALSO FROM AT
LEAST ONE DEMOCRAT AND I THINK
OTHERS.
THAT SHOULD THIS BILL RETURN
WITH A TAX INCREASE OR FEES SUCH
AS ONE FEARS THAT THERE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT VOTES ON THIS FLOOR.
TO TURN IT BACK -- THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT [inaudible]
SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS I JUST -- WANT TO THANK
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM CARMEL FOR
HIS -- THIS WILL TREMENDOUS WORK
ON THIS ISSUE FOR NOT JUST THIS
BILL BUT FOR FOR MANY YEARS AND
I THINK WE ALWAYS HEARD AND
TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLEAN DRINKING WATER CERTAINLY
IS A PHYSICIAN AND BACKGROUND
PUBLIC HEALTH I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF LIKE.
THE FUNDAMENTAL THING WE TALK
ABOUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
TO KEEP YOURSELF HEALTHY WELL.
IT'S A CLEAN WATER SANITATION
AND VACCINATIONS SO THERE'S A
TOP ONCE AND SO I THINK I REALLY
OF WANTED OF SLIDE MY GOOD
FRIEND I APPRECIATE.
THE FOLKS -- FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE TALKING ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT PEOPLE OF
ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER -- I ALSO
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT -- THE KERR
BILL AS IT CURRENTLY IS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DEBATE -- DOES
NOT INCLUDE TAX OR FEE -- AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WHAT WE AND WE
AND WE'RE GONNA BE DEBATING A
BUDGET LATER ON WILL -- AND
LOOKING AT FUNDING THROUGH THAT
MECHANISM BUT I THINK WHAT'S
MOST IMPORTANT WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE IS IS THAT WE NEED TO
ACHIEVE THAT OUTCOME THAT -- A
GOOD FRIEND FROM CARMEL AND I
HOPE ALL OF US SHARE OF BEING
SURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS.
TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER LATER
TONIGHT BUT SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO HUNDRED AND IN
ON AM PROUD AND LOOK FOR TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
DISCUSS THISITEM IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE STATE BUDGET I THINK IT'S
ALSO.
IMPORTANT WE ALL REMEMBER THAT
WE ARE A BI CAMERAL -- HOUSE
DATA WE TO HAVE BILLS ON THE
OTHER SIDE THAT WE HOPE OUR
LEAGUES -- CAN HAVE FAITH AND
CONFIDENCE IN THE POWER OF THE
COLLECTIVE INSTITUTION TO ACT
RESPONSIBLY WITH OUR LEGISLATION
AS WE DO WITH THEIR SOLD THAT'S
NOT A A A A BIGGER I'M GONNA
POKE.
IN TERMS OF MY LACK OF
CONFIDENCE OF THEIR CAPACITY I
I'LL LOOK FORWARD TO THE DEBATE
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE BUDGET.
I'LL BE VOTING I TODAY.
THING NO FURTHER -- DEBATE.
MADAM PRO TEM.
THANK YOU -- MEN.
PRESIDENT AND I WON'T BE
DEBATING I YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT.
BUT I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CARMEL I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NUMBER OF
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY.
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE FOR
YEARS.
I IT IS ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE
AND THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD THE LARGEST STATE.
THAT THERE ARE RESIDENTS THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS -- TO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
I IT IS JUST NOT SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF AND WE ARE
PROUD OF SO MUCH IN THE STATE.
I'VE HEARD YOUR CONVERSATION
TODAY AND THE DIALOGUE IT IS
WHAT I ANTICIPATED.
IT IS I THINK WHAT WE HAVE KNOWN
THAT THIS IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE AND I IT IS THE
REASON WE'VE TAKEN THE APPROACH
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A BUDGET PROCESS I WANT
TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE BUDGET
CHAIR.
THE VICE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT HAVE TAKEN THIS
ISSUE ON I WANNA -- SAY AN
ADDITIONAL I THANK YOU TO MY
SEAT MATE AND COLLEAGUES.
FOR BEING WILLING TO BE FLEXIBLE
AND AND SHIFT.
THE CONVERSATION AS NEEDED TO
GET THIS DONE.
I AS WELL AS OUR PRESIDING
OFFICER I AS I SAID BEFORE -- A
NUMBER OF US HAVE SEEN THIS
ISSUE AND WANTED TO ADDRESS IT
YOU KNOW I I ASSURE YOU AS THE
PERSON WHO WILL.
BE HAVING THE CONVERSATIONS
AFTER OUR BUDGET.
ARE THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE --
IS IN THE MIDST OF THEIR WORKING
CONCLUDING THAT THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSIBLE -- DIPLOMATIC
CONVERSATIONS WILL BE HELD WITH
OUR GOVERNOR AND OUR SPEAKER
ABOUT HOW WE GET THIS DONE.
FINALLY HOW WE GET THIS DONE.
BUT WE CAN'T SPEAK FOR WHAT
FUTURE YEARS MAY MEAN.
I IN TERMS OF HOW IT MAY BE MORE
FOR WE'RE HERE THIS YEAR SOME OF
US WILL BE HERE NEXT YEAR.
BUT REALLY WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
NOT POSTPONE THIS.
CRITICAL ISSUE ANY FURTHER WE
NEED TO TAKE RESPONSIBLE ACTION
AND I APPRECIATE -- THE
CONVERSATION THECOMMENTS OF
COLLEAGUES -- FROM BOTH OUR
POLITICAL PARTIES AND
PERSUASIONS IT IS HEARTENING TO
SEE THAT PEOPLE REALLY ARE
TRYING TO COME TO A POINT WHERE
WE WORK TOGETHER. TO GET
SOMETHING DONE AND I HAVE EVERY
FAITH AND REASON TO BELIEVE --
THAT ARE GOVERNOR AND THE
SPEAKER AND OUR COLLEAGUES -- IN
THE ASSEMBLY. ONE AS MUCH THE
SAME THING SO TOGETHER WE CAN
GET THIS DONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE ON THIS CONVERSATION
I'VE HEARD WHAT YOU'VE HAD. TO
SAY TODAY AND I WILL TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THIS DISCUSSION.
URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL -- COULD I
CLOSE YES I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
AND AS PART OF MY CLOTHES I
WANNA THANK MADAM PRESIDENT AS
THE PRO TIM DID FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
AND SOME RELATED EFFORTS THAT
WOULD HELP FACILITATE.
THIS IMPLEMENTATION.
I WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE THE
COLLEAGUES WHO DIDN'T SPEAK --
BUT REALLY SHOWING A SHARED
COMMITMENT TO SOLVING THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND AGAIN I WILL JUST CLOSE BY
REPEATING.
THE THIS BILL SETS UP.
A FIND IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
MECHANISM IT FACES FURTHER STEPS
IN NEGOTIATIONS IN THE ASSEMBLY
IN WITH THE GOVERNOR.
BUT THE VOTE TODAY ONE POWER OUR
BUDGET CHAIR AND ARE PRO TEM IN
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS TO CONVEY THE
WILL.
OF THIS BODY THAT'S HOW OUR
PROCESS WORKS IF ANYTHING IS
AMENDED I WILL BE THE FIRST TO
SHARE THAT WITH YOU.
AND WE HAVE A SEVENTY TWO HOUR
IN PRINT RULE NOBODY WILL BE
CAUGHT OFF GUARD SHOULD THE BILL
MORE IF IN A DIFFERENT FASHION I
CAN'T PREDICT.
ITS FUTURE TO YOU TODAY I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT WHAT WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD TODAY IS WHAT'S
IN PRINT.
AND REPRESENTS.
WHAT I THINK IS AN OVERWHELMING
WILL OF THIS BODY ONE THING I
DIDN'T MENTION IN MY OPENING?
WAS AMONG CONTAMINATED WATER
SYSTEMS INCLUDE MANY SCHOOLS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WHILE THIS IS NOT THE TIME FOR
FORMAL INTRODUCTIONS WE HAVE
SOME TEACHERS FROM OAKLAND.
WHO TEACH MY GRAND CHILDREN IN
OAKLAND PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND -- I
JUST WANNA LET THOSE TEACHERS
AROUND THE STATE NOW THAT WE
HAVE THE BEST INTEREST OF
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND STAFF AT
HEART IS WELL SO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I HEARD YOUR AYE
VOTE ON S. B..
TWO HUNDRED YOUR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL BY PORCHES.
HI.
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL FIVE I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
HI DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO AYE -- TITLE
AYE AYE JACKSON.
AYE JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LABOR.
HI MCGUIRE WHEN I MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONNING.
HI I'M MORE LOCK.
RAIL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO.
HI ROB.
I RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN.
BY STONE.
HI NUMBER.
I LIKE OUT SEE.
I WINNER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
BY.
PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GROVE.
BY.
MORE LOCK.
HI. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ONE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE MOVING
ON TO ITEM.
ONE TWENTY TWO WHICH IS SB TWO
ZERO SIX BY SENATOR SKINNER
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO OH SIX BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO COLLEGIATE ATHLETES.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN THE HBO DOCUMENTARY.
THAT'S A HEARING NOW ACTUALLY
WILL CONTINUE TO MAY TWENTY SIX
CALLED THE STUDENT ATHLETE
PRODUCED BY LEBRON JAMES.
THE DOCUMENTARY UNVEILS THE
COMPLEX WORLD OF THE MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR COLLEGE SPORTS
ENTERPRISE.
AND THE IMPACT IT IS HAVING ON
UNPAID STUDENT ATHLETES AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
SB TWO ZERO SIX ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA TO CORRECT THAT
DEEPLY UNFAIR AND EXPLOITATIVE
SET OF RULES.
IT STOPS THE ONE AND ONLY ONE
CATEGORY OF STUDENTS MEETING THE
RULES.
FROM ANY EARNINGS BASED ON THEIR
TALENTS.
MUSIC MAJORS COMPUTER SCIENCE
MAJORS ENGINEERING MAJORS ARE
FREE TO USE THEIR TALENTS.
AND IN INCOME NOT COLLEGE
ATHLETES.
SB TO THE ZERO SIX DOES NOT
REQUIRE OUR COLLEGES TO PAY
ATHLETES DIRECTLY.
IT'S SIMPLY AFFORDS COLLEGE
ATHLETES THE SAME RIGHTS THAT
OLYMPIC ATHLETES ARE GIVEN AND
NOTE OLYMPIC ATHLETES ARE ALSO
CONSIDERED IMMATURE.
SO THIS IS NOT PROFESSIONAL ICE
OR COLLEGE ATHLETICS AND IN FACT
MAY RESULT IN ENCOURAGING SOME
OF OUR STUDENTS TO STAY IN
SCHOOL RATHER THAN THE
MOTIVATION TO GO PRO EARLY
BECAUSE IT'S THE ONLY WAY TO
EARN AN INCOME.
I'M JUST LIKE OLYMPIC ATHLETES
SB TWO OH SIX WOULD ALLOW
STUDENT ATHLETES AND
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
COLLEGES -- TO MAKE EARNINGS
FROM THEIR NAME IMAGE OR
LIKENESS.
IN COMMITTEE WE HEARD PASSIONATE
TESTIMONY FROM A VOLLEYBALL
PLAYER AT STANFORD.
HALEY HUDSON I BRING HER UP
BECAUSE I IMAGINE MANY PEOPLE
ARE THINKING THIS BILL PROBABLY
ONLY BENEFITS.
THEN THE MEN ATHLETES MEANING
THE BASKETBALL PLAYERS THE
WE'VE HEARD ALMOST MORE FROM
FEMALE ATHLETES.
AND WHAT HALEY HARD TO DESCRIBE
SHE WAS THE NUMBER ONE PICK IN
THE U. S. FOR VOLLEYBALL.
SHE DECIDED TO ATTEND STANFORD.
AND APPS STANFORD.
IN PLAIN.
SHE WAS INJURED.
AND DUE TO THAT INJURY SHE HAD
TO STOP HER ATHLETICS.
NOW SHE WAS OFFERED BECAUSE SHE
WAS THE NUMBER ONE FEMALE
VOLLEYBALL PLAYER IN THE US SHE
WAS OFFERED -- SPONSORSHIPS AND
SUCH SHE COULD NOT TAKE THEM AND
BE ABLE TO PLAY FOR STANFORD.
AND NOW WITH HER NO LONGER BEING
ABLE TO PLAY DUE TO HER INJURY
SHE'S PREVENTED FROM EVER
GAINING ANY OF THOSE EARNINGS
THAT SHE MIGHT OF RECOUP.
FROM HER ATHLETIC TALENTS NOW I
GIVE YOU THE EXAMPLE OF MISSY
FRANKLIN KATIE LEDECKY BOTH
OLYMPIC ATHLETES BOTH AVAILABLE
TO GET SPONSORSHIPS DUE TO THEIR
OLYMPIC RIGHTS.
BUT BOTH WHO PLAYED FOR
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES MISSY
FRANKLIN CHOSE TO SWIM FOR CAL
BERKELEY.
AND SHE DECIDED TO SWIM ALL FOUR
YEARS AND FOR GO HER RIGHT TO
MAKE ANY MONEY FROM.
WHICH SHE WAS ABLE TO AS AN
OLYMPIC ATHLETE.
AT THE END OF HER CAL CAREER SHE
INJURED HERSELF SHE IS NOW NOT
BEING ABLE TO GO PRO SHE CAN
MAKE NO MONEYOFF FOR TALENT.
KATIE LEDECKY WHO SWAM FOR
STANFORD WHAT'S THAT AND AFTER
TWO YEARS OF SWIMMING FOR
STANFORD QUIT THE STANFORD TEAM
AND IS NOW UTILIZING HER.
OLYMPIC RIGHTS TO MAKE MONEY.
SO SB TWO ZERO SIX JUST ALLOWS
US TO CORRECT THAT ON FEAR.
IT'S GOOD FOR OUR STUDENTS IT'S
GOOD FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
THIRTY NIELSEN.
NOT A PRESENT LAID JEALOUS
SENATE FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
OUR COLLEGE ATHLETES HAVE GOT
ALONG VERY WELL.
WITHOUT GETTING PAID.
BY HAVING AMATEURS.
STATUS IF YOU WILL.
MAYBE YOU'VE PAID SOME ATTENTION
TO WHAT'S GOING ON OVER THE LAST
FEW DECADES IN PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS.
BUT THE MORE ABLE ATHLETES.
ALL SIGNING UP AGENTS.
AS COLLEGE STUDENTS NOW IT WILL
BEGIN TO SIGN UP AGENTS OR THEY
RATHER WILL BE SIGNING UP.
THE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
IT'LL BE ONE OF MY BED TIME. ONE
OF MY BIT.
AND WHEN YOU INTERJECT.
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT WILL BE ON THE MINDS OF
THESE ATHLETES.
AS IS ON THE MINDS OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES.
YOU'RE GONNA CHANGE THE DYNAMICS
[inaudible]
OF SPORTS.
THERE IS RELEASED THE BASKIN
[inaudible]
OF HOPE.
IN THE SPIRIT.
THE DEDICATION OF COMPETITION TO
AMATEURISM.
THE LIVE YET TODAY.
SO WHAT NEXT.
ON MARCH MOST TALENTED.
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
YEAH I BET IN TEN YEARS.
IT'LL COME TO PASS.
I URGE.
THE NOBLE [inaudible]
SENATOR WELLS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB. TWO OH SIX I TYPICALLY DO
NOT LIKE CALIFORNIA ONLY BILLS
BUT THIS IS A SITUATION THAT
CRIES OUT FOR JUSTICE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THE NC
DOUBLE A IS A BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY ARE THE LAST FIGURE I
COULD FIND FOR THE NC DOUBLE A
BASKETBALL TOURNAMENT.
SOME PEOPLE MAY SAY THE SUPER
BOWLS THE MOST ICONIC AMERICAN
SPORTING EVENT I THINK IT'S THE
BASKETBLL TOURNAMENT.
AND THEY MADE. SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS YET THEY HAVE THEIR
STUDENT ATHLETES -- STAR.
AT THE END AND NOT NOT PROPERLY
CLOTHES AND AND NOT PROPERLY
TAKEN CARE OF SO WITH THE TAX
MATTERS IF YOU LOOK AT THE STATS
1%.
OF ALL WOMEN COLLEGE BASKETBALL
PLAYERS ARE GOING TO END UP IN
THE W. NBA.
AND LESS THAN 2% OF MEN --
WHETHER IT'S BASKETBALL FOOTBALL
OR SOCCER PLAY AT THE
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL.
THE FACT OF MATTER IS THERE'S A
LOT THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF
CORPORATE.
PEOPLE.
MAKING CORPORATE DOLLARS AND
THEY ARE NOT SHARING THE WEALTH
PROPERLY THESE STUDENT ATHLETES
ARE TREATED LIKE A CHATTEL AND
IT HAS TO STOP AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB [inaudible]
TWO OH SIX SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO SUPPORT SB TWO
US SIX AND COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD -- I
DON'T THINK THERE'S A BIGGER
SPORTS FAN -- IN THE SENATE THAN
MYSELF I LOVE COLLEGE SPORTS I
REPRESENT THE ROSE BOWL -- AND
HAVE BEEN MY ENTIRE LIFE
FOLLOWING COLLEGE SPORTS -- AND
YOU KNOW I GOT CALLS FROM
ATHLETIC DIRECTORS FROM THE
MAJOR PAC TEN SCHOOLS ASKING ME.
TO HOLD THIS BILL IN SUSPENSE
BECAUSE THEY WERE WORRIED THAT
IT WAS GOING -- TO HAVE A
CHILLING EFFECT ON ATHLETES BUT
THE AUTHOR HAS MADE SUCH A
COMPELLING CASE ON THE NEED TO
BRING SOME FAIRNESS AND CLARITY
AND AND JUST BRING THE THE UNDER
THE TABLE CASH ASPECTS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING COLLEGE SPORTS.
ON TOP OF THE TABLE -- AND IN
RESPONSE TO THAT WE'VE SEEN THAT
THE ANTI TO A HAS ALREADY
INITIATED A COMMITTEE BASED ON
THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL TO
LOOK AT THIS EFFORT NOW WE HAVE
TO ENSURE THAT THAT IS NOT JUST.
A AS AVERAGE **** USED TO CALL
THEM A GOFFIN TO TO HIDE OUR R.
I. FROM THE TRUE.
PRIZE AND THE WAY TO DO THAT I
THOUGHT WAS TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL FOR
THREE YEARS SO THE NCTO A KNOWS
THAT.
THE AUTHOR ISN'T GOING AWAY THIS
ISSUE AS A GOING AWAY AND IF
THEY DON'T SOLVE THIS PROBLEM IN
THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
THESE PROVISIONS WILL BE CALM
LAWN APPLICABLES TO STUDENT
ATHLETES ON IN THE PAC TWELVE
AND THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS THE PRESSURE THAT WE
NEED TO PUT ON THE NC TO A TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THIS COMMITMENT AND I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR A FOR
INTRODUCING IT AND BE FOR BEING
WILLING TO ACCEPT.
THAT DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
BECAUSE IT GETS TO THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
WHICH IS HOLD THE NC TWO EIGHT
FEET. TO THE FIRE SO STUDENT
ATHLETES ARE PROTECTED IN A IN A
REASONABLE FAIR WAY IN OUR
RIGHTS TO SUPPORT SB TWO US.
SIX SENATOR BRADFORD.
WE RUN OUR LIKE.
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE FEAR
PAID TO PLAY AN ACT -- MAJORITY
OF THESE ATHLETES ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN -- MOST THE TIME
MAKE UP LESS THAN 3% OF COLLEGE
UNDERGRADS BUT 50% OF THE
FOOTBALL AND BASKETBALL TEAMS.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN PUT **** IN
THE SEATS OF ARENAS AND STADIUMS
ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
THEY MAKE THE UNIVERSITY TO MAKE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON SELLING
THEIR JERSEYS.
THERE ARE -- OTHER FROM OP NOW
YOU'RE FROM THE UNIVERSITY
BECAUSE OF THERE.
SUCCESS ON AND OFF THE FIELD BUT
THESE ATHLETES BENEFIT NOT.
ONE DIME I THINK IT'S A MATTER%
SPORTS FOLKS THIS IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE.
THIS IS A FAIRNESS ISSUE THIS IS
A BOUT PEEN OUR ALLOWING SOMEONE
TO MAKE A LIVING I WENT TO
COLLEGE WITH A LOT OF GUYS WHO.
PLAYED SPORTS AND THEY STRUGGLED
I MEAN THEY STRUGGLE.
TO STAINED GLASS IN IT DESPITE
HAVING A SCHOLARSHIP AND I%
COULDN'T EARN EXTRA MONEY
COULDN'T TAKE JOBS.
DURING THE SEASONS AND THEY LOOK
REALLY STRUGGLE BUT NOW YOU HAVE
COLLEGE COACHES MAKING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
THESE COLLEGE COACH MILLIONAIRES
ARE GOING INTO THE YOUNG MAN'S
HOMES RECRUITING AND WITH THE
PROMISE OF ALL THE WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS TO OFFER AND MANY
TIMES.
AGAIN.
VERY FEW OF THESE FOLKS EVER
MAKE IT TO THE PROFESSIONAL
LEVEL SO I THINK THEY SHOULD GET
THEIR DO WHILE THEY'RE STILL
PLAYING AT THESE COLLEGE THAT'S
WHY A LOT OF THESE YOUNG MEN.
LEAVE COLLEGE EARLY FOR
FINANCIAL GAIN I THINK THIS WITH
A SET OF EYES AND TO STAY AND
GRADUATE BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF
THEM DON'T.
DON'T GRADUATE AND I THINK.
I WISH THIS BILL WHEN IT EVEN
FURTHER I WISH YOU GUARANTEE.
ANYONE WHO PLAYS COLLEGE SPORTS.
A CONTINUATION OF EDUCATION AS
LONG AS THEY WANT TO ONE THEY
GOT UNDERGRAD DEGREE GET A
MASTERS DEGREE GET A PHD I THINK
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL FOR LIFE AT THOSE
UNIVERSES WHICH THEY PAY SO.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT AN IRISH
AYE VOTE.
SENATOR TO LETTER.
MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF TWO OH SIX I HAD -- A
QUITE A DEBATE WITH THE THE
AUTHOR JUST THE OTHER DAY WE
WENT BACK AND FORTH BACK AND
FORTH.
AND ON A PERSONAL LEVEL WHY
BECAUSE I HAVE A SON WHO
GRADUATED FROM U. S. SEED PLAYED
ON THE USC FOOTBALL TEAM.
AND HE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PLAY WITH A GREAT USC PLAYERS
AND HE WOULD SHARE STORIES.
HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS FOR SOME OF
THESE PLAYERS AND AND HOW
FORTUNATE MY SON WAS?
AND I JUST HAD A GRANDDAUGHTER
WHO JUST A GRADUATE FROM
SYRACUSE AND SHE WAS ON THE
SOFTBALL TEAM.
AND SHE SHARED ALL HER
OPPORTUNITIES BUT AT THE SAME
TIME ALSO SHARED THOSE WHO
DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY SO I
SEE THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY OF
FAIRNESS REPRESENTATION.
IT WILL OPEN UP THE DOOR FOR THE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN MINORITIES
ESPECIALLY TO BE ABLE TO SEE
REPRESENTATION NOW.
SO THEY COULD CONTINUE MAYBE ON
INTO THE FUTURE SO IT'S A IT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY OUT FOR US TO
OPEN UP THIS DOOR. FOR
OPPORTUNITY AND FAIRNESS IN
ATHLETICS AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND I THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING AT FORT THANK YOU I
SUPPORT THE I BO [inaudible]
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT I
THINK WELL ALL MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BROUGHT UP SOME SOME VERY
GOOD POINTS TODAY.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT OUR OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES THEIR
PRIMARY TASK TO BE TO PROVIDE A
QUALITY EDUCATION FOR OUR KIDS.
AND SECONDARILY -- TO ALLOW THEM.
TO USE THEIR WONDERFUL ATHLETIC --
SKILLS -- THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT MANY OF OUR UNIVERSITIES --
DO VERY WELL WHEN THEY HAVE SOME
LOCAL STARS WHETHER IN
BASKETBALL FOOTBALL TRACK.
WERE YOU BRINGING.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO A
STADIUM IT HELPS FURTHER --
EDUCATION IN THOSE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
THE PROBLEM THAT I SEE WITH THIS
BILL IS IT IS CALIFORNIA CENTRIC.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD BE A BILL
MORE APPROPRIATE TO BE
ENTERTAINED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE NC A A IS A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION THAT APPLIES TO ITS
RULES TO MEMBER INSTITUTIONS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
THE NC A A PROHIBITS A STUDENT
ATHLETE FROM RECEIVING ANY AFTER
BENEFIT.
INCLUDING COMPENSATION
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR SUPPORT.
THE PENALTIES TO THESE.
ATHLETES COULD BE REPAYMENT OF
MONEY.
THE OUT A SPECIFIED NUMBER OF
GAMES OR PERMANENT INELIGIBILITY.
SB TWO OH SIX AS WRITTEN.
WHAT PLACE?
TWENTY ONE OF OUR CAMPUSES.
AND THEIR STUDENT ATHLETES IN
DIRECT CONFLICT WITH AND SEE A A
POLICIES.
ON COMPENSATION MOREOVER.
THE CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIPS TO STUDENTS WHO
WOULD BE INELIGIBLE. TO COMPETE
UNDER NC A A RULES.
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN OUR
STUDENTS AND CAMPUSES BEING
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
IN INTERCOLLEGIATE SPORTS
COMPROMISING IMPORTANT ELEMENT.
OF THE EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
FOR ALL STUDENTS.
THE ORGANS AGAIN MADE TODAY ARE
GOOD.
BUT THEY NEED TO BE UNIVERSALLY
APPLIED.
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
BECAUSE WHAT I SEE IS I'M GOING
TO SEE I THINK WHAT WE'LL SEE IS.
AN ENHANCE COMPETITION
[inaudible] FOR STARTS.
OR FUTURE STARS.
THAT COULD BE COMING AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
AND POTENTIALLY UNDERHANDED WAYS
OF RECRUITING THOSE STUDENTS
[inaudible]
LOS STARTS. TO GO TO OTHER
UNIVERSITIES BOTH WITHIN AND
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR THOSE REASONS.
I THINK WE SHOULD PROCEED
CAUTIOUSLY AND SB TWO OH SIX AND
AT THIS POINT TIMERS CAN OVER.
THANK YOU SENATOR CHANGE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR
BRINGING AFFORD SHE ALSO
MENTIONED THAT A LOT OF THE
ATHLETES ARE WOMEN.
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY I
INTRODUCED A RESOLUTION CALLING
FOR PAY EQUITY IN WOMEN'S SOCCER?
THIS IS A FAIRNESS ISSUE.
YES IT WAS IF IT WAS AT MY
RESOLUTION WAS A FAIRNESS ISSUE
THIS IS A FAIRNESS ISSUE I URGE
AND I VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
YEAH MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW I HAD -- WHEN I FIRST
SAW THIS BILL I HAD THE SAME
CONCERNS IS -- AS THE SENATORS --
FROM -- KERBER AND ALSO FROM --
TEMECULA.
AND I WENT SAW THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY AND TALK THROUGH
THIS ISSUE.
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS NOT -- THIS
IS NOT THE TYPE OF SITUATION
WHERE WE WERE REALLY BEING
PRESCRIPTIVE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
SETTING A MARKER WE'VE HEARD
FROM SO MANY PEOPLE HERE TODAY.
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM AND WE
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM.
AIR THEY HAVING THIS STATE.
SEC FORTY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THREE ALLOWS THE NC DOUBLE A TO
DO THE JOB.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING NOT
JUST FOR CALIFORNIA BUT FOR ALL
OTHER FORTY NINE STATES IN OUR
OUR GREAT UNION.
I DO BELIEVE THOUGH -- THAT --
THAT DON'T YEAH THIS. TO TO THE
COMMENT ON WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN IS GOING TO HAPPEN HIGH
SCHOOLS YEAH WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW A PREP TEAMS.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
SUBJECT THIS HELP WILL HELP SET.
THE BAR I THINK FOR THAT AS WELL
AND THEN ALSO -- FOR MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM -- LOCKING YADA.
I THINK THE FACT THAT HE SAID.
THE STATEMENT HE MADE THAT --
YOU KNOW HE ASSUMES FACTS
WITHOUT EVIDENCE SAYING HE IS
THE BIGGEST SPORTS FAN IN THIS
BUILDING SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
REALLY SENATOR JACKSON'S BOLD.
WELL I WOULD CONTEST SAID TO AND
I HAVE FOLLOWED US SPORTS MY
WHOLE LIFE -- AND IF YOU DO THAT
YOU KNOW THAT COLLEGE SPORTS HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE MOST CORRUPTED
[inaudible]
AS WITH GREAT SCANDALS.
SOME OF THEM RIGHT NOW IN A
DIVERSITY OF ISSUES RELATED TO
OUR STUDENT ATHLETES RELATED TO
SPORTS RELATED -- TO SPORTS
AGENTS.
I THINK IT'S TIME THIS ALL CAME
OUT FROM THE SHADOWS.
AND THAT WE DID PUT SOME RULES
AND REGULATIONS WE KNOW THAT IN
SOME OF THE TOP.
UNIVERSITIES IN FOOTBALL AND
BASKETBALL AND OTHER SPORTS.
THERE ARE EFFORTS AND CREATIVE
EFFORTS I MIGHT SAY. TO TRY TO
CIRCUMVENT THE RULES OF AMATEUR
SPORTS.
WE HAD THAT WITH THE OLYMPICS
UNTIL FINALLY THEY SAID OKAY WE
GIVE UP.
OF WE WE'RE NOT GOING TO INSIST
THAT YOU.
SUBJECT YOURSELF TO A LIFE OF
POVERTY IN ORDER TO COMPETE IN
THE ATHLETICS.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT
SPORTS.
IN COLLEGE SPORTS STARTED TAKING
A REAL HONEST LOOK AT WHAT
ATHLETICS MEAN TO THE SCHOOLS.
WHAT THEY MEAN TO OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES THAT OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENJOY SOME OF THE BENEFITS BUT I
ALSO CAUTION?
THAT UNLESS THERE'S SOME
REGULATION.
AND MANY OF US HERE HAVE HEARD
HORROR STORIES ABOUT SPORTS
AGENTS.
HOW THEY HAVE MANIPULATED
PARTICULARLY YOUNG?
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND YOUNG ATHLETES IN GENERAL.
AND USE THE MEN MANIPULATED THEM
TO THEIR OWN GREED AND ADVANTAGE
LEAVING THOSE STUDENT ATHLETES
OFTENTIMES SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS BEING THROWN OUT OF
SCHOOL.
BECAUSE OF THE EFFORTS OF THESE
AGENTS SO AS WE GO FORWARD AND I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND I HOPE
WE ALL WILL WE ALSO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THERE HAS TO BE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE.%
SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE FROM THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY WILL
EXPERIENCE FROM A YA A WORLD OUT
THERE OF SPORTS AGENTS WHO HAVE
NO RULES NO REGULATIONS -- NO
ETHICAL REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ATHLETES GET.
THE RECOGNITION AND HE VERY --
BENEFITS THAT THEY DESERVE
WITHOUT BEING MANIPULATED AND
USED BY THOSE WHO ARE MORE
SOPHISTICATED IN OTHER TYPES OF
MORE WORLDLY BEHAVIORS CAESAR
ATHLETES AND I CAN SAY I HAVE A
GRANDSON WHO IS.
FINISHING UP. FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
SCHOLARSHIP TO A MAJOR
UNIVERSITY WENT TO THE NC TWO
WAYS AS A STARTING GUARD ON HIS
BASKETBALL TEAM.
THESE KIDS.
AS YOUNG PEOPLE WORK HARD.
THEIR PARENTS WERE CARDS SO THAT
THEY CAN GET THE ADVANTAGES OF
THE CLUBS IN THE KINDS OF
EXPERTISE THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
BECOME GOOD AT WHAT THEY DO.
BUT THEY ARE NOT SOPHISTICATED
IN THE WORLD OUT THERE AND THEY
ARE OFTEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF OF
FORTUNATELY I HAVE A GRANDSON
HE'S GOT A GOOD HEAD ON YOUR
SHOULDERS.
BUT NOT EVERY YOUNG PERSON IS
ABLE TO TRAVERSE THESE VERY
TRICKY WATERS AND SO AS WE GO
FORWARD AS WE GIVE THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
SOME OF THE BENEFITS OF THEIR
HARD WORK IN THEIR TALENT.
WE'VE GOT TO REMEMBER THEY
CANNOT DO THIS ALONE AND WITH
THAT I WOULD -- DRIVE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM BERKELEY FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE UP I I WILL
ADMIT THAT -- WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THE BILL AS IT CAME TO
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OZ THAT'S
KINDA SKEPTICAL ABOUT IT?
I WAS SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE BILL
IT TALK TO ME IN THE COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES ABOUT THIS BILL --
BUT WHEN THEY WERE SITTING
BEFORE US IN EDUCATION COMMITTEE
ASKED THEM I SAID WELL YOU KNOW
YOU YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT YOU
DON'T WANT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WOULD VIOLATE NC DOUBLE A RULES
AND OUT OF COURSE AFFECT JOCK
BUT PROGRAMS BUT YOU INHERENTLY.
AGREE OR DISAGREE WITH WHAT THE
BILL ACTUALLY PROPOSES THAT
ACTUALLY STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE -- TO
BENEFITS -- FOR FROM THEIR OWN
ACTUALLY EFFORTS.
AND FOR MOST PARTY ON THERE MAY
BE SOME TWEAKS OR SOMETHING I
SAID NOW WE DON'T ACTUALLY
DISAGREE WITH THAT AND THEN I
ASK THEM SAID WELL THE NC DOUBLE
A WHICH MAKES THE RULES IS
ACTUALLY A GROUP OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN.
THE BOARD IS COMPOSED OF COLLEGE
PRESIDENTS SO WHAT HAVE YOU DONE
THE CHANGE THAT CIRCUMSTANCE.
IT DIDN'T REALLY HAVE MUCH OF AN
ANSWER TO THAT.
AND SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE SET THIS TABLE I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT IF YOU HAVE
A COLLEGE STUDENT WHO WROTE A
WONDERFUL SONG.
AND IT TOOK OFF ON A STREAMING
SERVICE OR SOMETHING.
ARE THEY WOULD GET ROYALTIES FOR
THAT.
RIGHT -- SOMEONE WHO'S A YOUTUBE
STAR MAY BE DOING I DON'T KNOW
CAUSE MEDICS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
I I WILL TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S ON
YOU TOO BUT THEY COULD PROBABLY
ACTUALLY MONETIZE AND NOT HAVE
TO LEAVE SCHOOL.
RIGHT I MEAN IT'S THEIR CHOICE
WHERE THEY WANT TO OR NOT.
BUT THESE ATHLETES ARE ACTUALLY --
TOLD THAT THEY CANNOT BENEFIT
FROM THEIR OWN IMAGE FROM THERE
AND NOT ONLY DO THEY NOT BENEFIT
FROM IT THE SCHOOL CERTAINLY
BENEFITS FROM IT THE SCHOOL
MARKETS IT HEAVILY.
AND I THINK THIS IS.
FRANKLY UNFAIR AND IN JACK'S --
THROUGH THEIR OWN EFFORTS SO I
AGREE WITH MY BRENDA WHO TALKS
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
WE DO NEED TO HAVE SOME
GUIDELINES RIGHT WE WANT TO SEE
IS TAKING ADVANTAGE OF BUT I
THINK THE IDEA THAT.
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THEIR OWN TALENTS
AND EFFORT.
I JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
ATHLETICS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO CHANGE WE NEED TO
CHALLENGE OUR UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES TO MAKE THAT CHANGE --
AND TO FIGHT FOR THAT AND SO --
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST A CALIFORNIA ISSUES
A BROADER ISSUE.
BUT CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO LEAD WE NEED TO STAND UP FOR
STUDENTS.
THE STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER STUDENTS -- BENEFIT
SENATOR MORE LOCKED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SITE I
AM REALLY ENJOYING THIS DEBATE I
AM NOT A SPORTS GUY BASKETBALLS
FOR CALL PEOPLE [inaudible]
ITEM.
HI MY A I'M WE ARE PART OF THE
STATE LEGISLATIVE BODY I'M NOT
PART OF A NATIONAL.
COLLEGIAN ORGANIZATION SITE I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR IF I COULD JUST TO
CLARIFY.
JUST UNPLUG CENTER SKINNER WILL
YOU ACCEPT QUESTION YES --
MATRICES SENATOR I BEING TOLD --
YOU KNOW THAT.
IF WE IF WE DO SOMETHING UNIQUE
AND DIFFERENT THAT WERE.
WE WE WE WOULD BE TREATED
UNFAVORABLY OR WE COULD BE
PENALIZED.
AND SO WHAT WHAT COULD THE NC A
A DUE TO CALIFORNIA COULD
EXCLUDE THE CAMPUSES IN
CALIFORNIA FROM ITS.
NETWORK OF ORGANIZED SPORTS.
PERMISSION ANSWER THE CONCERN BY
SOME OF OUR PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
COLLEGES IS THAT THE N. C. TWO
WAY.
WOULD -- RETALIATE BECAUSE UNDER
THIS BILL IF STUDENTS WERE Q.
AND BE ABLE TO GAIN SOME
EARNINGS OFF THEIR IMAGE OR
LIKENESS THAT THAT WOULD BE A
VIOLATION OF THE RULES THAT THE
AND SEE TO A HAS PUT INTO PLACE.
NOW THE BILL IS EXPLICITLY%
WRITTEN. TO IN FACT -- DIRECT.
WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE THE
JURISDICTION OVER THE NC TWO
WEIGH.
IT DEFINITELY ADDS PROTECTIONS
TO THE COLLEGES BUT EFFICIENCY
TO A WERE TO CHOOSE TO THAT
COULD CONCEIVABLY HAPPEN.
BUT I THINK THE BENEFIT OF THE
BOTH THE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
AND THE FACT THAT WILL AND I
WILL GIVE THIS INFORMATION TO MY
CLOTHES THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
OTHER FRONTS.
NOW INFLUENCING THE NC TWO EIGHT
TO MOVE IN THIS DIRECTION I FEEL
THAT.
OUR WHATEVER FEARS OUR PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC COLLEGES MAY HAVE.
ON MAY PROVE TO BE ON WARRANTED.
SO WE HAVE A CHESS GAME GOING ON
AND WE'RE MAKING A POTENTIAL
MOVE.
AND IF THE NC A A SAYS FINE YOU
TAKE THAT POSITION WE WILL
EXCLUDE CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES
[inaudible]
FROM OUR CALENDAR.
THEN WHAT WOULD THAT DO TO THE
POTENTIAL SPONSORSHIPS.
OF THE STUDENTS WERE TRYING
[inaudible]
TO ASSIST.
THIS IS SPECULATIVE -- AND
CERTAINLY -- WE HAS THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MODIFY.
OUR LAWS IF THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE THINK ARE --
WOULD SERIOUSLY IMPACT.
BUT AS I INDICATED THERE IS
ENOUGH MOMENTUM AROUND THIS
ISSUE AND ANY OF US WHO ARE
SPORTS FANS YOU WILL NOTICE THAT --
IT IS ONE OF THE MORE POPULAR
TOPICS ON ESPN.
IT HAS BEEN NOW FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS.
OKAY.
THEN -- I HAD A FEW MORE
QUESTIONS BUT MAYBE IT JUST
BRING IT DOWN TO THE LAST ONE IF
WE DO JEOPARDIZE.
OUR STATE'S INVOLVEMENT IN THE
NC DOUBLE A WITH THAT ENCOURAGE
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA.
RESIDENTS TO GO TO SCHOOLS IN
OTHER STATES AND THEIR THEIR
POOR JEOPARDIZE OUR SYSTEM.
I I'M CONSUMER MAYBE MAYBE TO
RHETORICAL QUESTION ADDRESSED
IT'S RHETORICAL.
WHAT KIDS WITHIN UP IT ON MY OWN
TIME?
THAT A PRESIDENT JUST.
ARE YOU I LOVE LEVERAGE I LOVE.
TRYING.
TO NEGOTIATE IT WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF PRESSURE BUT I I I I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M COMFORTABLE
[inaudible]
RISKING.
THE THE POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR KIDS IN OUR SCHOOLS IN OUR
COLLEGES I SUB STILL WORKING
THIS THROUGH AND I'LL LOOK FOR
TO MORE DEBATE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SENATOR SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
THANKS SO MUCH SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS -- THE
DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD ON THE
FLOOR I WOULD NOTE -- MY CO
AUTHOR OF THE SENATOR FROM
GARDENIA.
POINTING OUT THAT OUR HIGHEST
PAID STATE EMPLOYEES IN ANY FOR
US CAN GO ON TO THE SECOND BE
AND FIND THE DIRECTORY THAT
SHOWS THE HIGHEST PAID STATE
EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE.
OUR COACHES COLLEGE COACHES AND
ATHLETIC DIRECTORS.
I'M IN YET WE DO WE THE ONLY
CATEGORY OF STUDENTS THE ONLY.
THAT WE WOULD PREVENT FROM BEING
ABLE TO GAIN ANY EARNING FROM
THE INCREDIBLE TALENT THAT THEY
BRING.
IS STUDENT ATHLETES NOW I KNOW
THE CONCERN THAT OUR COLLEGES
MAY MAY SUFFER CONSEQUENCE.
BUT THIS THIS DISCUSSION IT'S
LIKE SO MANY THINGS I AM NOT THE
FIRST INTRODUCED THIS AT OUR
ACTION WOULD REALLY BE FOLLOWING
A LONG TRADITION AND BE MORE
RESPONSIVE THAN SO MUCH.
THAT WERE THE THE HARBINGERS
RIGHT IT'S MORE RESPONSIVE
BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN
DISCUSSIONS IN BILLS OF A
SIMILAR NATURE.
IN BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST YES THEY
DID NOT PROCEED BUT THE SET THE
STAGE FOR THIS BROADER
CONVERSATION TO THE POINT NOW
WHERE AS I MENTIONED IF YOU
LISTEN TO ESPN OR WATCH THE
COLLEGE IT WHETHER IT'S MARCH
MADNESS.
OR THE AT VARIOUS BOWL GAMES
DURING THE FOOTBALL SEASON AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN PLAYERS
COMMENTATORS FORMER PLAYERS.
BRING UP THIS SUBJECT AND I
HIGHLY RECOMMEND THE DOCUMENTARY
THE STUDENT ATHLETE THAT IS ON
HBO RIGHT NOW.
NOW CALIFORNIA WOULD HOPEFULLY
NOT BE ACTING ALONE AT THIS
MOMENT BECAUSE THERE IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL IN CONGRESS
RIGHT NOW.
INTRODUCED BY CONGRESS MEMBERS
WALKER ENRICHMENT.
AND THERE ARE OTHER STATES WHO
ARE LOOKING AT LEGISLATION AND
ENTERTAINING LEGISLATION JUST
LIKE OURS.
AND HOPEFULLY THEY WILL ACT IN
ADDITION TO US GIVING MORE
INSURANCE TO OUR COLLEGES BUT
LET US FINALLY SAY THE POINT
THAT MY COLLEAGUE THE SUIT
MADE.
IT IS COLLEGES THAT MAKE UP THE
BOARD OF THE NC TWO WAY.
DATE CAN PLAY A LEADERSHIP ROLE
AND GET THE NC TWO EIGHT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND CHANGE THEIR
RULES WE WOULD ONLY BE HELPING
THEM TO DO SO.
AND SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
BY CAMBIADO HI.
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DOT [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO HI FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH.
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
NO NUMBER.
BOB I. CASKEY.
I WIENER AYE WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MORE LUCK. FIVE THIRTY ONE KNOWS
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS MOVING BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE A SHERIFF MIKE
BOUDREAUX THAT FROM TULARE
COUNTY WHO IS HERE -- ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR GROVER -- AND HE IS
ACCOMPANIED BY A SHERIFF'S FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE SO IF YOU'RE
STILL HERE WELCOME.
WERE HAPPY TO SEE YOU HERE TODAY
AND ALSO.
AND ALSO ADAM AND STRIPES BILL
FROM THE PILES BOYS CAMP WHO IS
HERE AS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
THE BIG SENATE WELCOME.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT WE
JUST HAVE A COUPLE MORE THINGS
WE NEED TO FINISH -- THE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER THREE
AND LEFT THE CALL.
ON ITEM NUMBER THREE AND NUMBER
FIVE WILL START WITH ITEM NUMBER.
THREE PLEASE.
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS BY [inaudible]
JANE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ROVE [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
JACKSON I STONE I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ICE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED -- THE
NEXT APPOINTMENT IS ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GROVE [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [naudible]
MITCHELL A THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
THEN MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE AND
NOW SINCE.
ARE THERE.
ANY MEMBERS IT HAVE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE SENATOR
MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH REGARD
TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS -- I
WOULD ASK THAT EVERY MEMBER OF
THE SENATE BUDGET REVIEW
COMMITTEE BE IN THE HEARING ROOM
BY THREE FIFTEEN THE LIKE THE
GAVEL DOWN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. THREE FIFTEEN A
BELIEVER IN HEARING ROOM. FORTY
TWO OH THREE TWENTY THREE
FIFTEEN THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
CENTER -- SENATOR DODD.
YES MADAM PRESIDENT TO I'D LIKE
TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS JOIN
INFO HEARING REGARDING HORSES
AND HORSE RACING.
WILL BE HELD AT THREE PM.
IN ROOM.
FOUR TWO OH TWO SEEING NO
FURTHER MEDIA ANNOUNCEMENTS OR
ASSIGNMENTS.
MADAM PRO TEM.
THE DESK IS CLEAR THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT -- COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
THIRTY ONE SENATE ITEMS TODAY.
A NUMBER OF THOSE ITEMS TOOK A
LITTLE TIME SO WE DID GET.
A GOOD AMOUNT OF WORK DONE TODAY
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
ITEMS REMAINING OF WHICH WE
ANTICIPATE.
A GOOD NUMBER WILL LIKELY BE ON
CONSENT BY THE END OF THIS WEEK.
SO WE ARE DOING QUITE WELL BUT
WE NEED TO STAY DILIGENT AND
FOCUSED AND TRY TO GET WORK DONE.
AND WITH THAT MADAM PRESIDENT --
WE WILL RECONVENE ON THURSDAY
MAY TWENTY THIRD THAT IS
TOMORROW AT TEN AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE AND WE WILL
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
TEN AM